hey guys welcome to this full course
video on javascript
this video will cover all the
fundamental topics of javascript
now javascript is a powerful client-side
scripting language
it is used mainly for enhancing the
interaction of a user with the web page
in other words you can make your web
page more lively and interactive with
the help of this language so if you love
web development then you're in the right
place
so here's a list of topics covered
first we look at a simple hello world
application in javascript
then we'll understand javascript in 10
minutes
we'll move on to topics like arrays
loops objects functions closure promises
and async await then we learn about
javascript this keyword javascript form
validation regular expressions and email
validation we'll then look at a simple
tutorial on javascript dom
next we'll understand the javascript
learning path and how you can become a
full stack developer moving on we'll
look at some important javascript
interview questions that will help you
crack your next interview and lastly
coming to the most fun part we'll build
javascript projects now in this section
we'll be building five projects starting
from beginner level projects like a
to-do list quiz app and a calculator app
and then we'll move on to more advanced
apps like weather app a tic-tac-toe game
and a snake game application
now i'm sure you're excited to dive deep
into it so let's begin
in this video we will learn all about
javascript and write our first program
using this language
what's in it for you now we'll start by
understanding what javascript actually
is
then we will get to know why it is so
popular these days and lastly we will
write our first program in javascript
which will print hello world in the
browser window
so what is javascript
javascript is a dynamic computer
programming language which is
lightweight and object oriented
now the best part about javascript is
the fact that it's open source and is
cross-platform compatible meaning one
piece of code written in any system
regardless of the operating system
functions the same in other operating
systems as well
lastly most commonly used is a part of
web pages that allows client-side script
to interact with the user and make
dynamic pages
now moving on to the next important
question why javascript
now being the most popular language in
the world javascript has a huge fan base
and benefits from a large community
support
javascript is now being used in many
industrial fields such as web
development mobile application
development and also game development it
is very diverse in nature
there are great career opportunities for
javascript developers as this technology
seems to be holding on its own when
compared to other languages
all right now moving on let's go ahead
and execute a simple program
to understand javascript better
so we'll go ahead and execute a simple
hello world program
all right for that first thing you need
is a text editor in this case we've used
the vf code editor
so now let's go to our
text editor that is vs code and here
let's open a file
you say
file
and now you can uh type in your code
here so we will have to add the
javascript to the html code and then
print out the words hello world on the
browser window right that's our
objective so let's add the html
boilerplate in this file
so let's type in
html
this is our tag
and then next we have the body tag
so within the body tag
we can add the script tag to insert the
javascript into html page right so we
say script
language
equals javascript
and type
equals
text
slash
javascript
all right
let's close the tag
and then
in the script we call a javascript
function that is document.write which
writes the string to our html page
right so we say document
dot write
and then braces we say hello world
okay and now we close the tags
you also close the body
and finally touch
all right
now when we save the file
we're going to save it say on my desktop
and i'm going to call it index dot html
right so make sure the extension is html
and then save it
and that is already exists
i say replace it
and now once you save it as an html file
you can see that the colors have
appeared so any errors will be easily
indicated here
so now let me save this and now let's go
ahead and execute the file that is
stored
so let me go back
to my desktop
and here i have index.html
there you go when you click on the file
it opens in your browser
and you can see the words hello world
now javascript is one of the most
important languages today
the rise of internet has helped
javascript scale to a stellar level
so in this video i'm going to introduce
javascript to you first let's have a
look at a brief history of javascript
javascript was written in 10 days by
brendan ike in 1995. he was working at
netscape at the time and was
implementing java the hot buzzword for
the browser later he developed a more
easy to use programming language called
mocha the idea was to make java
available for big professional component
writers while moca would be used for
small scripting tasks
moca was later renamed to javascript
now in 2009 node.js was released this
allowed programmers to write full
applications in javascript npm was also
created for installing reusable bits of
code in libraries
so moving on what exactly is javascript
javascript is a server side and
client-side programming language it is
commonly used to create web applications
now all of these applications in
javascript can be seen in diverse fields
like gaming web development
server development robotics among others
popular javascript libraries and
frameworks like react.js and angular
have skated tremendously in the past few
years
moving ahead let me show you a simple
demo to implement a few concepts of
javascript
let's head to vs code for this all right
so back in my vs code i've created a
folder called demo underscore js within
which i created a file for variables
which is the html file all right i've
also added the initial code for it with
the title tag and the
heading tag and now within the script
i'm going to define my variables so here
let me say
that the keyword where and say x equals
now
javascript is loosely typed and also all
these variables can be declared
as and when they're being used all right
so with this variable i can just print
it out let me say document
dot write
x
all right so let's go and
open the file
all right so here you can see the
heading has been displayed with the
value of x that is 5.
now we can also perform various actions
on these variables so let me say
variable y equals
and then let's say variable sum equals x
plus y
and here let me just output the sum
have a look at the browser
it displays eight
all right so now let's go ahead and
create another html file to understand
how arrays work in javascript so let's
say
arrays.html
all right let me just copy the initial
code for the same
all right i've added the initial code
for it and now let's go ahead and create
an array
[Music]
so here let me say let i'm going to
create an array of cars so let's say
cars
within which
i say bmw
and then i say volvo
[Music]
and then i say honda
all right
so we successfully created an array now
we can just output it using console log
say console log
cars of
0 which indicates the
value of the array at the position index
at the index position 0.
similarly
let's just say console.log
cars
all right
so when we
save it and then execute it let's see
let's have a look at the browser
you can see it's displayed bmw which was
at the index position 0 and then it's
displayed honda which was at the index
position 2.
now let's display the length of the
array so for that we can make use of the
len property and say cars dot length
here
and after this we'll just
console log it
so let's say
len all right so when we have a look at
the browser
we have three here which indicates the
length of our array now we can also
perform other actions like looping over
it so let's have a look at
javascript loops
so i'm going to create another file here
and say
loops
dot html
[Music]
so i've also added the initial code now
so now let's first look at the simple
for loop
so here
let me say
let me create a variable called n
all right and then
i'll say document.write
let's display a simple message saying
the numbers are
all right and
let me just break the line
all right now to display the numbers
from 0 to 9 i'm just going to use the
for loop same for n equals 0
and less than 10
and plus plus
and then i'm going to display the values
so i say document.right
n and let's just give a space between
the numbers
so yeah
all right so now when we have a look at
the browser you can see it says
the numbers are and it displays the
digits 0 to 9.
now let's look at another example for
loops so i'm going to create another
script tag
and now let me just say document dot
right
now i'm just gonna you know add space
add two lines from the previous one so
let me just
add these first
all right and now let's say let
y equals i'm gonna create an array
so let's say 2 4 6 8
12 and 14
yeah and then let's say
i'm going to create an index variable
that is i i equals 0
to length
equals y dot length
and sum equals 0
[Music]
and i less than length
i plus plus so here i've just created
three different variables and
initialized them here so i've created an
index variable i
a length variable for length and then we
have the sum variable that records the
sum of the array and then i've made sure
that the variable i is less than the
length and then i use the increment
operator so now let's save
sum plus
equals y of i
and then say document
dot
write
the sum is
sum
all right so let's
save and execute this
so here you can see that the sum 56 is
being displayed so this is how you make
use of loops you can also use the while
loop however i'm not going to get into
the details of it i'm going to help you
understand how functions in javascript
work so i'll say
functions.html
and let me also add the initial code
all right so now one thing to remember
is that there are various ways to define
a function in javascript however in this
video i'm going to show you two
different methods one is using the
function constructor and the other one
is using functions expressions now when
it comes to function constructor we make
use of the function keyword and the new
keyword all right so now let's just see
how it works so let's say where
my function
equals new
and the function keyword here which is
the constructor
i say function within this i'm going to
define my function so i'm just making
use of the simple sum function that adds
two numbers
so let's say a
and b these two are the parameters and
when i'm returning it i say return
a plus b
all right first let me define the
variables
so now when i call function i say
variable x
equals
my function
and i'm going to pass the digits let's
say 2 comma 3
all right
and now let's say let and now let's
display it so
demo if you've seen i've created an id
called demo here so i can make use of
that here
and i say dot inner html
[Music]
the sum is
x
all right so now let's save it and have
a look at the browser
you can see the sum 5 is being displayed
so now let me show you how to create a
function using function expressions
so let me create another
script tag
all right and now let me say variable y
equals
function
and the parameters that i'm going to be
passing are a comma b
and when i'm defining the function
i say return
a plus b
so what we're doing here is that the
function expression is being stored in a
variable and this variable can be used
anywhere in your script all right so now
uh
let's say
x
equals
y of 8
comma 5
all right and then let's just
display the value of x
[Music]
all right so now let's have a look at
the browser
you can see this place 13. in this video
we will be learning all about javascript
arrays and the popular methods of the
array object
so what's in it for you we'll start by
understanding what a javascript array is
then we will get to know about the
operations that we are performing on the
array
after that we'll get familiar with some
of the most used array methods
and lastly we'll go through map reduce
and filter functions
so what exactly is an array
now an array object lets you store
multiple values in a single variable
it stores a fixed size sequential
collection of elements of the same type
now an array is used to store a
collection of data and it uses only
integers as element indices
however associative areas can also use
string indices
moving on let's understand what area
operations are
now we can perform various operations on
an array in javascript
but let's start by creating an array
so for that let's go ahead and create a
folder first which will consist of the
file that we're creating right so for
that
let me just uh go ahead and create a
folder
and i'll call it demo underscore adding
so once you're done with that open your
visual studio code editor
and here say open folder
and click on demo array
okay it's creating the workbench all
right and now here you can see
the new file icon so go ahead
and create
demo.html file
all right here you go now let's start
typing the code
the first thing we do is type in our
html tag
and here i have the head tag
and let me say javascript
tutorial
all right and now let's create the body
tag
now within the body tag i create a
paragraph tag
and create an id
and let me call it
demo
and then close the tag now i'll explain
to you why we're doing this a little
later
so first let's go ahead and create the
script tag
so say script
and within the script let's create our
array so let me use the keyword let
and say we give the name of the array
cars
equals in square base braces
we say bmw
and
volvo
[Music]
and then say
honda all right so now we create an
array now one more thing is that we use
the keyword let so that which indicates
that the array can be changed throughout
the program
all right so now we go ahead and display
it so
i say document
dot get element by id
and here i say now the id
created was demo so i say demo here
and i use the dot
inner html property
which is equal to cars
okay let me change this to bmw first
all right so what exactly in or html
does is that it is responsible for what
is being displayed on the web page
okay now since we've taken id as demo
any changes made is reflected in this id
and then displayed onto the web browser
all right so let's save this and now
execute the file
so here i go back to my folder and then
to the file and go ahead and click on it
so there you go
the heading is displayed and the entire
array is displayed here
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
okay so i hope this was easy to
understand
now let's go ahead
so the next operation is to access an
array element
so let's go back to our vs code
and here let's create another variable
say let bmw bmw's variable don't get
confused with the array element
so bmw equals
cars
of the index 0.
so basically
cars of 0 is nothing but
bmw all right so that is being saved in
the variable bmw
and now let's just go ahead and display
this
so let's just copy this
and paste it here and instead of cars
you use the variable name bmw that is
this one
all right
so now let's save this
and when we
execute it
you see bmw here
that's how you retrieve an element from
an array
next up we have the array length
property which displays the length of
the array so again let me show you how
to do that let's go back to our code
and here
let's create a variable and let's call
it length variable so i say let l e n
equals cars dot left
now you can use the length property
which will retrieve the length of the
array for us it's as simple as that
and now after this
again let's just
copy the same
code here and then
let's
pass len
okay
now let's save this
and when you execute it again
it says three
so we've successfully retrieved the
length of the array
all right so the next operation is to
access the last array element right so
let's go back to our vs code
and now let's create another variable
and let's call it last
and we'll just say last equals cars
and within square braces cars dot length
minus 1
right
so basically
the length of the array is 3 and 3 minus
1 is 2 so it should retrieve
cars of 2 which is honda right
so let's just
execute this let me pass last here
save it and see if it displays honda for
us
there you go
it's as simple as that
all right so moving on
the next array operation is loop over an
array item
so for that let's go to our
code
and here
let's use the for loop so i say cars
dot
for each
and within this
we'll say
item
comma index
comma array
and now we use the arrow function
and display the content on the console
so i say console.log
of item
along with its index
so let's save this
and now let's go ahead and execute it
all right now as you can see nothing is
printed on your web page right because
whatever is being printed has to be
printed in your console so now click on
f12 which opens the developer options
and here you can see console so click on
that and now you can see the name of the
item in the array along with its index
so you see bmw 0 volvo 1 and honda 2.
all right
so moving on
now that we've learnt about the array
operations let's go ahead and learn
about the array methods
so the first method is tostring now as
the name suggests it is used to convert
an array into a string
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
and now
let's copy the same
code here
and here instead of last i just say
cars dot
to string
now you can use this method
to convert the array into a string so
let's save this
and let's execute it all right
now here the same output is shown
which means that the type has only been
changed to string type
all right moving on
the next method is pop now pop basically
removes the last element from the array
so let me show you how that works
let's go back to our vs code and here
we have to save
the pop element into a variable right so
let's create a variable say last
okay and oh since last is already used
let me call it last one
[Music]
last one of cars dot pop
and you can use the pop method to pop
the element
and now you can just
copy the same code
to display this onto our web page
and here
i just
say last one
now
since we've popped the last element the
array has only two elements right that
is bmw and volvo so if you want to
display the last element it should
display volvo right so what we can do is
we can just create another variable say
last two
and just
use the same logic here
okay
and now let's just
display it on your console and let's say
last two all right
so now let's save it
now the popped element has been saved in
last one which is displayed on the web
page and the last element of the array
after the pop function has to be
displayed on our console
so let's go ahead and execute the file
all right so honda has been displayed
that is the element that has been
removed from the array
and now once we check our console
here you go here you can see volvo
which means that is the last element in
the array
moving on
the next method is the push method now
as the name suggests it is used to add a
new element to the array and remember to
the end of the array so let's go back to
our vs code
and here let me say cars
dot push
push is the method that we're using
inside of which we'll say
audi all right
and now let's just display the same
things so let me copy this
and here let me say
cars
okay so let me save it
and once i execute it
it says bmw volvo and audi so we've
successfully added another element to
the end of the array
so the next method is the shift method
now basically shift is used to remove
the first element from the array
now this method shifts all the elements
reducing the indexes of every element by
one all right let me show you how this
works
so let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just say cars
dot shift
it's as simple as that
and let's just display this let me copy
the same thing
let's save it
and when we execute it
here you can see it just displays volvo
and audi so now cars has array elements
volvo and od
with array indices 0 and 1.
all right so moving on the next method
is unshift
all right so to add an element into the
beginning of an array we use the unshift
method
therefore this method increases the
array index by one
right so let's go back to our vs code
and use the same function
unshift
let's say cars dot unshift
and here we go let's
save it and here we have to specify what
we're adding right let me say hyundai
okay
let's save this
and when we execute it
you can see hyundai volvo and audi
as simple as that
all right moving on the next method is
the concat method now this is basically
used to merge two different areas
right so let's go back to our vs code
ensure
let's create another array first
and let's just call the array
bikes
okay
and let's create say
yamaha
and
let's say suzuki
and then we'll say royal enfield okay
and now
let's save this
and say let
vehicles this is another array which is
basically the after concatenation
the entire array is saved into this
array all right so let's say cars.concat
of bikes we just concat bikes and cars
together
okay and then let's just
display this over the web page
let me change this to vehicles
all right
let me save this
so let's go ahead and execute it
there you go now both the areas have
been merged together into a single array
so the next array method is the sort
method
now basically sort is used to sort the
entire array into ascending order
all right so let's go back to our editor
and here
let's just use the
sort method on the
array vehicles all right
vehicles dot
sort okay
and
let's just
display this on our web page
so
again let's go back and
execute it and here you can see it has
been sorted
the next method
is the reverse method so the reverse
method is again used to reverse the
elements in an array so it's logic right
so sort was used to sort it in ascending
order now when you reverse it it just
sorts it in this ascending order
so let's go back here
i'm going to copy the same thing
all right and here instead of sort
let me just say reverse
so let's save this and execute it
there we go
it has displayed the entire array in the
reverse order
all right
with that we finished the array methods
next up we have map reduce and filter
first up we have array.map
now the map method is used for creating
a new array from an existing one by
applying a function to each and every
one of the elements in the first array
and it does not change the original
array all right so to make you
understand this better let's go back to
our
visual studio code
and now here let's first create another
area
okay so let me call this num1
and let's have
integers let's say 2 3 4 5
6 and 7
okay
and now let's have another array
num2
so let's go ahead and say num1
dot
map
of let me define a function
say multiply
okay
so multiply is the function that is that
i'm going to define here
so let's say function
multiply
of value
okay
and inside this let me say return
value
into two
okay
so what this basically does
is that it multiplies each and every
element of the array num1 by 2 and saves
the new elements into the array num2
okay
now after this
let's go ahead and
display the content so let me copy this
and let's display the content
in the array num2
right so let me save it let's go back
here
execute it
so there you go
every element has been multiplied by 2
and then displayed again
i hope this was clear for you
now the next method is the filter method
so the filter method takes each element
in an array and applies a conditional
statement against it
and if this condition returns true the
element gets pushed onto the output
array but if it returns false the
element does not get pushed
all right so let me show it to you
now
let's
go ahead and create another
variable
say num3
and here i say num1
dot
filter
of say com
now comp is a function
let me define the function here
let me say function
comp
of value
takes a value as a parameter
within which i am going to check
if the value is greater than 4
now it only appends the element into the
array num3 if the value is greater than
all right
so now let me just
go ahead and change this to num3
all right
let's save this
and when we go back and execute
here we go
now the values so let's go back here let
me check
now num1 had the values 2 3 4
six and seven right so according to this
it has to only display five six and
seven do not get confused with num2 here
we've passed num1 here so it checks for
this array
right
so according to the logic it should
display 5 6 and 7
and it has done so here
okay
moving on
the next method
is the reduce method
now the reduced method reduces an array
of values down to just one single value
now to get the output value it runs a
reducer function to each element of that
array
okay now this method does not reduce the
original array again
so let's go back to our vs code
now let me create
another
variables in num4
and say num1 dot reduce
and let me call it sum
so what we're basically doing is that
we're adding all the digits 2 3 4 5 6
and 7 in num1 to a single value right
that is the sum and then we're going to
be displaying that
so what we're going to do is let's
define the function here
function sum
basically is total comma value
right
and then here let's say return
total
plus
the value
okay
and after this
i'm going to
display the content so let's say num 4
okay
let's
save it
go back and execute
here we go it displaces some of the
entire values in the array
in this video we're learning all about
javascript loops
so we're going to be covering topics
like for loop
while loop which also includes the do
while loop and then we're going to learn
about breaking out of a loop and then
we'll see how to skip a loop cycle
before proceeding make sure you
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
now before jumping into the for loop
let's first understand what exactly a
loop is
right so a loop is basically a
programming construct that executes a
piece of code as long as a certain
condition is met
all right and there are two different
types of loops we have entry control
loops and exit control loops now what
exactly are entry control loops now
these are the loops where the test
condition is checked before executing
the piece of code
for example you have the for loop and
the while loop so in their case before
entering the loop
the condition is checked and only if the
condition is met it enters the loop and
executes the code all right when it
comes to exit control loops the test
condition is checked after the loop has
been executed
all right so in this case the loop at
least gets executed i mean the code in
the loop gets executed at least once
so the example for this is a two while
loop
all right with this basic knowledge
let's go ahead and learn about the
different loops
so the first loop is the for loop all
right
so what exactly is a for loop this is
the basic logic and the flowchart in
front of you so what exactly happens is
that say for example you want to print
the word looping
say 10 times right so what you can do is
you can start and you can have a for
loop which goes from 0 to 9
and then you increase the number by 1
every time you print the loop
once it's equal to 10 or even greater
than 10 it ends the loop
right
so let me help you understand this
better with an example so let's go to
our editor that is vs code
here i've created a folder called demo
underscore loops within which i created
a file called for loops
all right
so now let's just write down our initial
code for html that is
html
and then i have a head tag
[Music]
within which i say javascript
loops
all right
now i have a body tag
[Music]
within which i give a heading for
clearer understanding let me have a
heading say
javascript
[Music]
for loops
all right
let me just call it for loop
now let's have the script tag
[Music]
within which
i'll have a variable say x
and now we have the for loop so we say
for
x equals
x less than
x plus plus
within which i say console.log
of x
so basically
what happens is
now you have the first variable which is
called the counter variable now this
keeps track of how many times the code
is being executed
right and next i less than 5 is a
condition now
the loop keeps executing as long as the
condition is meant
and lastly the counter variable is
incremented and usually it's incremented
by one
right so here we've done the same thing
and
inside the loop we print the value of x
all right so let me save the file
and then execute it
all right it's printed javascript loops
here let me just go back
okay my bad i missed out on the title
tag
so this has to be enclosed within the
title tag
so let me just
change it here
now let's save this
let's go back and just refresh the page
and that is it so whatever is in the
title tag basically appears here all
right so now since we're printing the
value of x on our console we have to
inspect our element so let's go here
and here let's check on console
and here you can see all the values have
been printed from 0 to 4.
all right now this is a simple for loop
so next up is a while loop
now the logic is similar to that of a
for loop so first the condition is
checked and if the condition holds true
then the code is executed and if it is
false it terminates
all right so moving on let's understand
the general syntax
so here first you have the variable
whose value keeps changing
and then you have the ending condition
which is basically the maximum value a
variable can reach all right so let's go
back to our vs code
and here for better understanding let me
just change this to
javascript while loop
all right let's just
delete this and here let's initialize
the value of x to 1
and now i say while
x
less than or equal to 5
within braces i say console.log
of x
and then i increment the value of x
all right so let me save this
and let's execute the file
all right so it says javascript while
loop and let's inspect
and here in our console it displays the
values of x right so according to the
logic
x is initially initialized to 1
and the value
gets executed once it enters the while
loop
all right it's incremented and then
checked every time
until the value reaches
6 right and then it breaks from the loop
since the value does not hold true and
then it terminates
so this is a logic behind the while loop
next up is the two while loop
now here
as you can see
first the code is executed and then the
condition is checked if the condition is
true then the code execution continues
and if it falls it's terminated
all right so this is an exit control
loop
also in an exit control loop
the code is executed at least once
so let's go back to our vs code
and here
let me just delete this
now let's initialize x to say
15 all right
and now i use the do keyword
within which i write the code
so first i'm going to print the value of
x
console
dot log of x
and then i increase my value
and here i mention my test condition
which is while
x
less than say 10
all right so according to the logic
initially the value is x
and once it enters the loop
here
it should print the value of x which is
all right and then it increments the
value but once it comes out of the loop
it checks for the condition
here the condition says less than 10 but
since x is not less than 10 it prints
the value x that is 15 and then
terminates
all right so let's save this
and execute it
so let me execute this
and here
let's check
the console
so there we go it prints 15. so what it
does is that it prints the value 15
first and then checks the condition
now
let's go ahead and change the value of x
to say
all right
so now it enters a loop
and then it prints the value of x and
then increments it
and when it comes out of the loop and
checks the condition
as long as the value of x remains less
than 10 it prints it
okay
so let's save this
go back here
and let's refresh the page
and here you can see the values 5 to 9
are printed so this is how the do-while
loop works
moving on to the next concept
breaking out of a loop
now as the name suggests break is the
keyword that is used to break out of a
loop
now here is a simple code for you
so according to the logic it prints the
values
between 1 to 10
and say at the value 5 you want to break
out of the loop you can simply use the
keyword break so let's go back to our vs
code
and here
let me just
make it simple
unsaved
or
x equals 1
x less than or equal to 10
let's increment it
and within the loop
let's
display the value x
on the console and then
we're going to check for the condition
if x equals 5.
all right
so if x equals 5
we break out of the loop
so let's save the file and execute it
and there you go it's displayed the
values from 1 to 5.
so basically the code inside the for
loop is executed and once the value of x
reaches 5 it breaks from the loop
simple right
all right so let's move on
next up we have skipping a loop cycle
all right so here
what exactly we do is we make use of a
keyword continue to skip a particular
loop cycle
say in this case we have a for loop
which displays the values of i
ranging from 1 to 10
however we want to skip the cycle when
it reaches the value 3. so what we do is
we make use of the keyword continue here
so basically it displays one and two and
skips the third cycle and then directly
displays four
all right so let me show you in our
vs code editor
here
let me just remove this and save
if
x equals
i'm going to continue
all right
after which
i'm going to say console
dot log of x
so let me save this
and then execute it
so here
let me refresh the page
and there we go
as you can see it displays one two three
and four and the fifth cycle
is skipped
all right and the rest of the digits are
displayed so that is how you can skip a
loop
i highly suggest you also practice all
of this and then play around with loops
to get a better understanding
so taking a step forward we're going to
learn about javascript objects in this
video
first we'll start by understanding what
a javascript object is
then we learn how to create a javascript
object and also get to know about the
properties of these objects
after that we'll get familiar with using
javascript methods lastly we'll
understand what javascript accessors are
so what is a javascript object
javascript is an object-oriented
programming language so everything in
java is an object
a javascript object is like a real-world
entity having state and behavior for
example a car
now we can take a car as an object it
will have its state like color and model
it will also have behaviors like
accelerate and break
javascript is template based and we can
create objects without having the need
to create a class
generally object is accompanied by a
class that defines an object's
blueprints but javascript doesn't
require any class to be defined for
objects
moving on to the next concept
to create a javascript object
now basically there are three different
ways of creating a javascript object all
right so we look at them one by one
the first one is to use a literal to
create and define a javascript object
so let's go to our vs code editor
now if you have any doubts regarding the
initial setup then i suggest you go
through the previous video that is
javascript arrays
to get you started with it so here i
have created a folder called demo
objects
and now i'm going to create a file
called
create
underscore objects
dot html
all right
so we'll begin by writing the initial
code
that is the head and the body so i say
html
[Music]
but in this i
create the head tag
[Music]
and then i create a title tag
and let's say
javascript
objects
then after the head tag i'm going to
create a body tag
and
let's create a heading and say
creating javascript
objects
okay
and now we create
an id
all of this is explained in the previous
video i really suggest you go through
the video before hand so that you get a
clear picture
and then i say id equals
say demo
and then i'm gonna close it
now the first method that we're going to
use to create an object is by using
object literals
right
so what we can do is say script
within which i declare a variable
say
where student
now within the object we're going to
create three different properties now
this is basically like a dictionary it
has a property a key and then a value
okay so i say name
property
and let's say
chris
and then another property say age and
say 21
and another property say
studies
and say maybe computer science
[Music]
okay
so this is the syntax used to
create an object using an object
literally
now after this what we're going to do is
we're going to display this right now we
want to display the message saying chris
of age 21 studies computer science
so what we can do is say document dot
get element by id
and the id that we're going to pass is
demo
and we say
in
html
equals
student dot name
which is chris
after which we display the message
of the age
[Music]
and then the age that is student dot age
studies
student
dot
studies
okay let's save this
and when we
execute the file it says chris of the
age 21 studies computer science
all right this is one of the ways in
which you can define an object
all right so moving on to the next way
of creating a javascript object it is to
use the new keyword now this is the most
traditional way of creating an object
right so let's go back to our vs code
let's create another script
within which we say
where student
equals new
object
i'm sure everybody has learned the same
way the same syntax
so
this is one of the ways
after which we can say student top name
equals
chris
again student dot age
equals 21
[Music]
and then
student dot
studies
equals computer science
[Music]
all right
now after this we again
display the message so let me just copy
this
[Music]
all right
so let's save this
and run our code again
and there we go it displays the message
chris of the h21 studies computer
science
all right this was the second method
used to create an object
all right so then moving on to the third
method
it is to use an object constructor to
create and define a javascript object
so let's go back to our code editor
and here
[Music]
we define a function so we say function
say start
with three parameters
that is name
age
and say
studies
okay
and now
within the function we use the keyword
this
so we say this dot name
equals name
[Music]
all right
we say this dot h
equals h
we say this top
studies
equals studies
now what we do is that we can
create a variable and pass parameters to
the function so we say that
student
equals stud
and within braces we say
chris
comma 21
comma computer science
[Music]
all right so we've done passing the
parameters
after this
we're going to copy the same
print message
here
[Music]
all right so let's
save this and execute our file
so let's refresh the web page
and there we go it still displays the
message chris of the age 21 studies
computer science so this was the third
method that can be used to create
objects
moving on to the next topic
object properties
now a javascript object is basically a
collection of unordered properties right
values associated with the javascript
object are called its properties
and properties can usually be added
updated or deleted excluding read-only
properties
so now let's have a look at the demo to
help you understand this better
so let me go back to my
vs code so this is where we left off and
this is how we created objects right
so now let me create another file
and let me call it
[Music]
objects underscore properties
dot html
and now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
copy the first piece of code here
all right let me just copy this
into my
new file
and here as you can see student is the
object that we've created and name agent
studies are the three properties
now say we want to update the age all
right so what we can do is here we can
just say student
dot h
equals
let me change it to 24 all right
and then we save this
and when we execute the file that was
object underscore properties
you can see chris of the age 24 so 21 is
updated to 24
so this is one of the ways you can do it
or there's another method
you can just assign the property to a
variable and then display the variable
instead so what we can do
is we can just assign student.h
to a property say x
and here instead of displaying
dot age we can just say
x
all right so let's save this
and when we run it
it says 21 because we haven't updated
21 to 24 anywhere all right
so 21 remains the same
so another method we can use
is we can just say
x equals h
so we're directly assigning the property
to the variable
and here
when i'm displaying it i say student
of x
all right
so let me
save this
and when you look at the web page
it still displays the same thing these
are different ways of accessing the
properties you can update them delete
them unless they're read only
all right so let's move on to the next
concept object methods
now basically a javascript method is an
action that can be performed on the
objects
so you'll understand better with the
help of the demo
so let's go back to rbs code and here
i've created another html file called
objects underscore methods all right so
let's let me just copy the initial
code
paste it here and let's have the
enclosing tags as well
[Music]
and html all right now here i declare
another tag that is the button tag so
we're going to be making this a button
here so i say
button
id equals click me so that is the action
that i'm going to
be performing
and the message that is going to be
displayed on the button will be
click
all right
so we're going to see the usage of it a
little later
now let's go ahead and create an object
so i say script
[Music]
within which i create
the user object
so we created using a object little here
and i declare the property name
as this again
and age
say 24
okay
so let's close this
all right so the next thing i'm going to
do is i'm going to create a new function
that will use as an object method
all right so i say function
and let's give the name say hi
okay
within the function we declare
we basically display a message
so we're going to see alert
and hello
all right so this is going to be
displayed in a separate dialog box
so now once the declaration is done
what we're going to do
is we're going to use
create another property basically say
user dot
let's say message
and assign
say hi to it
so basically what we're doing
is we're adding the previously created
method to a new property that is
user.message the message property all
right
so now i say
document
dot get element by id
and say demo
[Music]
and the message that i want is just
hi
plus the username
all right
[Music]
so what we're going to do is we're going
to display the message hello
all right when the user clicks on the
button
so for that let's say
let's just copy this
[Music]
and here
instead of demo
right we're going to be passing the id
click me
as per this
and the event is going to be on click
event
so here i say on click
after which
i'm going to simply pass
user dot
message
let me just
delete this
[Music]
all right so here i notice that i've
given an equal to sign i'm sorry it's a
colon
all right so let's save the file and
let's go ahead and execute it
all right so here you can see hi chris
being displayed and once we click on the
button
you can see
an alert which says hello
all right
so now let's move on to the next concept
that is java object accessors
now getters and setters allow defining
an object accessor all right to get the
value of a property in a javascript
object we use a getter and to set the
value of a property of a javascript
object we use a setup so let's go back
to our demo
and now let me create another file
and let's call it
object
accessors
and now again let me just
copy the first initial part
[Music]
all right so now
let's go ahead and create a new
object so let me say script
within which i say where
and let's call it car
all right
so let me define the properties say
model
and
the model is say bmw
320d
and
another property is a color
and let's say it's navy blue
and the last property say fuel type
[Music]
and let's say it's
diesel
[Music]
now what we can do is we can you make
use of the keyword get
to access the properties so i say get
and say fuel
within which i return
this dot
fuel
type
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's display it
document dot
get element by id
demo
dot inner html equals we say car
dot fuel
all right so now let's save it
and execute our file
here you go it retrieves diesel for us
now this is one of the ways of accessing
the properties
now to help you understand setter
let's go ahead and create another
object all right say where car again
now let's say the model
is
audi a4
[Music]
color be bright
red
[Music]
and fuel type
let's keep it blank
all right
now to set the value we use the set
keyword we say set fuel
the parameter is fuel
within which we say this
dot fuel type
[Music]
equals fuel
right
now let's set the value for the fuel
say car dot
fuel
equals
petrol
all right
now let's display the same
let me copy this
and what we want to display is the fuel
type right so here we say fuel type
so let's save this
and let's go ahead and
execute the file
and there we go it retrieves petrol
so what it does is basically it assigns
the value petrol to the property fuel
type and then we display the same on our
web page
so this is how you make use of getters
and setters
in this video we're going to learn all
about javascript functions so before
jumping in let's go ahead and look at
what's in store for us
first we're going to learn what exactly
javascript functions are
then we'll look at javascript function
expressions then the function
constructor
self-invoking functions functions as
values functions as objects arrow
functions generator function and the
predefined functions
also don't forget to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update moving on to our first
topic
what are javascript functions
so basically a function is a group of
reusable code which can be called from
anywhere in your program right
when you have a piece of code that you
want to execute repeatedly in your
entire program it makes more sense to
define it once and call it over and over
right it makes the code more efficient
and readable this also helps programmers
write modular codes
so this is the syntax you make use of
the function keyword followed by which
you mentioned the name of the function
the name of the function is completely
your choice
next you mention the parameter list and
within curly braces you can define the
function now the function body is
basically the code that is executed
every time the function is called
so let's go to our vs code editor
and here it created a folder called demo
functions within which i've created an
html file called functions.html
all right and now i've just typed in the
initial code
now let's create a function
so let me say script
within which i use the keyword that is
function keyword
[Music]
and now i give
the name for my function i say my
underscore
function
and the function takes
a parameter say value now this function
basically returns the square of the
digit all right
so within which
i say
document dot get element by id
the id is demo
and now it just displays value into
value
all right so the function basically
displays the square of the number
now outside the function let me call the
function
does
my function
and let me pass the value 5
all right now let's save this
and execute it
so let me go back to my file
and here we go it displays the value 25
so this was a simple function which took
a value
a digit as a parameter and then returned
the square
moving on to the next concept
function expression
now what we learnt previously was
function declaration but a function can
also be defined as an expression
now this is what the syntax looks like
now here the function is created and
assigned to the variable explicitly like
any other value
the meaning remains the same that is you
create the function and store the value
that it returns into a variable and in
our case it's x right so let's go to our
vs code and let me help you understand
this better
so now
i create another function
[Music]
and here i say
let
x equals let's use a simpler function so
i just mentioned
function
and within curly braces i display an
alert message
and i display a message saying hello
all right
now
after that to display the message what
we can do is let me just copy this
output
code
and replace it here
[Music]
and here what we're going to be
displaying is the value x right now
since it consists of a function you'll
have to type the curly braces now this
is crucial for its execution all right
so let me save this
and then execute
let me execute this
and here you go it says the site says
hello so we've successfully executed the
piece of code
we can also assign this variable x to
another variable and then call that
variable instead
right we can say let
y equals x
and instead of calling x here
we can simply call y
let me save it and then let me refresh
the page
and there we go it still displays a
message hello
all right so this is one of the ways of
defining a function that is as an
expression
moving on to our next concept function
constructor
now javascript functions are defined
using the keyword function right now
functions can also be defined using a
javascript built-in function
now this is the basic syntax so here
we've created a function called my
function and we've used the keyword new
after which we've used the constructor
function
and inside we provide the parameter list
after that the return value
next you can call the function here
right so let me just go back to my vs
code
and now
let me just make changes to the same
piece of code here
i create a function say
my underscore function
[Music]
okay
all right let me just change the name
to my function all right
and then here i use the keyword new
and the function constructor that is
function
[Music]
within which i'm passing all the
parameters
so i have
a
b
and i'm going to return
the sum of the digits
all right
and now while calling the function
let me just store the value in a
variable say x
and let's call the function that is my
function
with the parameters two and three
all right
and now let me
display it so i'm just
gonna copy this
and i want to display the value of x
right
all right so let me save this
and execute it
if you refresh the page it displays the
sum that is 5.
to make it more readable let me just
display another message here
let me just say
the sum is
[Music]
x all right
let me save it and then refresh the page
it says the sum is 5.
all right now this is how you make use
of the function constructor
next up we learn about self-invoking
functions
now as the name suggests these functions
are invoked automatically without being
called
now previously when we learned about
function expressions we saw that
parentheses were crucial
so you have to add parentheses around
the function to indicate that it is a
function expression
so here is a syntax for you so what
we've done is we've made sure we've
enclosed the entire function within
parentheses
so let me help you with that let's go
back to our vs code
and let me create another script
[Music]
and here
let me create the function within the
parentheses
and say function
it's not taking any parameters
instead it is going to alert a message
so let me say
hello
welcome
all right
after which
we're going to call the function so
again we have to mention the parentheses
let's save this
and execute
so when we
refresh the page
it says hello welcome
so we never called the function
rather it got invoked by itself so these
are self-invoking functions
now let's go ahead and look at functions
as values
now in javascript a function is
basically a value so we can deal with it
as a value now here is a simple syntax
now if you closely look at the syntax
you might think that this is same as
function expressions well no in this
case what we do is we first define the
function and then we assign it to a
particular variable but in the case of
expressions the function definition was
defined during the initialization of the
variable right and also we had to
specify the parenthesis in order to call
the function so to help you understand
this better let me go back to our vs
code
and here
let me just erase this
and let's define a function
that returns the product of two digits
so let me just call it product
[Music]
which takes two parameters let me say a
and b
within which we return the value
a into b
all right now after this let's create
another variable say y
equals
function oh i'm sorry the name of the
function is product
so product
of two and 5
all right so this basically returns us
10 right so let me just
copy this to display this on our web
page
and here i change the message to the
product
and here let me change it to y
so let's save this and execute it
so let me refresh the page and here you
go you can see the message the product
is 10.
now what we can do is we can make
alterations to this
now say i want to multiply the value
with 5 again
right so basically this returns 10 and
that value is multiplied by 5. so let me
save this and
refresh our page and there we go it
returns
and there we go it displays 50.
so this is how you can make use of
functions as values
moving on to the next topic
functions as objects
now javascript functions are a special
type of objects called function objects
now a function includes a string which
holds the actual code that is the
function body of the function the code
is literally just a string
although not recommended you can also
create a function with the help of the
function constructor
i will show that you a little later on
but for now let's look at the syntax now
here we have a variable called body
which basically consists of the function
body it's enclosed in double quotes and
that's a mistake please ignore it all
right so next we have variable function
name here we create a function using the
keyword new and then we pass a parameter
list
and the body basically tells us what the
function returns
right
next we have an alert message to call
the function so let me just show how
this is executed
back in obvious code let me create
another
function
and let's say the function returns the
area of a circle right so let me just
create a body variable
which returns
so the area of circle is pi r square so
we make use of math
dot i
into radius
right
so it's basically pi r square
after which
let's see
where circle
[Music]
and here let's create a function using
the new keyword
function
and then here we pass
the value that is the radius
and then the body
right so basically
this is the definition of our function
so let's use alert
to display the area so we say alert of
circle
or five
all right let me save this
and execute it
so when you refresh the page
it displays the area of the circle
so this is how you can use functions as
objects
moving on to our next concept arrow
functions
now functions can be written more
compactly and more precisely with the
help of arrow functions
all right now arrow function expressions
are ill-suited as methods and they
cannot be used as constructors
now also while using arrow functions
using const is a safer option because a
function expression is always a constant
value
so this is the syntax now you can only
omit the return keyword
within the curly braces if the function
is a single statement
so this is the syntax first you provide
the name of the function
with an equal to sign
followed by the argument list
and later you make use of this arrow
icon and define the expression
so this is basically
nothing
but this
so let's go back to our vs code and
check for our files
so let's create another function
and here let me say
const
my func
equals now say we want to display the
product of three digits so let me just
pass a b c of my parameters
and we make use of this icon which
indicates that this is an arrow function
within which i say return a
into b into c
all right
now let me just
assign this to a variable
let me say
product
because we've used x here
and then let me call my function that is
my func
and pass the value 2 3 and say 4.
all right so let's display
the product so let me just copy this
code
and here let me say the product
of the three
digits is
and let me say product here because that
is what is being used here right
all right so let me save this and
execute it
all right first it displays the area of
the circle
all right and then we say okay
and there we go it displays the message
the product of the three digits is 24.
so let me do one thing let me just
comment this out
okay
let me save it and then execute it again
it just displays this
all right so this is how we can make use
of arrow functions
moving on let's look at the generator
function
now regular functions typically return
only one value right or a single value
or sometimes even nothing but a
generator function can return multiple
values
and the speciality is that it can do it
so on demand all right now to create a
generator function we make use of an
asterisk so an asterisk indicates that
the function is a generator function
so here you can see that we have a
function followed by asterisks and we've
created a function called generator
sequence
so here you can see we have the asterisk
after the keyword function followed by
the name of the function right
but the main method of a generator
function is the next method
when this method is called it basically
runs the execution until the nearest
yield value
all right all the nearest yield
statement
then the function execution pauses and
the yielded value is returned to the
outer code
all right so the result of the next
method is always an object with two
properties it has a value property which
is basically the yielded value
and then it has a done property which
displays true if the function code is
finished or false if it's otherwise so
let me show its execution for a clearer
understanding so let's go back to our vs
code
and here let's create the generator
function
[Music]
let's say function
asterisk
generate
function all right
now within which
i make use of the keyword yield
[Music]
and i say yield 1 first
followed by yield
and finally i make use of return which
indicates the termination so i say
return
3. all right
now let me make use of
a variable say generator
and assign it to the generator function
that is generate
func
and now i create another variable say 1
which will basically
return the value when i call the next
function so here i say generator
dot
next
okay
so whatever generator dot next returns
it's stored in one
so to display the message i say alert
and now i'm going to make use of a
method called json.stringify
[Music]
all right so basically this method
converts a javascript object or a value
to a json string
all right so within which i'm going to
say 1
that is this
all right
so now let me save this
and execute it
let me refresh the page and there you go
here it returns
two properties that is value and done it
says value is one and done is false
right it is false because we haven't
reached the return statement yet
so what we can do is to display the rest
let me just copy these
and display it one by one
[Music]
see there let's see this
and here let me say 2
and this is three
let me copy this
[Music]
okay here i say
two
[Music]
and then essay 3.
all right so let me save this and then
execute it
so when i refresh the page
it says 1 and false
after which again it says two and false
and finally when it displays three it
returns true for the done property that
means we've reached the end of the
function definition
so this is how you make use of a
generator function
now let's move on to our last topic that
is predefined functions
now javascript has many built-in
functions all right now here are a few
of them we have eval parseint
float escape and unescape now let's go
through one by one
all right first up is eval now this
basically evaluates a string and returns
a value
all right so to help you understand this
better let me go back to our vs code
and now let me just create another file
and let me call it
predefined
functions.html all right
and i've just copied the initial code
all right so for eval
the syntax is eval
within which
i say
expression
all right now this is the general syntax
so what this eval does is that it
evaluates the expression
and if the result is not a string the
result is just returned and if the
result is a string it is taken to be a
javascript program and evaluated
so let me show you how it's done
so first let's create three variables
all right let's call them
x
and initialize it to five
then y
with six
and then let z
be seven all right
now let's just displace the result on
the console so let's say console.log
[Music]
eval
of let me say
x plus y
all right
after which i again say console.log
of eval
offset
here since the expression is a string
this gets evaluated
and here since it's not a string it just
returns the value z
and here since it is not a string it
just returns the value of z
so let me save this
and then execute it
all right so let me just
check
our console
there you go it evaluated the expression
and added the two values that is x and y
and returned 11
while z is returned as it is
all right this is what eval does
next up is parseint now as the name
suggests it passes a string argument and
returns an integer of the specified
radix or base
and the syntax basically includes the
keyword parse
and the string within paranthesis
pars float on the other hand passes a
string argument and returns a floating
point number
again the syntax has the keyword parse
float along with the string within
parenthesis
next up is escape now this returns a
hexadecimal encoding of an argument
and on the other hand unescape returns
the ascii string for the specified value
in this video we're going to cover the
topic of javascript closures so without
further delay let's begin
so before understanding what exactly
closures are let me preview about the
variable scope
now javascript defines two scopes you
have the global scope and the local
scope
now any variable declared outside of
function
belongs to the global scope and as a
result of which it can be accessible
from anywhere in your code
these variables are nothing but the
global variables
and local variables are those variables
which are declared within a function and
as a result of which these variables can
only be accessed within the function or
maybe its nested functions
so to give you a brief example
consider this piece of code here the
variable a
is defined outside the function and as a
result it is a global variable
and the variable b is declared within
the function that is function name
and only this particular function can
access this variable
all right so let's go to our editor that
is vs code and here i'll help you
understand this better with an example
so here i've created a file
called closures.html within a folder
called demo underscore closures and now
in my code
i've written the initial code
and now
let me say script
[Music]
now i'll create a variable say let
x
be say 10
okay
now
i'm going to create a function with the
keyword function
and let me give it
the name my function
[Music]
within which i define another variable
say b
which is equal to 20
and now
let me just display
[Music]
a plus b
all right now here the variable x
oh i'm sorry i've said e here so let me
just change this to a
all right so here the variable a
is a global variable all right and the
variable b here is a local variable
however the function my function can
access the global variable a as well
so now let me just call my function
all right
and let's save it and run our code
and there you go you can
see it's displayed the value 30.
so the code can access the value of this
variable as well
so i hope you understood what global and
local variables are
so moving on
now let's see what a closure is
now closures in javascript is basically
a feature
where an inner function can access the
outer functions variables
all right
so basically a closure has three scope
chains
so every function has a set of variables
that it can access so all the references
to these variables are stored in a stack
and this is called the scope chain so
closure has three scope chains
so it has scope chain of its own that is
the variables defined within its own
function body
it also can access the variables of the
outer functions
and finally it has access to all the
global variables
so to help you understand this better
let's go back to our vs code
so here let me just comment this code
and then let's just create another
script
all right now first let's create a
global variable so let me call it
variable a
and initialize it to 10.
and now let's define a function
and let me call it
first
function
all right within which i'm going to
define a variable b
now this is going to be a local variable
which is local to this particular
function
all right and within this function i'm
going to define another function
call it
second
function
and now i'm going to define a variable c
which is basically the sum of a and b
all right i see a plus b
and this function returns the value of c
so i say the term c
all right and finally
our function first func is going to
return the second function
so it is nothing but return
second function
now let me call the function so i say
variable sum
equals
first thunk
so if you have any doubts regarding
functions i highly suggest you go
through our previous video on javascript
functions
all right so moving ahead
once the function is called the value
return is going to be stored in the
variable sum and then we're going to
print the sum
so we say document
dot right
and let me display a message
the sum is
[Music]
and let me just break it
all right
so we save this
and then execute it
let's go back to our
browser and just refresh the page it
says the sum is 30. now we can also go
back
and make changes here
suppose i want to add a value i can just
say 20 plus a psp
so let me save this and here it says 50.
so basically
the function second func can access the
value of b and a
so this is what closure is so it gets
access to its own variables
the variables of its outer function and
the global variables
i hope this was clear
in our previous few topics we learned
about areas functions and loops however
this time we're going to take a step
forward and then learn about
so let's go ahead and jump right in
now you must be wondering why javascript
promises even came into picture and what
exactly these promises are
so don't worry i've got your back in
today's video we're going to learn about
promises why they were introduced and
also i'll explain their functionality
so let's go ahead
first up why javascript promises
now javascript is predominantly single
threaded
meaning
all processes contain the execution of
instructions in a single sequence so
basically in simple terms one command is
processed at a time now if a function
relies on the result of another function
it basically has to wait for the other
function to finish and return and until
then the current function remains idle
now this can be extremely frustrating
because it's time consuming and very
restrictive i mean you're not using the
system to its full capability so to
overcome these drawbacks asynchronous
concepts or asynchronous programming
came into picture
so in this case the main thread
continues its execution while javascript
allows long network requests and other
tasks to happen simultaneously
now with the help of features like
callbacks promises and async await
asynchronous programming can be easily
achieved
i hope now you understood why promises
or asynchronous programming came into
picture
moving on what are javascript promises
now in the case of synchronous actions
you could instead of arranging for a
function to be called at some point in
the future return an object that
represents this future event
this is what the standard class promises
for
now a promise is basically an
asynchronous action that may complete at
some point in the future
and when it's completed it produces a
value
now it is able to notify when its value
is available
the easiest way to create a promise is
by calling the promise.resolve method
now this function ensures that the value
you give it is wrapped within a promise
now a problem is basically has three
states first up is the pending state now
this indicates that the underlying
operation has not yet been completed
next up is the fulfill state this
indicates that the promise has been
fulfilled with a particular value
lastly we have rejected now this
indicates that an error has occurred
during the operation and the promise is
rejected with a particular reason
moving on a promise is said to be
settled when it is either fulfilled or
rejected
because remember promises are immutable
they cannot change their state so once
they're either fulfilled or rejected
they're said to be settled
so when a promise is fulfilled it has to
do a particular job so for that we make
use of the then method now the then
method basically runs for a result and
this is used to attach a callback when
the promise has been resolved
all right same with the case of the
scenario when the promise is rejected
it makes use of a catch method which is
used to attach a callback when the
promise has been rejected
don't worry you'll understand the
concepts better when we get to the demo
so moving on let's look at a quick
flowchart to understand promises better
first up you have a new promise now the
promise is in the pending state
now this promise runs for an
asynchronous action now we check if the
action is successful
if it is a yes then we call the then
method and if it is a no then the catch
method is called
and to end it if it is fulfilled then
the asynchronous action is performed and
if it is not that is if it is rejected
then error handling is performed
and lastly the values of these methods
is returned to the promise
i hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the
general syntax
you can use the let keyword and provide
a name for your variable and then you
create a new promise now this promise
object takes a function which in turn
takes two parameters that is resolve and
reject
so to help you understand all of this
better let's go ahead and look at a
simple demo
so in vs code i've created a folder
called demo promises within which i've
created an html file named promises
so i have the initial code ready here
so let's begin typing our code
so let's say script
and here as i explained we say let and
let's give the name car
to our variable
say car and we create a new promise
all right so the promise
object returns a function
which takes two parameters
called resolve
and reject
all right
so within the function
let's define
a simple use case
now let's assume that we're checking the
car for its fuel all right so we'll
create
variable called fuel
underscore full tank
now let's set the variable to say true
all right
now let's set the variable to true
now this indicates that the fuel tank is
full
so now if the fuel tank is full
what i can do is i say resolve
all right
else
i reject it
okay i hope you understood what i'm
doing here i'm just checking for the
fuel tank and if it is full which is
true then it gets resolved and if it is
false then it gets rejected
so if the promise gets resolved
the then method is called right so let
me call it here
i say car dot then
now this runs a result right so it's a
callback function
within which i say document
dot write
the fuel
tank
is full
happy driving
[Music]
all right
and if it is
rejected
i say
dot catch
which also returns a function
that says document
dot right
let's just display a simple message
saying that the fuel tank is not empty
[Music]
all right
so let me save this and execute it
so here it displays the message the fuel
tank is full happy driving
now that happens because we've set the
value to true here
now in case we change it to false
let's see what it displays
all right it displays the message the
fuel tank is not empty
so this was a simple example showing how
a promise works
now let's go ahead and understand nested
promises
so for that
let me just comment this out
and now let's create a function that
returns promises so in our case what
we're going to do is first we'll check
for the fuel tank now in our case we're
taking a scenario where the fuel tank is
empty and the engine of the car is
overheating so as a result the car is
not safe for traveling all right so
let's go ahead and create these
functions
so i'll say let
empty underscore
tank
okay which returns
a promise
so within which i say return
new promise
and the function takes two parameters
that is resolve
and reject
within which i'm going to display a
message
saying
resolve
it says the car
doesn't have enough
fuel
all right
now let me just copy the same piece of
code
to check
for the engine all right
so let me just change the name of our
variable here
let's call it engine
and here it displays the message
the engine is overheating
all right
and lastly
when both of these scenarios hold true
that is the car doesn't have enough fuel
and the engine is overheating
we say that the car is not fit for
travel
let me just call it
and here
i'll display a message saying the car
is not safe for traveling
[Music]
all right
so
right now we've created three functions
that returns promises
so first we check for the empty tank
right so let me just call the function
here
empty tank
and we make use of the then method
which is executed when the promise gets
resolved
which takes
a callback function
all right so basically when we check for
the empty tank
after this is executed we check for the
engine right so here we simply call the
engine function so let me just say
return
engine
all right
now this is a nested promise in itself
so on top of it i can run the then
method again
so if
the tank is empty and if the engine is
overheating
then i'll just check if it is safe for
traveling or not
so let me say
function
and here let me just return
the method travel
all right
now after this
if all of these are executed
then i say
function
finally i'll display a message
same
saying done
all right
so let's save this file and execute it
so here i go and click on promises
let's go and check our console
and there we go
the message done is displayed
so here since every time the promise is
being resolved a message is displayed i
can basically catch the message in a
result
okay
and this result can be passed to the
coming methods
so here i just say result
i see result again
[Music]
all right
so now we get the message the car
doesn't have enough fuel so we have to
append it with the next message so let
me just say message
here
i've used msg
[Music]
and let's just append it here
and the final message gets appended here
with result
okay i have to add message here as well
all right so let's save it and execute
the file
all right so here you can see the
message done gets displayed first
and then since we're appending it after
the message done it says the car doesn't
have enough fuel the engine is
overheating the car is not safe for
traveling
so this is how you can make use of
nested promises
in this video we're going to learn all
about javascript asynchronous concepts
that is async and away so without any
further delay let's go ahead and learn
about async in a way
firstly let's understand the basic
concepts of synchronous and asynchronous
programming in case of synchronous
programming all the actions are
performed sequentially so you have the
execution of the function 1 after which
you have function 2 and then you have
function 3 and after all of these are
executed the program terminates now
although synchronous programming is
clean and has lesser errors it has its
own drawbacks the entire system is
halted when a particular process is
being executed now as a result of which
it is time consuming and the system is
not used to its full capacity
so to overcome that asynchronous
programming was introduced now in this
case let's assume that a particular
function of a process is being executed
now let's consider that this particular
function is waiting for a resource let's
say a network resource now instead of
waiting for the function to acquire this
resource the main thread continues its
execution with function 2 and function 3
and when the resource is acquired it
receives a callback indicating that the
function 1 has to be called and finally
the entire chain is terminated so this
is how asynchronous programming works it
makes sure that the system does not halt
when a particular process is waiting for
a resource this makes the entire system
very efficient
now that you know the concepts of
synchronous and asynchronous programming
let's move ahead now async and await are
purely asynchronous programming concepts
i again suggest you check out the video
on promises before watching this
alright so moving on
what are javascript async functions that
is async and await now async and await
are built on promises
the function is basically accompanied by
the keyword async indicating that it
returns a promise within this function
the away keyword is applied to the
promise that is being returned and the
await keyword ensures that the function
waits for the promise to resolve
now on the surface the execution looks
synchronous while it's actually
asynchronous now at the place of usage
of the await keyword the execution of
the function is practically blocked
now async functions make the code more
readable and are easy to handle when
compared to promises
now to give you the general syntax you
have the async keyword associated with
the function name
within which we have the await keyword
with a particular promise now to help
you understand the entire concept better
let's look at a demo
now i've created a file called async
await in my visual studio code
so what we're going to be doing is that
we're going to have two functions that
help you check for the result now you
pass this code as a parameter to these
functions which in turn return promises
telling if you have passed and will also
give you the grade that you scored all
right so let's go ahead and say let
let me call the variable result and
let's have a function
which takes
the score as a parameter all right
within which it returns a promise so i
say return
new promise
now as you know a promise basically has
a function
which takes two parameters that is
resolve
and reject
now i just display a message saying
calculating
results
all right now if
my score is say above 50
i resolve it
by displaying a message saying
congratulations
[Music]
you have passed
all right
and
if it is less than 50
i reject it with the message saying you
have faith
all right so this is a very simple
promise that i created
so moving on let's create another
function that returns a promise
so basically this function will tell you
the grade that you've scored so say let
grade equals
function
now this takes response as a parameter
so let me just say response
now again let me just copy this
all right
within which
i'm going to console.log a message
saying
calculating your grade
and we're just going to resolve the
promise with the message
your grade is
a all right
and then we append the response
now the first promise either results
saying that you've passed or it rejects
saying you failed and in case it gets
resolved then the next promise is
automatically resolved with the grade a
all right so moving on
let's call the functions so here let me
first call the function result so i say
result
and let me pass the value 80 since it
gets resolved and now i make use of the
dot then method
now here i catch the response
all right and then i just display a
message
indicating
results received
okay
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pass the response to my next function
that is the grade function so what i say
is i say return grade and the parameter
is
response let me just pass that
now what exactly happens is that the
grade function also returns a promise so
on top of that i can use the dot then
method
so i use the then method
and let me just say final grade
[Music]
now within which i just display the
message
final grade
all right now lastly we make use of the
catch method
in case of errors this catches the
errors
so let me just say error
then
[Music]
console log it
all right
so this is the code
let me save this
and let's execute it to see its normal
execution so this is without using async
innovate all right
so let's go ahead and execute this
so here let me check the console
and there we go it says calculating
results results received calculating
your grade your grade is a and
congratulations you have passed
so this was basically without using
async innovate so now let me show you
how you can use async and await and how
easier the code becomes all right so
what we can do is let me just comment
this out
all right now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to call my function right
so i'm just going to make use of the
async keyword while calling it so i see
async
function and let me call the function
calculate
results
okay
so now inside this method i'm going to
call the functions result and grade so
when i first call result the value that
is returned by result is going to be
stored in the variable response so for
that let me just say const
response
now i make use of the await keyword here
i say await
result
of 20 or
in our case let me just say 80
all right
so what the away keyword does is that
the function result ceases to execute
until the promise is resolved and
whatever the promise returns gets stored
in the variable response
all right so now after this let me just
display a message
that says
results
received
all right
now next i'm gonna call the other
function that is great so again i'm
gonna say constant and i'm going to have
to create another variable let me call
it final grade and it's the same
procedure i use the await keyword
and call the function grade
and i pass response as the argument
all right
and after this i'm going to say
console.log
for final grade
so it's as simple as that so first we
call the result function which returns a
promise which gets stored in the
variable response
all right then we're going to call the
grade function and pass the response as
an argument
and the result of which is being stored
in final grade all right and lastly we
display final grade so now you must be
wondering if this executes what about
errors what if the value that i pass is
less than 50 right for that i'm going to
have to catch an error
so what i can do is that i can place
this entire code within the try block
all right so let me just say try
and now what i can do is i can catch
now if there is an error it gets caught
and then i display it
let me say console.log
error
all right
and lastly let's call the function
calculate results
okay so let me save this and execute it
so all right here we go
it displays the same messages in the
same sequence that we saw before
so now to give you an example of
rejection so here let me just pass 20.
all right
let's save it
and there we go it says calculating
results you have failed so you can make
use of async and await instead of
complicating the entire piece of code by
using promises
in this video we're going to be learning
all about javascript this keyword
so without further delay let's jump
right in
so you must have heard about this
keyword several times so in javascript
this keyword basically refers to an
object which is executing the current
piece of code well in simple terms this
keyword basically just references the
object that is executing the current
function
now if the function that is being
referenced is a regular function
then this keyword references the global
object
all right i'm sure it must be a little
tricky at the moment but please hold on
and if the function that is being
referenced is a method in an object
then this keyword references the object
itself
so to help you understand the concept
better and to clarify all your doubts
let's look at a simple demo
so here in vs code i've created a file
called this.html
all right you can give it a name of your
choice now here let me first define a
variable
and let's call the variable
say
value
and let's set it to say 50
all right
now let's go ahead and create a simple
function
so let me say function
[Music]
my function
all right
and within this
let me define the value
for value
let me set the value for the variable
value as hundred
okay
and now let me just alert it all right
so let me say alert
value
[Music]
okay plus value
and then let me have another alert
message
which is going to display this dot value
so let me just say this value
and
instead of just saying value i say this
dot value
all right now after this let's go ahead
and call the function
my function
so let me just save this and execute it
so here it says value equals 100
and then when you see this dot value it
says 50.
so now here you can come back to the
code and see
now when i just say value it takes the
value 100 all right which is taken
locally but when i say this dot value
since it is a normal function it's
references to the global variable which
is here this value
i hope this makes sense to you now
now moving on let's look at the behavior
of this keyword within an object method
so let me create an object here
but before that let me just
comment this out
let's say script
and now let's create an object so
let's say const
and then i give the name of my object as
random
and within this let me say name
and
let's call it
john
and then i create a method called info
okay and within this i display a console
message
that says hi
my name is
and now i make use of this keyword i say
this
dot name
all right
and now let me just go ahead and call
this method
so i say random
dot info
all right so let's save this and execute
it
so let me check my console
and there you go it says hi my name is
john
so if you clearly observe here
when we say this dot name since it is
being used within a method that is
defined inside an object
it references to this
property here
all right unlike this case where it
reference to the global variable that
was mentioned outside
so i hope this helped you understand the
difference between the two
now let's look at another simple example
so now let me just change the value of
name here
to say tutorial
and now let's define another property
which is basically an array so let me
just call the property video
within which i have an add a let's say
javascript
another value
say this
and then let's say keyword
and in my info method i'm going to just
display these video tags
so
let me just
save this
okay let me just delete this first
and let's say this
dot video
now since it's an array we can make use
of for each
and now for each in turn takes a
callback function
and then i say
i'm going to call it
a tag
the parameter that's being passed
within which i just console log it
and say
tag
all right so let me save it
and then execute this
now here you can see that the values in
the video property are displayed that is
javascript this and keyword
now let's suppose
that you want to display the name along
with every
string here
right so naturally you would go ahead
and just say
this
dot
name
right it makes perfect sense
so let me just
save and execute this
now if you see just the values of the
property video are displayed here
now the main reason for this is
if you closely observe that this
function here is mentioned within the
callback function
right so when it is referencing it is
referencing to the global object
which is unclear which is undefined in
this case so to overcome this what we
can do is that
the for each method takes in two
properties one is the function the other
one is the object so here we just pass
this
all right so what happens is it's going
to reference the current object that is
random so let me save this and then
execute it
and there you go
you can see that tutorial that is the
name has been displayed
all right i hope you understood the
concept of this keyword it could be a
little tricky but as you work on it
you'll get the hang of it
in this video we're going to learn all
about javascript form validation
so what exactly is form validation
now i'm sure you must have filled
several online forms right a simple
example would be a new registration for
a website
now every time you miss out on giving a
particular detail or end up giving
faulty information the website alerts
you
so this process of ensuring that the
information provided is legit is called
form validation
now this generally happens on the server
side however javascript facilitates form
validation on the client computer before
sending it over to the server
now there are two functions performed
one is the basic validation which
ensures that all the mandatory fields
are filled now this is implemented with
the help of a simple loop
and the other is a data format
validation now this checks the data for
its correctness
so to help you understand form
validation better let's look at a simple
demo
all right so back in my visual studio
code i've created a file called forms
alright it's an html file and i've typed
down the initial code
now the simple use case that i'm going
to show will include the validation of
the email and the password fields in a
form
all right so for that let's go ahead and
first create a simple form
so here html allows the form tag so i'll
say form
within which i'm going to provide
our fields so i say input
and then the name i'm going to be
providing is email
[Music]
all right and then i'll provide a
placeholder and call it
email
and then the type of the input is going
to be text
all right and then let me just give a
break tag here
so now let me just copy the same thing
for my password as well
so here we go i say
password here
and then the placeholder again will be
password
[Music]
and then i'm going to keep the type as
text
and finally i'm going to have a button a
submit button right so let me say button
type
is basically submit
all right
and let me just play submit on my button
okay
so with the help of this we've created a
simple form so let me show you how this
looks
so here we go we have successfully
created an email field a password field
and a submit button and every time i
click on the submit button you can see
that my page is getting refreshed
now once the user provides the correct
email id and password we want to display
a message all right so for that i've
created another file called message.html
and this is a simple file where i'm
displaying the message hello there
welcome
all right
so this is a simple message that i want
to display
so for that i have to
add it in my form tag
now once the form gets submitted
an action has to be performed and the
action is to navigate to the
message.html file right so let me just
say action
[Music]
equals
message.html
now you can also provide a name to your
form so let me call it
my form
all right
so let me just save this
all right so moving on we have to now
validate the information that is
provided for that i'm going to create a
function here
so let me call the function
validate
all right
so here i'm going to check for my fields
right
now if the email field is empty then i'm
going to alert the user saying please
enter the email and if the password
field is empty i'm gonna again alert the
user to provide the password
so for that we're going to make use of
this simple if else logic
so let me say if
document
dot my form
[Music]
dot email
dot value
is null
so i'm going to check if the value
provided on my email field in my form
is null all right
what i'm going to do is i'm going to say
alert
please
provide
your
email id
okay
and then
i'm going to say
document.myform.email.focus
now what exactly focus does
is that it makes sure that the cursor
remains at the email field that is it is
focused at the same field
all right
so let me just copy the same thing for
my password field
so let me say else if
let me just copy this
instead of email
i say password
within which i'm going to alert the user
to provide the password
[Music]
i'll say please provide
your password
all right
so basically it first checks for the
email field and then for the password
field so let me just say finally else
do nothing
all right
okay so now what we're going to do is
every time we click on the submit button
the form gets submitted correct now we
can control when the form is getting
submitted
so basically the form gets submitted
when this function is executed
so for that we can use another property
here
called on submit
and here i'm going to call my function
that is validate so let me say validate
here
all right so let me save this and let's
check the output
so here as you can see
let me just try submitting it without
providing the email field all right so
here we go it alerts us all right and
once i click on ok
it still displays the message hello
there welcome
now that is not what we want right
so once the email field is empty it
should remain in the same page
and the form shouldn't get submitted but
here in our case it is getting submitted
so for that we're going to have to make
use of return values so what happens is
if my email field is empty then i'm
going to return a false
so here i say return false
and here as well
and finally when both my email and my
password fields are filled i'm going to
return true
all
right and same goes here
let me just say return validate instead
of just validate
right
so
here we go
let me save this and now let's check the
output
so here let's first submit the form
without providing any information
all right so it says please provide your
email id when i click on ok observe that
the cursor remains at the email field
so here let me just give some random
value
and then let's try submitting it again
without providing the password
and then it says please provide your
password
all right
okay now if you observe that the cursor
is remains at the email field so let me
just check my code once
here we go i haven't mentioned password
here
so let me change email to password
so let me just provide some random value
at my email field
and say submit
and then i get a message saying please
provide your password
and now you can see that the cursor is
at the password field right so let me
just give random information there
and then i say submit
and here we go
the message hello there welcome is
displayed
so this was a simple demo on form
validation
so i really suggest you pause the video
here and then go through the code once
in this video we're going to learn all
about javascript regular expressions
so what exactly are regular expressions
now a regular expression is basically a
sequence of characters now these
characters could be digits or the
letters of the alphabet and this
expression usually searches for a
particular pattern
now the user can basically define what
has to be searched in a text all right
and these expressions could be alphabet
or digits as i explained before
also one of the main reasons that we use
regular expressions is for text search
and text replacement operations
so this is a general syntax you have a
pattern that needs to be checked and you
have a flag associated with it so
further on in the video i'll explain to
you what flags and patterns are but
before that let me give you a small
example of what a regular expression is
so i have made use of this website
called regexar.com i'll link it down in
the description box below
so this is the website
now here let me just show you a simple
regular expression now say we have a
text that says
apple
all right and now we have to search for
the letter a so what i do here now this
is going to be my expression so i first
provide a pattern right so i just say
capital a
when i say capital a you can see that
the letter a has been matched
in my text all right so it's as simple
as that now one thing to remember is
that here it is case sensitive
all right so if i say a regular small a
it does not get matched
all right so if i want to match ap i can
just say ap and it gets highlighted here
all right so this is a simple regular
expression that matches with the text
so moving on
let's see what exactly these flags
patterns and quantifiers are
so what exactly is a flag so we
previously saw that the syntax consists
of a pattern and then a flag right so
these flags basically specify to alter
the behavior of a regular expression now
these flags are generally appended after
the red x literal and can be specified
as a second argument in your expression
right so let's see the different flags
that are supported by javascript
now you have these five flags here you
have g which is the global flag
now this finds all matches instead of
stopping after the first
all right then you have i which is
ignore case which makes the entire
expression case insensitive and then you
have m which is multi-line
so the carrot and the dollar match the
beginning and the end of each line
respectively then you have unicode and
if this flag is not supported you must
match specific unicode characters and
then finally you have y which finds all
the consecutive or adjacent matches
so moving on we have patterns now these
patterns are basically brackets and are
used to find the range of characters
now again we have these patterns you
have a to z which finds all the
characters from a to z in lower cases
only then we have 0 to 9 which finds all
the digits between 0 to 9 and finally we
have the letters of the alphabet and the
digits separated by a pipe all right so
this basically finds any character be it
an alphabet or a digit
i hope this was clear to you so moving
on we have quantifiers now these
quantifiers define the number of
occurrences of a particular string
now consider n to be a string so we have
three quantifiers here we have the plus
we have the asterisk and we have the
question mark so plus indicates one or
more occurrence of the character n
all right and the asterisk indicates
zero or more occurrences of the
character end while a question mark
indicates zero or one occurrence of the
character n
so now that you know flags patterns and
quantifiers let me help you understand
them better with the help of a demo
alright so here i have a simple text
which says welcome to this tutorial on
javascript this video teaches regular
expressions
now here
when i search for a particular word see
let me search for the word this okay
so i say this
now ideally even this has to be
highlighted
right however it does not that is
because as mentioned earlier it is
extremely case sensitive right so what
we can do is here we have flags
so here i say case insensitive so once i
click on that both these words get
highlighted
all right so this is how you make use of
the i flag
now moving on let me help you understand
patterns
now as mentioned you can have a range of
characters
now just in case here
say i just make it case sensitive again
and here
i would like to select all the letters
of the alphabet
from a to z
all right so when i do that you can
observe all the letters are highlighted
except the ones that are in the upper
case
correct because that is not mentioned
here so here when i make it insensitive
you can see all of them get highlighted
so this is how you can make use of a
pattern
now to understand quantifiers
let me use a separate text all right
let's have a couple of a's and a few b's
now here when i say a
you can see all the characters are being
highlighted right which is correct
but when i use the asterix
symbol here what happens is you can
observe
all the four a's are considered to be a
single unit what aztecs does is that you
can see here it says match is 0 or more
of the preceding token now the preceding
token is a and matches 0 or more
occurrences of the character a
now same if i say b next to it
you can see all the characters b are
matched
right
however you can check
the characters a in this particular text
are not highlighted
i'm sure you can understand why because
the expression that i'm looking for is
any occurrences of a
followed by the character b
in this text here there are no
characters a and b together correct so
here you can see that a is not
highlighted
but once i give an asterisk again
what happens is that the character a
gets highlighted
what happens is that b can have zero or
more occurrences so here there is a zero
occurrence of b so a gets highlighted so
this is how
gas does quantifier works
now one of the most important concepts
of using regular expressions
are the special characters
so here you're gonna indicate the
special characters with the backslash
so we have backslash w for example now
what w does is that it matches any word
character right so all the characters
here get matched
now it also has a counter character
which is the capital w all right so what
this does is that it does not match any
word so it matches everything that is
not a word including the periods
now let's see if you want to match
all the white spaces you can make use of
the character s here
all right and when you have the
uppercase s
it matches any character that is not a
white space
now let's say you want to match
a digit you can just have backslash d
so let me just type in a few digits
and here you go all of them get matched
now let's say you want to have a range
of values that get matched right now
let's say i want to match just three
digits
so i can make use of curly braces and
within which i can mention three now
here you can see that it matches three
of the preceding token correct so the
preceding token is basically a digit so
it groups them in threes
so let me just add two other digits and
there we go
same goes with the matching of words so
here let me say w
so when i say 3 all of the characters
are grouped in threes all right
now let's say i want to group the words
that are three or four in number so here
i can just say
comma four
all right now it gets matched
all right so now it gets grouped in
force
so this is a simple example to show you
how special characters work in a regular
expression
moving on let's see how you can use
regular expressions to search for phone
numbers
now here in my phone number
i'm going to have an area code
so let's say
0 8 0 followed by a new digit number all
right so let me give a random number
all right so it's eight digits so some
people write a phone number like this
while others could write it something
like this you could have a hyphen in
between and then
an eight digit number all right now how
are you going to look for this text so
what we're going to do is we're going to
make use of the special character that
is for a digit you make use of hyphen d
and first we're going to look for
the area code that is a three digit
number right so let me just say
three here
and next we're going to have an optional
hyphen so for that now since we learnt a
pattern can be enclosed within square
brackets so let me just
say hyphen here
and let me say a question mark now a
question mark indicates zero or one
occurrence of the preceding
character right so we're going to have a
hyphen for a question mark
and then finally we're going to have a
digit again
and here the number of digits is 8. so
let me just specify that
all right so when this happens you can
see both my numbers are getting
highlighted
although the text remains the same it
could be specified with different
formats right so just like this you can
create expressions that match various
formats
so this was just a simple video to
acquaint you with regular expressions in
this video we're going to be learning
all about javascript email validation
so first of all validation is an
essential part when you're communicating
with the user almost all the websites
and applications that you use have forms
that you need to fill in and every time
you fill a form that information you
provide needs to be validated
so this is an essential and a crucial
part now when you're providing more
critical information like user
credentials say your id your password
your date of birth all of that needs to
be validated so javascript enables this
with the help of a feature called email
validation
now email validation first of all
ensures user authenticity
it also facilitates email validation on
the client side so that all the
processing that takes place on the
server side is faster
and lastly with javascript one can
validate a name password email date etc
now i'm sure everybody has used email
ids right so here's a dummy email id for
you one thing that you must have noticed
is that all ids come with an ad symbol
now the first part before the act
character is the personal data
now here it could include your name you
can provide digits etc so the length of
this personal information can be up to
64 degrees and following the at
character you have the domain name the
domain name can be up to 253 characters
talking about the personal data
now this data can include any sort of
information you can provide your name
your birth date etc so basically it can
consist of all uppercase and lowercase
letters of the alphabet
it can have digits from zero to nine
you can include all special characters
and lastly it could include the period
character one thing to remember is that
the period character cannot occur twice
and is not supposed to be either the
first or the last character
all right so this was just a brief
introduction to email validation now to
give you a better understanding let's go
ahead and look at a simple demo
so back in our visual studio code i've
created a folder called javascript demo
and i've also created a file called
email validation
i've also typed in the initial code
also if you haven't watched our videos
on javascript regular expressions and
javascript form validation then i highly
recommend you go through them
email validation is basically just a
combination of the two so i suggest you
first head back and watch those videos
and come back here all right so the
first thing that we need to do is create
a form that includes the email field
right so for that let's go ahead and
create our form
here i'd say
form
within which i'd give input
let the id be
text
and i'll give the placeholder property
and let it be email
and the type
text
all right
and then i will
break the line
and finally i have a button that's
basically the submit button right so let
me just say button
type
say button
and then
the message displayed is submit
all right
so now when you're validating a form you
will have to
provide certain cases that is the if
else conditions
to validate it correct now first i'm
going to create a function wherein i'm
going to pass the information typed in
by the user as an argument
and this function consists of a regular
expression against which the id provided
by the user is checked and if the
pattern matches it then the id is valid
and if it does not then you'll have to
alert the user so now let's create our
function
let's say
script
and now let me
create a function
called validate
all right
and now i'm going to create a variable
called mail
and i'm going to get
the information provided by using this
id
from the input now i'm going to get the
text using this id correct
so let me just say document dot
get element by id
within which
the name of the id is text
let me say text dot value
all right
so the next thing is to create a regular
expression
now consider two different ids here now
the domain of the first id ends with dot
com
while the next one is ending with dot co
dot n so when we're defining the regular
expression we'll consider all possible
scenarios
so now let's head back to our vs code
and here let me just say
variable reg x
beginning with a forward slash
and then
you have
a carrot now the carrot symbol indicates
the beginning of the regular expression
now since we can have the lowercases
uppercases and all the digits
let's go ahead and mention them so
here
let me say a to
z
all lowercases then we have uppercase
and we have all digits
0 to 9
followed by which we can also include a
period and an underscore so when you're
including a period symbol you will have
to use the escape character that is
backslash
and then you mention the period now one
thing to remember is that a period
symbol in regular expression means that
it can include any of the characters
but here since we're using the literal
character that is the period we have to
include backslash after that we can have
an underscore as well
all right
followed by which we have a quantifier
that is plus
now plus here indicates one or more
occurrences of all these characters
so here we include plus
after which we have a literal that is
the act symbol
followed by which we have the domain
name so again the domain name can
include all the letters of the alphabet
and the digits
so for that let me say
a to z
a to z and 0 to 9.
again to remember we have to include the
plus symbol
indicating that it
let me just get rid of this
so we include the plus symbol to
indicate
one or more occurrences of of these
characters
again followed by which we have a period
symbol
so for that let's just go and type in
period now you must be wondering why i
didn't use the backslash
now a backslash or an escape sequence
here can only be used within the squared
braces outside of it it is considered as
a literal
so here i just mentioned the period
again i highly recommend you go through
the javascript regular expressions video
to clarify all your doubts
so moving on
after this i have to mention
the extension that is dot com or dot co
dot in
now generally these extensions are in
lower cases
so
for that let's just
go ahead and mention a to z
again followed by a plus that is a
quantifier
with an optional
dot again
followed by
the letters a to z
again these can
again i mentioned plus
followed by which i'm going to add the
question mark
now the question mark indicates zero or
one occurrence of the preceding
expression so in this case
this
extension that is dot in
is optional
now the question mark here indicates
either a zero occurrence or one
occurrence
all right
so
uh to end the expression you have
the dollar symbol and then
the front slash
oh i might have missed something
okay yeah i haven't closed this so let
me just add the parentheses all right
so this is your regular expression
against which we're going to be checking
the email id right
so now
we're going to use the simple if else
logic
so for that let's say if
reg x
text
dot mail
mail is basically what has been
passed by the user
all right now if this is true
that is if the mail when checked against
the regular expression comes in to be
true
then i'm going to alert the user
saying
you have
provided
a valid email id
and i'm going to return
true
else
if the expression does not match
then i'm going to alert the user with a
message saying sorry
incorrect
email id
and i'm going to return a false
so now you must be wondering where is
the return value going so for that i
have to add the on click event on my
button
so here let me say on
click
it's going to call the validate function
all right so there we go
let me save this
and execute it
in my browser when i type in xyz
gmail.com
and when i click on submit
it alerts me saying
you have provided a valid email id so to
check the other condition as well let's
type in dot co dot in and submit
and again it says that we've provided a
valid email id
now uh let's just add
a period and an underscore as well
so if i say x
y zed
dot
a
underscore bc at gmail dot co dot n
and when i submit it it again says it's
a valid email id
for a false case let's go ahead and
remove the add symbol
and submit it it says
sorry incorrect email id
or you can also go ahead and remove the
period here
and submit it
it still says that the id is valid now
here what happens is that gmail co is
taken as one domain name with an
extension dot in so here this is valid
so this was a simple video to explain
email validation
i encourage you to play around with
regular expressions and also uh
consider all possible scenarios while
you're validating your id hi there
and in this session we will be seeing
what exactly is dom
which is document object model
and how can we
manipulate the term how do we interact
with the dom elements and nodes
and then we will wrap up the session
with a very interesting and engaging
demo
which is about movies
so we'll be creating a movie web page
where you can see the list of movies you
can search for these movies and we also
can add a new movie
and delete them so these dom
manipulations will be seen for a movie
webpage
so what is term
document object model
it is the data representation of the
objects that comprise the structure and
content of a document on the web so this
dom is a programming interface for html
and xml documents
and it represents the page so that the
programs can change the document
structure style and content
dom represents the document as nodes and
objects
this way programming languages can
connect to the page
a web page is a document
the document can either be displayed in
the browser window or as an html source
but it is the same document in both the
cases
the document object model or dom
represents the same document so it can
be manipulated
dom is an object-oriented representation
of the webpage which can be modified by
the scripting language very powerful
language like javascript
dom is usually represented in a
hierarchical tree like structure
so you can see
this picture on to my right where you
can see a html element which will be the
root for the parent element
and it has two child elements that you
can see one is the head and then we have
the body
head consists of the metadata like title
it also consists of script and style
tags
and body comprises mostly of the content
of the webpage so in this example you
can see a h1 which is a heading tag you
also have another element which is the
list element that you can see which is
an unordered list which consists of two
list items now these two list items are
the child elements of this particular
unordered list
and these two comprises of the child
element of body which in turn is the
child of the root html parent element so
we have a parent and child relationship
that you can see over here
and when we speak about events later in
the module so you can see like how the
parent can
handle the child event or the child can
be able to
manipulate the events of the
parent element via javascript
so we can use javascript to perform
different tasks of dom manipulation like
traversing the dome
you can read the
text or
the history text or in the text or
whatever property value which is present
in the form of
the element inside the element or a node
so you can do a read operation basically
or you also can
edit or update something
and we also can add new element we can
delete the existing ones we can change
the style so we can do all these
manipulation of this document object
model using just javascript
so
all of the properties and methods and
whatever events that we have
available for manipulating and creating
pages and these are organized into
something like objects
so the document object that represents
the document itself the table object
that implements the special html table
element dom interface for accessing html
tables and so forth
so the entire dom if you see it's like
object reference object by object
reference
so what is the power of javascript in
manipulating this
dom
so we'll see the perspective of
javascript now
so using javascript as i told earlier
so you can add elements or nodes or you
also can remove the html elements or
nodes that we see in the structure
but this is just not html elements of
the content
even you can manipulate the style
so you know cascading style sheet or
this css
which represents the theme of a page so
for a webpage the theme or style is very
very important
so the html represents the content and
css represents the style or theme
and the javascript is the core
functionality or the feature of a
webpage so these three things are like
you know like a trinity of a web page or
website these three things complement
each other and go hand in hand
so just with your javascript so your
content is definitely important content
is king
for any
particular website or system so content
is mandatory it has to be there
so without content it's nothing
but style is also very important so if
you have to attract your first time
customers so you can attract them only
with a very nicely styled theme or
design
so this ui and ux design is plays a very
important role to attract your customers
so after attracting your customers so
these are just not enough it is also
important to provide good features so
your customer is now trying to shop from
your website so
he is so attracted by your
design minimalistic beautiful design so
he starts shopping
and after that at some point or the
other he is unable to put items in the
cart or he is not able to contact you
via some contact form so these are
provided for your javascript or some
javascript packages like jquery or
angular or react so this is very very
important so the functionality and
feature if you don't provide it of
course the custom you are going to lose
your customer
so
your javascript is so important and
powerful here that um so i was saying
that
using your javascript you can add whole
lot of html content you can from scratch
you can add styles also or change the
existing style
not just the font and color
you also can completely change the
spacing padding alignment everything so
the entire theme style and content you
can change via javascript alone and
coming back to your
events
now this is very important part of
javascript
this is the place
where the user interacts with that
webpage or website say for example in
the form of a
form so you have a registration form or
a contact form
so using these forms so where we have
these input elements like a button
we also have lot of text boxes and check
boxes so all using all these input
elements
so we can get the input and we can
interact with the user
so the user can click a button
and he can select something he can blur
or he can get into
some particular input element but by
gaining some focus
now all these are done in the help of
some triggering points which is called
as events
now we have these event listener
especially for older browsers
and these events are nothing but some
triggering point which can trigger some
actions
now these actions are termed as
functions
or your handler for that particular
event
so to put this in a very simple layman
form say for example uh someone is
ringing the bell your doorbell and you
are getting up and
you are attending
the door so you are opening the door and
checking who is it
so in this scenario so someone ringing
the bell is the event
and you getting up and
going and saying so who is it and
accordingly responding so that would be
the function so that is the action so
you that particular event
doorbell ringing has triggered you to do
or take some action which is your
function
so we will see more about this event so
in this project we'll have a lot of
errors and we will also be handling
those using some functions and actions
so
what next
here in our um project so in this
demo that we will be seeing
what are we going to do so what is the
take away so what can you expect out of
this so you can see this screenshot
so this is the web page that you will be
creating
now this webpage as i told you earlier
it is a movie website um so it's like a
movie webpage it's a single page that we
are going to create
and you can see a list of movies to
watch some latest movie
so you also have some red color buttons
to your right
so these buttons like
so here it is written as
delete button and there is also a green
color add button over there which is at
the end of the page
where you can input some movie name and
you can dynamically add it now all these
we are doing via javascript so you can
statically add it also using your html
but in this particular example so we are
going to use javascript to dynamically
add
a new movie
and if you want to delete those movie we
are going to delete that also so this is
what we are going to see as an example
and in this demo application so when you
can create these uh details of the
movies
now i have to say something here so i
have styled this using css
but we will not be going in depth into
the css because that is not in our scope
but i will walk you through the code
that i have written so that you get this
beautiful you know the background image
and the alignment and margin and padding
those are the properties that i have
included to get this style so i will
walk you through that then once that is
done so we'll focus more on our
javascript code so that we can create
this particular
movie website in an easier so very very
simpler easier manner so how we can
implement this particular
concept of damn door manipulation so
that we will be seeing in our movie
project
okay so let's get started
and before we begin with the actual
coding
of creating a new movie and
deleting a movie so before we do that
i would like to walk you through the
actual application
so let's get started on that
so before we get on to the coding and
stuff so i would like you to
take a look at the final webpage or the
website that you would be creating
so
let's take a look at that now so this
will be the um website that you will be
uh developing so you can see that it's a
movie web page it's it's kind of a
single page uh
application because we are creating
just one single
web page for this particular demo so you
can create any number of pages you want
later
but for this we are just going to create
one index.html
now in this if you can see there is a
list of movies here popular movies
yeah so most of my favorites that you
can see and as i move my cursor you can
see that there is a purple color um like
a border that's actually a border that i
have written in css it's a border
property
so you can see that on the left which is
highlighting that particular row
and you also can see a corresponding
button in red which is the delete button
so when i press it's going to delete
that particular movie
and you also can see a text box at the
end of this page and there is a green
color button to add a new movie for this
so
you can see the entire page has been
styled in css so it looks
quite appealing so i have given an image
which
emulates like a movie screen movie
theater screen
and there is a card that you can see so
this is the card
and so which has this title and a tag
line
and all these have been aesthetically
arranged here as you can see so this lot
of css here so which
goes about to create the theme and style
of any web page
so css is very very important so if you
have to
attract any um
you know probable
customer for your page or for your
business the
something that is very important the
entity that is very important is your
style
or your theme so the css plays a major
role over here
so i will show you the um you know i
will have a code walkthrough of how i
have styled using css so let's try to
add a movie over here you also can see
there is a
placeholder tip also text also over
there
um
let's go on with this
movie
yeah the popular one
so let's say add and you can see
instantly now
avengers getting added at the end of
this particular row
and you also can see that there is a
delete button that got added
automatically so if i have to delete a
movie
so you can see that it just goes off
instantly
and i have to remind you um so this is
not
linked to any database so it's not
persistently stored so if i have to
refresh it you get everything back so
this is just like stored in
an array so it's just a list of movies
that we are just going to store in the
page so if you have to have these
changes reflected of course you'll have
to connect it to a database so this is
what we are going to do
um so using the dom and using the
javascript feature so how are we going
to add an entity or element to your dom
and how are we going to delete it
so this is what you can expect out of
this demo
all right so
here we are in the editor
i'm using visual studio code so this is
the editor
that i'm using currently
i do use other editors like sublime
brackets webstorm
so this is purely up to you
whichever is the editor that you're
comfortable with and you're already
working even if it is going to be
notepad plus plus
um or if you're from a java background
and you use eclipse more you can go
ahead with eclipse
so whatever is your editor your
preferred preferred choice
uh you can go with that
visual studio code have been working
since the inception so i have i'm also
from the dot net background so i've
worked
exhaustively with visual studio also
so here this editor is very comfortable
in many ways it is just not for
javascript
it you also can use vs code for
angular or react or python any other uh
type of technology that you choose any
type of web development you can use
visual studio so it has a very nice
intuitive and simple user interface and
it has an integrated terminal so where
you can run your server also and it has
a very good debugging
options with intelli sense and you can
install
packages on the go and you can also use
this particular space for deployment
also so it's pretty um easy and
comfortable
so if you prefer visual studio
and you're from that
background or you have been using
exhaustively for means tag or monster so
you can use visual studio otherwise it's
completely up to your choice
so you can see that i have a folder
which is called as dom demo
where i already have three files there
so
two of which is nothing but some
pictures so this is the background so
that i'll be using
so
if you could recollect so i had shown
you the uh
web page with that theater background so
i will be using these two images for
that so you can take a look at it
so you can see this one right you could
recollect that so i
will be using this for background and
where i will be listing out the movies
uh so i will be using this
image i will not be using the entire
image i will be cropping and i will be
using it
and the all these style uh to use these
images for other
style features also for including those
buttons and you know the rows
all these i have used css
cascading style sheet
and so this is the style that i will be
including so
so i will not be um
you know explaining each and everything
so i presume so you all have some basic
knowledge of css
and html
so what
i have done briefly to get that style i
will explain it in a very um
precise concise manner so that like
you will get an idea like where what
feature i have included and you can
explore on your own
these style features
so you can see that the background image
i have added as this property and the
size font family and colors and spacing
i have set
this is for the heading and
so you should be knowing about different
types of selectors like id selector
stack selector class selector so this
hash denotes the id selector
so i will be using this id selector when
i'm creating my html page
so what i have done is for that
particular i'm creating one container
okay so for that container i'm giving a
name called as a wrapper
so where this container is the one which
is going to
list out all the movies for us so the
margin padding border now these are very
very important so if you want to have a
evenly aligned
readable legible list or text or content
so you have to play around with these
different properties of css
and you also can see that
there is a page banner so
this is the outermost container then i
will also be showing an image within
that where the movie list
will be displayed and within that i will
be giving the you know the top movies
that list so for that and the paragraph
for the tagline so some of these
alignment features and width and margin
i have given
so you also can see that i have given
certain elements
with these ids movie list and this is
for the button add movie
margin has been given there
and the list i do it's an unordered list
so unordered list um
i don't want to specify any particular
bullets there so ordered list will be
having like one two three or abcd
unordered usually bullets will be
displayed so i don't want any bullets so
i am displaying that as none
and so this is the one
i have used for the list items that you
can see
and by default if i don't move the
cursor the border left if you can
recollect i had one purple color one
right which got highlighted only on the
left border
um so
by default i have made it as you know
gray so but when i hover the the so this
is the pseudo list so when i hover over
it so the state it gets changed so it
becomes the color becomes purple here
and these are the style features that
you can see for the
delete button
so this is the delete button so it's a
class so that's why it has this period
symbol
and
so what are the different so it has a
radius it has a rounded corners that
button
and the text is white so all these and
again like when i hover so from red it
changes the background color
and you also can see um this is the
style for the add movie button you can
see that so this is predominantly it is
an um gray color
and so this is for the input which is
your text box
and this this is the add movie button so
this particular
button so i have made it as green
and you can see the other features also
and again so however it becomes like a
dark green so these things and all you
can change
right and for these labels so for all
the elements um that i will be creating
now in the index.html so
this is the style that i'm going to
apply so
you can
go ahead with your own style there is no
restriction so you can change the color
the alignment you want to change the the
background layout so completely to you
so our focus is not css
for this particular demo so our focus is
on the javascripts done manipulation
all right so let's start creating our
webpage
so the first step how do we create our
web page is by creating a html page
um
after we create a html page and
set those content you know the list of
movies
will try to create uh the most important
file which is your javascript file and
we will connect all these together to
your html file so we already have the
styles.css in place
so after we create our html page we will
be creating the javascript
page also and we will be connecting all
these three together
so here you can see there is an icon
which states new file
and
so let's get this name
index.html and you can see the icon gets
magically changed over there
so
i have a corresponding
uh
you know
extension
file
which
actually
gives all these extensions that logos
will be
automatically updated so you might not
be having that uh by default so if you
want you can just go ahead
with your
these extensions
you can see that so you can see this
this is the one that i have already
included ps code icons so if you want to
have those logos so that you have a
clear picture of what you're creating
you will be able to do it so here we
also can create one more which is your
app dot
js this is the one that you will be
creating next
so you can see this js icon also pops up
nicely so by default you might not be uh
seeing this icon so but if you have that
particular extension that file you
should be able to see it
all right so
inside my
index.html so let's start with our
coding
so first thing so you can see that very
nicely this intellisense is also popping
up
okay so here i say that it is a html5
document
so the html document earlier we had html
4 version for many many years
so recently it was upgraded
w3c which is our world wide web upgraded
that to the next level which is your
html file so here
this particular the first line where it
denotes the name space it's much more
concise and precise now otherwise if you
know about if you have already coded in
html4 you will know the pain of writing
that you know lines and lines of that
name space so the first line indicates
that it is a html5 document
so now we will have to specify the root
element or
the parent element or the outermost one
which is our html so all our tags and
elements goes inside this
html tag
so we have this head
and we also have the body
so
so head as i told you earlier
during the uh discussion so where i was
saying that all the metadata
and other
properties like your title and
so if you want to link other files like
your styles or your script everything
goes inside your head um having said
that you also can include your
script src anywhere inside your body
also you can have more than
one script source also
not necessarily that it has to be inside
your head only
but we specify some metadata and other
um
within your head elements so here i'm
including one character set here so this
is the
default one which is your unicode
okay eight so
not mandatory but you can include this
one and as i told you we can also
include your style and we also can
include your script but we'll do that
later so right now i'll just include my
title so which will be displayed on the
web page uh title bar on the
topmost one that you can see
i will say
movie
right so now this goes inside the head
inside our body as i told you
while we were going through this style
so we have already created this
outermost container and i have given
some name for that so we will be using
this
in our html
content so where i am going to create a
dip
and all the id
so will be represented as hash that you
will be using in your css so you can see
this one so
i've used this hash it means that we'll
have to use an id over here
so
let's say
wrapper
now this is going to be my outermost div
and all the other elements are going to
be present inside this dip
and inside my div i'm going to have a
head down so this is a html element
header
and inside this header i'm going to have
the title
so which says movie time and it also has
a tag line i showed you in the finished
web page
so
those
movie title as well as the tagline i'm
going to include it here
so inside my header
i'm going to have this one more
and i've already created the style for
this
so this will be the page banner
and
inside
my page banner
i'm going to have this title
so the movie title i'm going to use h1
over here
and
i'm also giving the class because i've
already defined
and
you also can define the style outside or
you can have a style inside the head
that you can refer so in that case it
would be referred as internal style now
this will be external style but if you
want you can also have an inline style
say for example
i can include a style
property here so this will become the
inline style of h1
which will have the highest precedence
so
in this i say i want to have a white
color
so you can either
pick from the text as such or you also
can give this hex value
so both are same
then after that so all your css
properties are terminated by a semicolon
and it uh it's
separated with this colon like this
property
name and the value separated by
colon and
the statement it ends with a semicolon
so here you specify whatever is the
heading that you wish to display
and
next
we will be
giving the tag line
so let's also have an inline element for
the tagline
so we'll be using the same thing which
is the white text since we are going to
have a colored background
so we are using the white text here so
i'm copying and pasting it here
yeah
so here
so we'll have to close this
here let's say
[Music]
curated
stuff most
amazing
movies
so you can
write your text like however you want so
however you want to
display those tag lines and the title
so
i'm closing my
paragraph here
and i'm also giving a break
there
and so with this this particular dev
which is the page banner so this is over
so i've created this page banner just to
display this is the entire thing is your
header you can see
so this is your
which is your banner and this entire
thing is my wrapper so i i still have my
list of movies that will be coming up
here in this section so this will be the
title and the tagline
so after this
header i want to include a div
which is going to be my movie list
so we'll call this
movie
different list
and inside which i'm going to
have
um the title again something like a
subtitle
so i'm using my
h2 so where i say
again i get this
title class so which will be used in
styling
and
within which i will say
movies to what so this will be the title
for the list
so after which we are going to include
our unordered list of movies
now inside which
inside the unordered list i'm going to
have now
see two things here um
if you could recollect the uh that movie
page that i had shown
we will be uh creating the name of the
movie
in the in the row wise format and
it will also be having the
[Music]
delete button so you would be able to
see that the delete button would be
there
and
so
both elements have to be there for each
movie list so i will be specifying the
name of the movie here
and i will also be specifying the
delete button so inside my
list item i'm going to have a span
now this span
so i'll say
so it'll have name
and
where let's include the first one
and turn
and i will be including a span element
for the
delete button also
and i will just say delete
okay
so let me copy this one because we are
just going to use this for all the this
particular style for all our
movies so i'm copying this and i'm
pasting
maybe
four or five movies
so
[Music]
three
two and five
okay so let's
write whatever movies that you want over
here so let me just change these movies
quickly
okay so all of my favorite movies
inception again
yeah
and
stage
okay
all right so the last one maybe i have
included one extra it's okay
um
just the avengers or avengers okay
whatever so i have uh included this five
movies now
so with this this movie list is over
so
now next what we will do is we'll have
to do one more thing before we move on
to javascript file
so in this one we have to create
our
we will be having a form element here
the main reason being we have to include
a submit button so that
i can
inform the javascript module or the
function so which can handle
the addition of new movie when i have to
click on the add button here
so
i'm giving a name for the id
so this will be the forms which will be
the parent element and inside the form
i'm going to
what we are going to have is we are
going to have the
button
and also the input box
so the input
the text box we will be including so you
can see the list of
input
elements of your html so we'll be
selecting text
and we can have a placeholder it's
nothing but the text
so
where i can specify okay so this is
this should not be inside
so this is text
so the placeholder property where you
can give some hint
of what is supposed to be entered in
that
text box so i'll say add
[Music]
so let's close this
input box
now this
button let's add
so now this is going to invoke the
function which we will be adding in the
javascript
page
so with this
we have closed this form and we have
also closed this div and the body so
with this the
html content the code for the html
content is ready
so if you have to see this
page so
i have this option set up here so open
in default browser
so when i click this one
okay so you can see this and so if
you're wondering why is this blank over
here
you can see this here now yeah
it's the
main reason is i've given white text
because we'll have to include the style
we have not included the style yet so
just the html content it looks like this
so it's not it doesn't look so great i
know
so there is no
javascript
function also
but we can see that whatever content
that we have mentioned
so
it has been
displayed properly so the next step
for us to do is to
add the css and see if it matches the
style that i had shown earlier
so if you have to add the css so let's
see
okay so we have now seen before adding
csu so i keep saying about the
importance of the style and theme also
so i know your content is ready but it
doesn't look so attractive so how could
you make it so engaging
and
so that the probable customer or your
business user can start using your web
page so how can you make it much more
engaging and attractive
let's add the css and see
if it creates a magic or not
i know this is not our prime focus but
css definitely helps
so
the link is the
tag that we will be
using to
specify the reference so this is the
reference where i have to add so
whatever is your css style so this is a
external style so i use my href property
to attach this
external style here so i'll have to
include so you can see that it gets
listed yes
and
it's not mandatory but still you can
mention
that it is a style sheet
so css is the default style sheet and
javascript is the default
scripting language for your html so we
have attached this now
okay
so
let us see again
okay look at that now look at that
so you can see this before css
so
literally it is uh nothing it doesn't
look like anything at all but you can
see like after css so if you are
if you have
fancy taking for your forms if you love
fonts maybe you can change all these
fonts i've used some default fonts
so
however you want you can
go ahead and change it you can see that
whatever we have given in the css that i
have highlighted
it's now
getting reflected in this new page so
you can see the difference between this
and so that's why i opened another tab
for you to show the see the difference
but nothing is going to work so you can
see that the hover so you can see the
red is changing into maroon and this
may be not much of a difference but you
still can see i would say if you're
using css don't change those
text size and
you know the alignment and
placing because
there it the effect that you will be
getting where it will be like flickering
a lot and it will be the alignment will
be an issue always change the color or
some highlight those things not the size
and alignment so you can also see like
how nicely these rows are getting
highlighted
so now whatever we add
so
nothing is going to be
coming on because we don't have a
javascript
functionality yet so that is what we are
going to see now next so let's start
our javascript coding which will be the
next module
now let's start with the
app.js which will be your javascript
file that you will be
including and coding for dom
manipulation
so this app.js file has to be integrated
inside your
index.html so how we have included our
style we will have to use another
element which is your script and we have
to include src instead of href so that
we will do it later so now let's start
creating this code for the app.js
so let's start with this document
element and we will have to do the
coding for
one of the event so we'll be writing
those functionality whatever
we have done so we are going to create
the event and attach your
functionality for that particular event
so
there are ways different ways by which
you can do it and event listener is one
of the way so i can specify so as you
can see in this intellisense this purple
color box indicates that it is a method
so you can see that it is a method and
this blue brick that you see so that is
a property so
we'll be using this method
so i'm adding an event over here so what
is the event that we are going to add
now so we are adding this
event which is called as the dom
so i will explain so what exactly is
this
dom content loaded
now this event fires when the initial
html document
has been completely loaded and passed
so
without for other dependencies like your
css file style sheets images or any
other elements to finish loading so your
original content
so if it is loaded and passed this event
will be filed
and
the target for this event is your
document itself and that has to be
loaded and you can listen for this event
on the window interface to handle it in
the um capturing bubbling or the
tumbling phase so javascript event has
different type of phases also
when the event can traverse
um
inside from your parent to your child so
that it can be handled at that level
also it's called as your tunneling and
when it has to go upwards so it will be
like bubbling face so so different ways
by
how your event can traverse and it can
be captured
so there is another event which is
called as load now that will be
you will not be using that
for this particular purpose so here i am
just using this event
to check if the content if that
particular document your html document
is loaded uh without the other
dependencies that's what i said without
the style sheet or other features to be
loaded but another event is there which
is called as just load and it should be
used to
uh today to detect a fully loaded page
along with style sheet and everything so
it's usually
people confuse between
this load and the document content
loaded so understand the difference for
load it is like fully loaded whereas dom
content loaded is only when the dom
features or the html content is loaded
so let's write the function
for this so
we will be using this syntax so first is
this event name and here we are going to
include the function so all other
function that we will be including so it
will be going inside this
main function that i have
first thing that i am going to do is
create a variable in this case we will
be creating a constant because we are
not going to change anything
to capture where exactly these
event and the functions will be affected
so in our case the list movie list is
where we are concerned we can add a
movie we can delete the movie so we have
to create um
entity which can refer to that
particular list so i am creating so you
can use a var also
here since this is not going to be
changing so i'm using a constant
so i'm using this method which is called
as your query selector by which
you can select that particular
um
you know the element whatever element
that you have created so here i want to
select my
unordered list so i'm using this movie
so it is present inside
container which is called as your movie
list so inside which
i am selecting this unordered list and
that is getting stored in this list so
this is um
it's like
disabled or like grayed out because we
have not used this list object yet so
when we use it so it will be highlighted
i am also going to create one more
to store my form
so
whatever forms you can have like
multiple forms also and all the form
elements i'm storing here
and so let's do the first one say
if i have to delete
my movies so to delete these movie
i'm going to attach so we have already
created that list so to that list now i
told you right so now if you start using
it it will be highlighted so you can see
that one
so i'm adding another event listener so
whenever i'm going to click that
i'm going to check if the user is
clicking the delete button or he's
clicking something else so
i'm using this
click
event so i'm attaching a event
an event handler i'm attaching over here
and then i'm also
you can also pass on another parameter
so in this case i am passing some e
parameter which is you can also name it
as event also um
or whatever name that you want so this
event parameter is nothing but all the
metadata will be
stored in that particular
um
object e or the event object so it will
have all the necessary
properties stored there so you can find
out the source of the event you can find
out the target of even so everything
will be stored in the event object so
here i'm checking using my if condition
so i'm checking if the target
okay so if the target element
has i told you the event object will
have the source where it originated and
which is the target so here i'm checking
if the class name is equal to is equal
to
delete meaning if i'm trying to click on
the delete button i'm checking that so
if it is right so if it is true
then i am creating a
li
which is your list item and i am trying
to remove that particular
element there so i am saying that target
so i am saying which is the parent see
when i have to delete the element it has
to delete the entire
ally right including the span which is
the movie text also one more span which
has the delete button
so i have to delete the parent element
so here
i'm mentioning that i'm creating the li
which is the parent element
and
now i say
the parent node of this particular li
so i want to delete this so
to delete an entity in dom if you have
to do it you have an
uh method which is called as your remote
child so you can see that
so
the parent node along with your so both
your spam so the entire li element i
have to remove
so i am removing it like this i am
calling this method which is called as
your remote child which is going to
remove that particular li element
so now this is with your
li
so here we have added this and
we are trying to delete it
so this is
one of the functionality and the next
one that we have to do is
add movies
um so before adding the movie so let's
see if this is going to really work
so for that we have to include one more
step what is that yes right we have to
attach it so your
index.html does not have this
app.js
linked yet so
let's
add that so here we'll be using script
src
is equal to so this is my app.js and
let's include this one
so once you have included
um so in my app.js
i have given the
main
dom contact loaded event so underneath i
have these
different features included
one is the deleting the movie one is
deleting the movie another one that we
will be writing is adding the movie
so let's see if this is
going to work or not
so go back to this
i've already added
the script and
so you can open it so you can refresh
the existing page also let us see if the
delete button really works now
yes it works
so
okay i just deleted everything but as i
told you earlier
this is um
this is not a permanent database that
you will be like storing
so these does not get reflected
persistent in a persistent way
so when we refresh the page we are going
to get it back but we can see that the
deletion
by our dom manipulation using javascript
code has worked successfully now so we
are done with the first feature so we
will have to move on to the second one
where we can add a new movie and when we
click on this button it has to be
instantly added let us go back to the
editor to add the
next feature now
so let's get started with adding the
new movie
so
it's not like the straightforward delete
feature
there are certain series of steps that
is involved
when we are adding a new movie
so first being to
creating the elements look whatever
elements that we are going to add so
it's just not one
uh text or the movie list we also have
to add the delete button along with that
right so that would be the first one and
the second one would be to add
the
text
content as such so what is the
text content or value what is the new
one so the delete text and also the name
of the movie so that has to be added
and you can see that each and every um
you know these it has a distinctive
style property the left a purple border
when it is highlighted and each row it
also has a delete which is like a red
color
button which is curved on the edges so
these different style features have to
be included so how do we do that
so that would be another step that we
have to do which is adding the classes
and finally we will have to attach it to
the dom
so then you attach it to your dom
element
so let's start with the first phase
so
all these element now it's present in
the form so from the form we are trying
to add
the new
movie new element so for that we'll have
to capture the form so form is in the
form of an array
so each html element can have n number
of forms
so we have already given the id as add
movie for that form we just have one
form so we are
retrieving that and i'm storing it
inside my add form
constant
next
so i'm using this add form to add this
event listener over here
so when the
button so which is so here you can have
all these events so here i'm saying
submit is the event so submit is the
most important event so by which you can
actually submit the value
otherwise um
whatever changes that needs to be
captured will not be done properly
so i'm including this
function
and again i'm passing this event object
which is your e
so now here
um
i'm adding all these ones so
first one that i'm doing over here is to
include your
prevent
default
this proven default method
cancels the event
if it is
cancelable meaning that the default
action that the
that belongs to the event will not occur
say for instance if we have to use it
for a when the user clicks on a submit
button but it has to prevent that
clicking or submitting of a form or
there is a
clicking on a hyperlink or something but
it should be prevented so these default
actions now if you want to prevent
uh so you can use this one so here we
are going to use it because we don't
want this to be
literally
bubbled up and but you also have to note
that not all events are cancelable
you can use the cancelable property to
find out if some event is cancelable or
not and these this particular prevent
default
method
also does not prevent further
propagation of an event through the
drawn so if you want to literally stop
it so there is another method which is
called a stop
propagation
so
we are invoking this uh method first and
so let me just close this one also
and i want all these other
feature to be included within this one
okay
so
first step after creating the capturing
the form element
i want to create the other constants
for these values and
elements the other elements so first
thing
i am creating a constant called as
value
now here
i am selecting the using the query
selector again this method again
and i want to retrieve this
input type so where i say
my text box so i want to retrieve it so
where i say the
type as
text so
i want to retrieve the input type where
the type as
text
so be very careful with the
codes so if you are using the double
quotes as the outer one just use it for
that and use an inner for the inner code
use a single code so vice versa
so check on that
and how it is closing
so otherwise it will not throw any error
but you will not be getting the value
that you expect also
and the second constant that i want to
create it is for the list item so here i
have the document
and here we are going to use this
special
method you can see that there are so
many number of create element creative
and many create methods are there as a
part of
javascript dom feature
so we are going to use this one create
element and i am going to create a new
li element
because this is the one that we want
which needs to be added to the unordered
list
and of course we will have to create the
um
the corresponding variable or the
constant for the
name of the movie so that has to be
there right so i'll have to create
that one so
that one again is
as you can see it's a spam
so
i'll show you the html code here
so quickly let's go
and so you can see this one so this is
what we are trying to create here in
this feature so i will have to create
two elements over here so one is for the
movie another spam is for the delete
button so these two has to be created so
this is a span and you can see that the
class will have to add next
but this li element we have to create it
like this that is what we are doing here
so i'm creating a span so
one is for the movie name and another
one we have to create a
delete button
so if we have to create a new record so
each record has a movie name as well as
the delete button
so i'm going to create that as well
so
in this one again so what is the element
that we will be creating in both the
cases both are span which is present
inside li so li is the parent element
and these two span will be the child
element so all these have been now
created
individually or separately we have
created now we have to set the hierarchy
so we have to append these two as child
of this li and this li has to be
attached to this
body so this one so this appending will
do it at the last right so first step we
have created this
elements so first we have retrieved the
movie and we have added attached event
listener for the submit button
and
then in the second one second phase of
creating elements we have created so we
have uh checked if whatever is the value
that the user is entering inside the
text box so using that we are going to
create it so
then we have created the alloy element
which is your list item and then the
span element for the movie name span
element for the delete button so all
these have been created now let's go to
the next phase which is to add the text
content so we have already received the
value that the user has entered in the
text box and we are storing it in big
constant called as value so now that we
have to attach it to this particular
element which is the movie name okay so
that will be the next one so here i will
say movie name
dot so it has this property as you can
see which is called as a text content so
so this is the span element so if you
have to create a text for that so i am
saying that whatever the user has
entered in the text box that is stored
in the value constant so that i am
storing it here that i am passing to my
text content property of the movie name
which is nothing but the span that we
have created
now the second one we have also created
this delete button span right so that
so
content we have to create so which is
nothing but the text that will be
displayed so here we are creating the
button as delete button
okay so however you want to create it
remove or the d caps however you want to
create you can go ahead and create it
so
now this step is also over so first we
have created this form and then we have
created all these elements the
corresponding li and then the movie name
span delete button span
and then we have also attached the
corresponding content for these two span
elements
now we have to add the style so of
course
you can see like how it is displayed
so this one has a red color buttons and
then you can see the different
these borders so that we have already
created in the external style sheet
this has to be updated here
so
we are doing this
so i say class list
dot add so this is add
so we are adding the
class name
for the corresponding element that we
have created so that you get the uh
style feature that we have already
defined
okay
by default it goes on with your ad event
listener
all right so this is this is the class
name
okay so we are adding it so let's go to
the style.css
and so you can see this
delete
and
name so all these are present over here
right so all these are there so i want
to attach so you can see this one name
and delete it already has this one so
that we are trying to attach it here so
this step is also over so we are
attaching the class for the style or the
theme purpose
now final and most important one is to
attach it to the dom so that
all your content along all your elements
along with those textual content
added with those class properties with
the css features now it is all rendered
onto your dom in a proper hierarchical
way so that is now is very important so
that is the final step
so i am saying li so now li is your
parent element right
so
i am attaching my li
first your li has to be attached to the
list
i think we have already created this
list which is nothing but the unordered
list so this li has to be attached to
the list
and
inside your li these two
spans your movie name and delete button
both has to be attached so your movie
name and delete button are the child
elements of li and li is the child
element of your
uh list so it has to be attached so
first let's
let's attach your
[Music]
movie name so the child of your
ally which is the first span
and
i'm also
attaching the
delete
button so which is another spam child
and finally i'm attaching the
li
which is in turn a child of the
list element
okay so here i say list dot append child
which is your ally
okay but inside your li you can see the
movie name and delete button we can go
to the index.html to check so ul or the
list is the parent element
inside which i have my li
list item and the li is it becomes the
parent for these two which is the name
of the movie and the delete button for
each corresponding record so these two
child element first we are attaching to
a line and then this l line we are
attaching is uh to the ul so that is
what we are doing here
right so this will be the final and most
important step
so with this we are done with our
script
so
make sure you save this one
and let's go back
to this
and refresh it once
okay so this delete button it is working
as usual
we have already seen that and
let's see if a
new movie can be inserted
okay let's say
wow now you can see that instantly
new
movie has been
added at the bottom and you can see
the two span elements
okay which is the child of the zli it
gets added to the
parent which is the list item so this is
the outermost one which is the uh ul or
your list type list
and then each one is the child which is
your life the li has two child which is
your movie name as well as the delete
button so we have first created these
values
and then
the classes have been added
to ensure that the css is consistent
and then finally we use the doms append
child you can use your append method
also to attach it so that this hierarchy
is formed so using dom manipulation via
javascript so
we have seen that as a very very
um
powerful in a very in a powerful way
and in a very uh simpler and effective
way how we can
add
new elements new nodes attach events
listen to events and
also to delete it all these it can be
done so effectively
so you can keep adding
or you can try to validate this also
and say if i want to edit this i won't
edit the existing movies even that it is
completely possible you can do that or
only the style if you want you can
change that style also so everything
just with javascript so just with
javascript so how you can create the
element so without the html content at
all you can just write from the heading
to the footer to the content everything
you can create
just with your javascript so that is the
power of javascript so
i think we have done quite enough with
this
manipulation so for a quick recap
we started with these three files so
style dot css so i walked you through
the entire style and theme features i
have incorporated and we also had these
two
images already so you can include so
this is just an overview
guideline of how this dom can be
manipulated in one way
you are free to explore
uh having this as a base and you can
just work upon how you want to
carry on with your dom manipulation so
we created first this index.html so we
created all the content uh the head and
body and initially we didn't attach it
with the style sheet as well as the
script
then we created those containers the
wrapper and page banner so that we had
the corresponding styles for all these
and we also created a
ul which is an unordered list with all
these list items so these list item
internally so it has each one had two
span
one is the name of the movie another one
is the delete button for the movie
and you also
can see that last we have also added an
input element for the text box where you
can add the movie and also a button to
submit so that the
new movie has been inserted
so after this we created this
javascript coding so we started with the
dom content loaded and first we saw the
delete movie uh we use the event
listener when whenever i click on the
delete button so based on the event
object i checked for the target and i am
removing that particular element so i am
using the remote child over here for
deleting a movie or deleting any
particular node as such and we are using
happen child to add the movie so these
two are the important functions that you
have to keep in mind and in the second
one we added a movie first we created
this form we captured this
and then we created those individual
elements the allies pan for the movie
name and delete button and we also had
those values that needs to be written
which was added and then we added the
class and finally we use the append
child to append these two span element
to the li and then li which is the child
of your list gets added
so that is how we saw this
dom manipulation i hope you all enjoyed
this uh demo and also your the concept
of your dom manipulation via javascript
is clear to all of you let's consider a
discussion between joe and jess
joe wishes to learn javascript but is
overwhelmed with the vast amount of
content to cover
jess kindly helps in creating a learning
path to make things easier for joe
if you're looking for assistance with
this too then you're in the right place
so let's begin
to make things easier i'll classify the
topics into fundamentals advanced level
topics web platform and other tools and
frameworks
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already then
make sure you hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
first let's begin with javascript
fundamentals i'm sure these are topics
that everybody has already learned
however getting a fundamental
strong lays the foundation for better
and faster learning
some of these include the lexical
structure of javascript
javascript variables types and
expressions
javascript functions which include the
function constructor self-invoking
functions functions as values and
objects arrow functions generator
functions and predefined functions
then there's javascript arrays it could
be array methods mapreduce and filter
then there's javascript loops which
include the for loop for in loop while
loop and the do-loop
and then we have objects which include
creating objects object properties
methods and accessors
moving on there is data structures like
boolean string number null undefined
there's control flow statements like if
else there's data object
there's type conversions that is
converting from one data type to another
then there's mathematical operators and
lastly there's scope and javascript that
talk about the local and global
variables
now once you've laid your foundation
strong you can go ahead and work on more
advanced topics
now let's have a look at them
first one
being call backs now this is a pillar
for something called as asynchronous
programming
and then there's promises
and finally there's async await that are
built on promises to achieve
asynchronous programming
there's closures that are an extension
of variable scope and define how global
and local variables are accessed
the next important concept to learn is
timers that help in delaying the
execution of certain code or functions
then there's prototyping
followed by inheritance now they specify
how javascript objects inherit
properties and methods from a prototype
next up there's binding
there's also regular expressions where
you'll have to learn about
flags patterns quantifiers
meta characters and basic string search
and replacement techniques
lastly we have unicode
event loops which involve blocking an
event creating a simple event
and lastly we have generators
moving on let's look at some of the
important web platform tools required to
master javascript
first up we have cookies that talk about
how to create read change and delete
cookies for any web browser
there's local storage that is you'll
have to know how data is being stored
locally on the browser
we have apis or application programming
interfaces that define how to extend
functionalities to a browser one such
important api is the fetch api which is
important to request resources be it
network resources or database resources
finally there's the document object
model that defines how anything that is
being changed on the browser is
affecting the model state and vice versa
and lastly we have service worker which
is basically a script that runs in the
background of a web browser and assists
in offline app development
moving on let's have a look at the tools
supported by javascript
now javascript offers a wide range of
these libraries and frameworks however
you could choose to learn whichever that
suits your interest and requirements
firstly there's react which is an
excellent javascript front-end library
that helps create interactive web pages
now there's angular which is a
javascript framework that is used to
create a single page applications
next up we have view which is also a
front-end javascript framework used to
create single page applications now
although these libraries and frameworks
have the same objectives their
underlying architecture and working
differ and as a result of this different
people prefer different frameworks and
libraries for app development you can
choose the one you wish to learn and go
for it
next up is typescript
now typescript basically defines a set
of types to javascript and helps users
write javascript code that is easier to
understand
typically all the typescript code
compiles down to javascript code
next framework is electron now this
framework again enables you to create
desktop applications with the help of
javascript html and css
and lastly there's jquery now jquery is
a lightweight write less do-more
javascript library
the purpose of jquery is to make it much
easier to use javascript on your website
it does so by simplifying ajax calls and
dom manipulation
now to give you a simple overview of
what we've learned
we have beginner level or fundamental
topics then we have the advanced level
topics there's web platform and finally
there's tools
but you must be wondering how can we
help you
now one thing you could do is take up a
simply learn certification course
now
to help you understand this better let
me just open the website
here you can type in javascript
and there are a few courses and masters
program that we provide you have the
node.js training course and then there's
the full stack developer meanstag
masters program you can also click on
them and go through the overview and if
you think this is what you're looking
for you can go ahead and take up the
course in this video we're going to talk
about how to become a full stack
developer now there are a lot of
aspiring full stack developers out there
so i'm sure this video will help you all
out
so here are the topics that we're going
to be discussing so first we'll see what
full stack development is who is a full
stack developer then we'll move on to
the responsibilities and then we'll dive
into the detailed roadmap and then also
let you know about the salaries of full
stack developers
and finally how you can get
certifications
all right now what exactly is full stack
development
now consider a web application let's say
instagram
so every time you refresh the page new
images are loaded
so this is what the user experiences
right new images are loaded onto his
feed
but what exactly happens behind the
scenes is that the back end fetches new
images from the instagram servers and
these images are then loaded onto your
instagram feed right the app is so easy
to use and leaves the users extremely
satisfied
in case of any application there's
always the front end the back end and
the database
so the process of building all of these
aspects for an application is called
full stack development
so i hope you understood what exactly
full stack development is
so moving on
let's see who a full stack developer is
now basically a full stack developer
works with both front end and the back
end of an application
he has to be familiar with languages
like html css javascript and also one or
more back-end frameworks like node.js
and python
now these developers have got all the
web development skills to build websites
and applications from start to finish
now that we've understood what exactly a
full stack developer does let's look at
some of his responsibilities
now the first responsibility is
developing the front end so as discussed
they must be able to develop the user
interface for the users with the help of
html and css
next up is design the backend now this
is also the most crucial part of app
development they should be able to
design robust backend architecture to
ensure the smooth functioning of
fetching and updation
next up is to design database and
servers now databases and servers must
be resilient to any outages and must
maintain consistency
next up is cross platform compatibility
now depending on the platforms there
could be some discrepancy and alteration
in the functioning of an application
right it's crucial to make sure that the
applications behave accordingly on all
these platforms
next up is developing apis depending on
the plant architecture the developer
must be able to develop apis
the application must also be responsive
and interactive and keep the user
completely engaged
and lastly it should meet all the
technical and consumer requirements
so these were the few responsibilities
of a full stack developer
moving on let me explain to you a simple
roadmap of how to go about to become a
full stack developer
so this roadmap basically shows you the
prerequisites and skills one should have
to become a successful full-stack
developer
all right so let's go ahead and begin
with tools and software
now the first and the most rudimentary
requirement is a text editor now the
most widely used editor is vs code it is
free open source and can be used to code
in different platforms like windows mac
os and linux
next up is a web browser so you can
either use firefox or chrome but chrome
is highly preferred
now also you could need a few editor
extensions and vs code has a few of them
some of them could be live sas compiler
and live server
moving on you need to have a good hold
on html and css
so html is a markup language that is
used to define the content that appear
on your web page right the developer can
incorporate images text and videos
depending on the requirements
and moving on to css it is basically a
style sheet which is used to decorate
your entire application it is used to
define the appearance of the content say
in terms of shape color size spacing etc
next up is javascript now this is the
most widely used front-end language and
enhances the interaction with the web
page
now you might want to brush up your
knowledge on simple concepts like arrays
functions objects and loops
you can also learn es6 features like
callbacks promises a thinker wait
time manipulation and event fetch api
and json
all of these are required when you're
making use of different javascript
frameworks and libraries
so i'd recommend you brush up your
knowledge on all of these topics
react angular view and jquery are some
of the javascript libraries and
frameworks that one can use
now all of these topics that we
discussed earlier b8 esx features or
basic concepts they come in very handy
when you're using these frameworks
among react vue and angular over the
last couple of years react has gained
immense popularity
followed by which view is also being
widely used now angular has seen a
downward curve over the past few years
so depending on your requirements you
can choose one of these frameworks
next up is version control now git and
github are the most widely used version
control systems now git basically helps
you manage project files
git basically keeps track of the entire
history of things that the user is
working on right so it makes sure that
it allows the user to backtrack and see
what he's worked on until then
moving on to github it is basically a
web-based service for version control
using git
now the user can also look into other
people's code identify issues or errors
and also even propose changes now this
comes in extremely helpful when you're
working in a team
let's move ahead and look at some of the
backend environment now the most
popularly used environment is node.js
now this is basically an open source
cross-platform runtime environment that
allows developers to create server-side
tools and applications in javascript
now node is typically used to create
real-time applications with two-way
connections wherein both the client and
the servers can communicate and exchange
data without any hassle
now i really recommend you have a basic
knowledge on command line as well that
is now knowledge in basic command line
like npm that is note package manager is
also essential so this was a simple
overview on node.js
moving on to other backend languages
there's python and the most commonly
used framework that is django now python
is the easiest programming language out
there and i'm sure everybody will agree
with me with this
so it also offers many libraries and
frameworks for different technologies
so when it comes to back end in full
stack development django is a clear
winner now it is a high level python
framework that enables rapid development
of websites
it is also free and open source and has
a huge active community of users
so i'd really suggest you get your hands
on django and work on it extensively
moving on let me give you a brief
overview on the trends in 2020 first up
is blockchain
now blockchain is an emerging technology
and has seen tremendous growth in the
last few years
now it has also entered into domains
like healthcare and finance
next up is ai and chatbots
ai is booming and there is no doubt in
that
so languages like python and javascript
frameworks at tensorflow are widely used
mobile app development this is one of
the top trends you should look out for
in 2020. now there are mobile
applications for practically anything
these days so frameworks like react
native and flutter can be deployed to
develop these applications
next up is progressive web applications
now these are like a hybrid of mobile
and web apps they are faster to load and
provide some amazing features like push
notifications
another important feature is their
ability to work offline
lastly we have iot with the increasing
number of devices getting connected to
the internet every second
development of iot applications is also
on a rise
so these were a few trends that you
should look out for in 2020
moving ahead let's look at the salary of
full stack developers
now according to pay scale the average
salary of a full stack developer in
india is around 5 lakhs 90 000 rupees
per annum
the average salary of a full stack
developer in the us is around 75 000 us
dollars per annum
now there are several online
certification courses but if you're
looking for something that is concise
and well structured then head out to the
simply learn website and here you can
see a few options you have the full
stack java developer masters program you
have the full stackdeveloper.net masters
program
and you also have full stack web
developer mean stack masters program
you can also go through the overview
and depending on your requirement you
can choose the appropriate course
hello everybody so welcome you all so
this particular information is all about
giving you the idea of like what kind of
questions
it may be asked during the time of
interview which is related to your
javascript
so
this particular slides will help you to
understand what kind of questions you
may expect from your interviewer and
kind of answers you need to get ready
with let's get started with the
javascript interview questions
so let's get started with the beginner
javascript questions we have multiple
levels available here we start with the
beginner level first
so the first question is always like
what do you understand about javascript
so we know it very well the javascript
is a very very popular scripting
language it is basically designed for
client-side scripting
and server-side scripting development
why server-side because nowadays
javascript is also used in a back-end
using node.js so that's why it is also
called for server side development so
the question is like
uh javascript is
actually also helps the developers to
develop some more responsive html pages
okay which can be well understood and
executed by the web browser
okay which having the support
capabilities for object oriented
programming skills
now the next question is like what is
the difference between javascript and
java see the reason is because the
javascript initials are java so
everybody think like okay there is some
relationship with the java so actually
the thing is like there is no
relationship with java i would say
javascript is object based language
whether java is object oriented language
a lot of syntax
and some standards are matching with
java that's why exactly it is saying it
is javascript
otherwise there is nothing like that
but another difference if i talk about
javascript is mainly designed to run
with the browsers where the java is
designed especially for the virtual
machine and operating system
now another thing is like javascript
does not need a compilation because it
is directly used interpreter but when
you talk about called java it requires a
compiler as well as the interpreter both
now
what type of various data types are
supported so all standard
data type second byte short int long
float double character boolean
these all different type of data types
are supported in
javascript also just like in traditional
programming languages
okay
now
what are the features of javascript so
the first feature which you always
remember it's it is a lightweight
programming language it is
been interpreted by
the browsers rather than compiled
it is a cross platform that means it can
work across multiple browsers
so it is not specific to the browsers
so that we need to understand next it is
an open source hence you do not need to
pay for any licensing fees it comes free
with all different type of browsers
it is an object oriented but i would not
say that the pure object oriented i
would rather say it is an object based
language
next it can gel well
with multiple front-end as well as the
back-end technologies because most of
the languages which are coming up in a
market they have a support available to
get integrated with the javascript and
due to that javascript is very very
popular
so it is also used especially for the
development like a network based
application
so in case if you want to have some kind
of network centric application here the
javascript really suits very very well
okay
next question what are the advantages of
javascript so the first
advantage which we are talking about
like javascript basically have a very
very nice interactive language it is a
event-based
okay functional programming language i
would say so it is a quick feedback
because it loads very very fast
in your existing web pages
it is
giving you the support of developing a
very very rich user interface because of
that your application look consistent
across multiple type of browsers
another is like we have a call variety
of javascript based frameworks are
available like you can talk about
angular you talk about react you talk
about viewing they're all basically
different type of javascript based
frameworks that helps a developer to
enhance their skills
with writing less amount of codes
so how you create a script or how you
create an object in javascript it is
very simple the curly braces curly
braces is basically designed to give you
the feel of this is a typical object
there are a variety of ways are there to
create an object in javascript which
we're going to see
in our next video
okay now here we see about the next set
of questions which are there with us
like how to create an array in
javascript so creating an arrays
in javascript is very very easy now you
can see the square brackets
okay they are the way to basically
create an
array in the javascript so just a square
brackets are a very very simpler way so
called laterals to create
the array objects in javascript actually
you should know that array is also
object which is a predefined object
comes with your javascript
so called implicit objects
now what are the built-in methods
available in javascript so you remember
about these methods comes from those
built-in objects comes with your
javascript as we have mentioned in our
last slides
like math
boolean
string
okay
date they're all basically predefined
objects are available under those
objects these methods are actually
available like date if you can see it
will display the current date and time
concat to concat two different type of
string push some
adding some new records into your array
pop to remove
round to do the round
length to calculate the length of the
string so these are all some well-known
methods or frequently used methods
available in javascript
now what different type of scopes
available in javascript for the
variables now
so
scopes are basically designed to give
you the visibility
within your program
okay so different type of scopes are
available when it's called a global
scope so global scope is having the
availability within a file
anywhere else you can access this
particular code or particular variable
that is called global scope and local
scopes are those scopes which are
accessible within a function
and hence cannot be accessed by any
other function or outside of this
function so two standard type of scopes
which are available here
now what is this keyword in javascript
this means to refer the current object
okay so whenever you see that this
keyword it is designed to refer the
current object in
javascript so we typically define
this keyword to assign the value to my
current object properties
usually this is a place where that this
keyword is mostly used
now what are the conventions of
giving the names to the variables
okay so some standard naming convention
which we should always follow
but few things as you remember there are
certain reserve keywords
are there in javascript which you cannot
offer
while giving the names to your variables
or to your functions
like if i can say var
let cons and many more which are there
available which you cannot assign to
your any existing variable
provided or functions
under your javascript
now
here they are trying to say
variable names cannot begin with any
numeric value like you cannot give
var with abc so not abc i would say
rather one two three or something like
that so they must be a combination of i
would say integer as well as a character
okay so
they must only begin with letter or
underscore characters it is the same
like as we have it in java also
now
naming conventions are very very
important
javascript is a case sensitive hence
the small a and capital a have two
different meanings for the javascript so
that part needs to be well taken care of
now what is the callback in javascript
so you need to understand the callback
in javascript is a kind of function
which you are passing as in parameter to
the other function to execute
okay so callbacks are mainly designed
to
tell your application that
they need to wait rather than continue
to execute
so callbacks
will help you to behave
asynchronously and that's what exactly
this most
valuable feature of javascript
so as i discussed already so it is where
the function needs to be passed to get
executed
so how do you debug a javascript code so
to debug your javascript code in any
browser you can just press the f12
no matter which browser you have it
either chrome
or firefox or anyone you can just press
the f12 key and there
you can get this option called debugger
where you can just go and perform all
the necessary debugging related stuff
right over there
or so many other editors like in sublime
text visual studio code
atom
they're all offering you the built-in
support to debug your javascript code
now
what is the difference between
a function declaration and function
expression so this is a very very simple
difference
so when you say
function abc here
okay so you declare as a separate
statement within the same javascript
code
okay in another example what you do you
define a function within a variable name
called a
which you can create to construct some
another object for this
that's the only difference between these
two
so
this function can be called before the
function is
defined
and this will be created where the
function is pointing
and reaching it
okay so it can be used only after that
so that's what we have discussed it now
going forward
this offers the better code readability
and better code organization and that
the other part is basically used to
create a conditional or a declaration
functions
so what are the ways of adding the
javascript code in an html file so they
are
i would say
two ways are available one either you
can declare it in a separate file you
can add it or second you can write a
embedded javascript code where you can
just write a javascript code either in
your head tag or body tag but there will
be one difference like if you're writing
it as an embedded javascript you cannot
use it
for the different html file where the
internal javascript file will be limited
to that html however external javascript
will be more useful when you want to
reuse it again and again
so these were some
standard
basic javascript questions for us so
let's go ahead and talk about something
which is related to your intermediate
questions in javascript
now so what do you understand about the
cookies see the cookies are basically a
kind of a small text file okay which is
kept in your browser
and contains the information
about your client activities
okay so whenever the client is accessing
your websites
these websites
can track your activities through this
particular cookies
okay so this just basically record
your general
behaviors like what you're doing with
your website so that accordingly they
can give you
the better recommendations
now how you're gonna create a cookie in
your javascript so creating a cookie
cookie is one of the property available
under your document object so that you
can create it using document.cookie and
give a key so
your all cookie uh stands with your key
and value pair so you have a key you
have a value pair
so how you gonna read the cookie
so cookie you can read with the help of
the same property called document.cookie
and here you can just use this statement
like what key and value pair so whatever
the keys you have defined similar q will
be reading it to give the value of
whatever
option you want to read it
now how you gonna delete the cookie
so
cookie can be deleted it very easily by
calling this delete cookie function
where you can just tell about
the time and duration when you want the
cookie to be get deleted
so when you set the expiry time so
cookies are deleted
after specific period of time that will
be treated as a good programming
practice
so what is the difference between a
letter and var keyword see there is a
new feature which is there added called
let keyword which is known as called
block level scope the blockable scope
means
your variable whichever you're defining
under
any block level statement will be
limited to that particular block like if
you're defining it any opening block and
closing block
so beyond that you cannot see that
suppose if we're defining it under if
block
or any block so these
type of variables
are no longer accessible outside where
the var keyword will be typically
treated as a global variable and hence
it can be accessed
anywhere
so what is the closure in javascript so
closure is basically going to give you
a better way of
providing the consistent way of
developing a javascript code for the
developer so closures are basically
created whenever a variable
that is defined outside of this current
scope can be accessed within the current
scope okay that means which is
a variable which is defined outside the
scope even using the scope
of this particular
closure it can be accessed inside too
now
what are the arrow functions in
javascript
friends arrow function in javascript is
very very popular now they're just gonna
give you a kind of alternative way of
defining the function keyword
the other just a shortcut way of
defining the function in
javascript these are the simple handy
functions i would say
so what are the different ways of html
can be accessed in javascript course so
there are multiple ways are there so you
can access using document.get element by
class name you can access get element by
id you can get access document get
element by tag name and you can say
document.queryselector so these are the
multiple options are there
through which you can access the element
within your html tags
what are the ways of defining a variable
so var keyword as we discussed
you can define a variable
you can also define the variable using
const so if you define any variable
using const so these variables will get
constantly declared and it cannot be
changed
once you define the value so any value
or any variable which is defined using
const
it cannot be changed in later stretches
what are imports and export in
javascript so to make your javascript
modular
so there's an option available of
importing and exporting it
so what exactly the difference
difference is very simple like you are
writing the set of javascript code and
if you want to get it accessed
outside in another javascript file so
how the two javascript files can
communicate with each other that is
where exactly the important export code
comes to make your javascript highly
reused and more modular
now
these are the quick example as you can
see now
two different files are there so if you
want to make your particular variable
or function accessed outside you always
use export keyword with them
and if you want to access them out you
can just use an import keyword
as you can see it is defined there
so
another file can easily access your
the content of the previous files to
make your code even more modular and
useful
so what is the difference between a
document and window in javascript see
document is the one which is a part of
your document part which user can
actually see that
okay so the document object is the
object which falls under the category of
window window is a top level object so
in javascript we have an option
available name called bom that is called
browser object model
in which the top level object which is
there that is called window and under
this we have a called document so
whatever you see
under your
browser it is a part of your document
so what are the
javascript frameworks
and their uses see javascript frameworks
are mainly useful to make your
application more organized
with less code
and without getting into the into the
detail
okay so having this particular framework
will give you the opportunity so that
developer can
use the javascript in much more better
way
to write a complex code in more
simplified manner
this is where exactly your frameworks
are designed for so there are some very
prominent and useful frameworks like in
react angular
vue.js and lot many other names are
there in market
which will be using the javascript as a
core and take the entire javascript
development to the next level so the
next question is what is the difference
between
a
undefined and undeclared in javascript
see it is very simple
undefined means the variable which is
undefined
you're declaring a variable
okay and which you haven't defined okay
that means the variable has been
declared but the value has not yet
assigned that is called undefined
undeclared means the variable which
you're trying to access that itself is
not available it doesn't even exist
so what is the difference between
undefined and null in javascript see
undefine as i already told you
it means the variable has been declared
but it is not assigned with any value
null is actually the assignment value
that
we can assign to any variable
which
contain no values as an alternative i
would say so what is the difference
between session storage and local
storage see it is very simple html5 has
offered these features to you
so the session storage and local storage
both offers you the
data which can be stored in a browser
but session storage is short-lived
the moment your page is deleted or
closed the session data is immediately
get deleted where the local storage data
is remain for the longer period of time
and the data doesn't get deleted after
the browser history is over
okay so i would say the local storage
time span is far bigger compared to the
session storage
okay everyone so we'll have some
advanced javascript questions now
we've already seen the beginner level as
well as the intermediate level questions
now it's time to discuss about some
advanced double questions to like
the first question slide comes like how
do you empty an array in javascript so
it is very simple
if you want to assign
so there are few ways are there
number one by assigning the array length
to what to the zero
so automatically turns to empty
second
is what by assigning the completely
empty array
okay the third will be by popping up all
the elements of the array
so multiple options are there and the
last which you talk about by using the
splice function so these are the four
important aspects are there
which you can treat how to
empty your
javascript
array in a very very simplified manner
now what is the difference between even
capturing and even bubbling see this is
one of the very very common question we
talk about even capturing even capturing
is actually the kind of process
where you just try to
capture the event of
most outer most element and then
propagating it to the innermost element
so even capturing is what like you're
talking about picking up the element
or picking up the event from the
outermost like you talk about called
nested div tags
so you pick up the particular
you know even from the most outer most
div tag and you're just passing it to
the innermost then it's called capturing
the bubbling
is the process
okay which starts with the inner most
and goes to the outermost elements it's
just an opposite direction that is
called event bubbling
so the question is one of the very very
popular like what is the strict mode in
javascript see the strict mode of
javascript is introduced
to give the more better error handling
capacity of the javascript so whenever
we talk about call strict mode so all
variables have to be declared explicitly
so you cannot leave it like that and it
cannot be assigned to the read-only
properties
so we can enable the strict mode only by
adding the user strict mode on the top
of the javascript file
now
what about
and how we would be able to get the
following output of the below javascript
code so we have a call bar equal to 10
and we have written one function in the
if block and after that we're just
capturing the value
of a and then you are printing the value
in a console.log
so what would be the output for that see
it'll be
a call then undefined
once again it'll be kind of what it'll
be
undefined how come it would be look it
is very simple
first thing
okay in your application
you are basically saying the if
condition statement in the code will
evaluate the eval function
as you know very well what exactly the
evaluation is later on
the eval function
okay
will take the function and return the
function abc whatever the function it is
available
and then inside the if statement it
execute the abc and return the undefined
because as you know it variable the if
statement code executed runtime was the
statement inside this if condition is
being evaluated so that's where exactly
it is
next can you write a javascript code for
adding the new element in a dynamic
manner is exactly you can write it down
so you have this very common function
available name called
document.createelement
like people say like i want to add the
new text boxes when i click on the
button
so
i can write it very well so either it
will be a text box or it will be the new
element you want to edit so
document.createelement
is one very very common
i would say the function and later on
you can use the typical dom
functions like i can talk about to
create next node or append child so
using this combination you can easily do
so
next what is the difference between call
and apply very common question so the
call method
whatever the method you have it in a
call
these
method arguments are provided
individually okay along with this value
but in apply what happens arguments are
provided in the form of array
along with this value that is the only
difference between call and apply
so what would be the output of the below
javascript code as you can see right now
we've written one object name called
student provided one property called
college with abc
after reducing object.create passing
this is student as an object itself and
after that you're saying delete
student1.collagenconsole.log
student.com so what would be the value
for this
so it is very simple
it is very simple example of object
orientation so the output will be what
abc as we are accessing the property of
student object so certainly the value
will be what
abc for sure now
what would be the output for below
javascript code as you can see now we
have written a one
function
four and it is written 11 so we are
saying type of
so this will certainly refer to what to
the error
reason is why because a function
definition can have only single
reference variable
as its name that's why exactly it will
be throwing what an error to you
how do you remove the duplicate
value from the javascript array it is
very simple we have a call filter
function so the filter method i can
basically call it and three arguments it
may be expecting it the name of the
array the current element and index of
the current element
so that it can remove all the duplicate
elements from there so how do you remove
the duplicate elements
from javascript array so the same way i
told you like
first it takes three parameters
so using the filter method and by using
the for loop so the empty array is used
for sorting all the repeating elements
so like that you can simply make it more
easy
so how can you draw a simple javascript
dom so you can set it as a very simple
javascript dom elements which are there
where you can have the document and then
the html
and followed by all child elements like
an head tag body tag body may contain
further child elements like an anchor
tag
so these are all basically known is
called a presentational elements through
which this complete html hierarchy will
contain inside this using this
javascript css html combo known as call
to do application to do applications
kind of general task manager application
where you can attach add the task delete
the task
and uh completed tasks very simple and
sophisticated application we will start
to start working with and here we start
working with our first
very simple statement
that this one is called
so let me go and create a new folder
name call
not here
html
and now here again we would like to
start working with the
html by constructing our css5 will be
well taken care of
so we say
div
sorry
now inside this
we would like to have
some header portion
okay let me say another tip type
and insert the step type let's say
id
equal to
this box
okay and again
now here after that
we will like to use the h2 tab
and inside
you can see
my
to-do list
after the fetch tool you'll have to use
the text box
input
text
id equal to
item
and
placeholder equal to give anything i'm
saying
title
okay and close this
next we like to use the spam tag
and this is
one click
equal to
now
i do not have the function name called
new element but you would like to create
it
okay and
class equal to
given name i'm saying add
you would like to use the uf
url you know that you follow unordered
list
here i will say
id equal to
list
under this ui tag i'll look
[Music]
the first item
like that i can have some other items
with me
play games
walk with the dog like that i can have
number of tasks which is available to me
okay so here the human tech is getting
closed
and the div tag is also getting close
that's it
okay
so i do not have a css file with me so i
can just create
css
and this i like to import it
that's it let me try to see
the outcome
okay so i can have
very simple looking field for title
nothing is there
add
which must be a
kind of a button for me or whatever it
is
so it is just a span tag for me
on which i will try to click and perform
some action remember this notebook
now here once it is ready i would like
to go ahead and talk about my
main css which will help me to make the
complete look and feel more better
okay thank you
so we're going to start working with the
css now
from my css
uh
we want to basically perform
the edit where
close button i want to create it
and i want to create a close button to
hide the current list items in multiple
activities i have it which i want to do
it with my css let's get started with
css now
and with my css i would like to create
some basic effects toward my application
fine so step number one i would like to
say a strict
for everything that means for everyone
i'm saying box sizing
border box
basic one
nothing is affected because for common
for all
here i would like to start with my body
now
body
background color
background color i will say
background image it's up to me whether
you would like to use it or not
but i can use
600 pixels
next background position
then i would like to use center
next is background repeat
because if i do not have an image i
would not be using repeat so
background
size
cover
looks beautiful
well
going ahead we talk about our container
part
okay
so if i just see my previous code which
is there with me that is called
calculator
here in this app.css
i have option called container
so that was my container i just copy
this
and i use it again here
here in container width i would like to
use 50 percent now
background color remain white align self
center display block margin
just start using
120 pixels
auto and box shadow
border radius we're not using
adding once again we are not using
box shadow 5 pixel 10 pixel 20 pixels
perfect
there we go
okay
so this is my simple look now talk about
the ul part now
margin
next order left
sorry border left
6 pixels
next list
iphone
style hyphen type
i'm saying
next party
let's take a look
better
okay
now
so
few things will be used
uh
border left six pixels solid tail
padding now we talk about our ul and
allied part
okay cursor
pointer
next position
related
next pattern
we just would like to use the pixels
like this
background
right
remain textbook
okay font size
you can select 18 pixels
transition
for zero point two seconds
so transition
okay and the last option
user icon select
none
perfect
now looks beautiful
you can see now how the effects are
awesome okay url like that
now
we talk about our positions wise
properties ur
li colon
over
okay i say
background color
okay and after that i use your
let's check
all values
background color
again i can use the same
okay
now
after this
we are using this called ulli project
i'll be using background
text decoration
line through
which is the checked option
okay
now
after that
check before i also want to use it so we
just say
url
check
before
you will ally check colon before content
after that position
absolute
after that water style watercolor sorry
watercolor i'm just using color white
then border style
solid
then bottle width
border
iphone width
bottle hyphen width varies in 0
2 pixels
then top
10 pixels
left
pixels
then transform
rotate 45 degrees
then height
15 pixels
then with
7 pixels
now you see this now
how they work like
the javascript will be applied later on
to make it even more better so we are
just getting it ready for that
okay after that we'll be using foreclose
in this close using position
absolute
then write
zero
ready
four options we are using it here
okay then afterwards
close
or
and just close over and be using
background color
that's called
and
color
right
this is for close over
then we'll be talking about color header
header will be using background color
tail
then padding
30 pixels
and 30 pixels
color
looking beautiful
well this is your header what we have
written it now
after we will be talking about header
after an input
dot
header colon
after
content
colon
and then display
header after
okay
now after this will be using for the
input
not
dot i'll be using rather using directly
input
then border radius
zero
then width
75 percent
then padding
two pixels
okay then float left
the next option will be font size
i'm using 16 pixels
perfect
nice so
this is my text box
okay
now
we like to talk about buttons
okay
it's time to talk about code button so
we'll be saying dot
at
bt
so
once again the conditions that will be
remain same
talk about call
padding pixels
talk about covet
we say 25
we say background
purple
then we talk about call color
okay and we use float
left
after this fourth left right on what
texturing
center
then font size
you talk about construction pixels
then talk about cursor
will be pointer
we will talk about transition
here we talk about
0.3 seconds
and then border radius
that's it
and
change
that's it let's check
awesome
so you see now how exactly is it now
so my to-do list css part is over okay
well after this
we're going to talk about our gs file
which is on the most important area of
your code
now here let me close down everything
and start creating another file here one
is called
app.js
the main calculation goes here
so from this point onwards we would like
to start working with a property
whichever we have created here
on the top of that we start working here
okay
so
in my css what are the things are
required
that you want to understand okay so we
talked about option called li li stand
for what just items
so
let's start
for
i
equal to 0
is
[Music]
which element
txt equal to again
document
dot create text node
and
i'll just keep the value here using
forward slash
txt and then
my node list
i
dot
append
so the first function which we have
written
okay
so there's a name
called node list it's just a typical
logic in fact i would not even say the
function it's just a logic which you
write
after that uh
what we need to do now is
um we have to start working with our
option called
close
equal to
document
less than
i
dot
on
click
ok close i
dot object equal to
search
and now here we save our
div
equal to
this
dot
style
okay
and now
next thing so this is for when you try
to click on a close button to hide the
current list item
okay so you can see
current
test
okay
now
next what we will develop the code is
is to basically add a check symbol
okay while clicking on the list item
that means if any items you basically
click so what should happen now
so when i so it will get straight saying
that hey this task is over now so we can
say bar
list
document query selected
url
which takes even parameter
okay here i see if
dot
target
check
okay and what should happen now
but before that
i just need to check the condition for
if foreign
dot
false
that's it
okay now you have to basically go and
create one of functions for this
so after that i'm going to create a new
function now function
document
then
input value
equal to
document
dot
get element by id
item
dot
okay
and after that we're just calculating
this
value
t
equal to
document dot create text node
okay here we pass
like this
and here we see if
input value
equal to
blank nothing is there
then what so in such cases we can say
alert
is basically the validation for me
this field cannot be empty
okay this field cannot be empty so this
is the first error message we are
showing that else condition
in else condition which is a document
dot
get element by id
okay which is the type of item
okay so
taking a particular item which is a type
of
so else condition which is saying
document element by id
rather than item let's pass list here
and inside this list we'll say
dot append child
and here i will be passing out
okay
otherwise what would happen
we will talk about this option called
determined by id item
item dot value
equal to
black
okay that's the case now
after that it will start working with
our
span tag now
the span tag will have its own condition
there
so first we check about this
and now we talk about how it's fine so
we just say for the span we say
or span equal to
documentary create element of type
okay so here's what's trending
dot
create element of type 1
span here
so
after this is span we'll be talking
about our next feature now so this after
this is span
will be
yeah so we're now talking about call var
txt
equal to once again
document
so
and then last but not least we have to
basically iterate to all
four i
equal to
zero
i is less than
close dot
length
and
i
plus plus
then
close
of type
i
you're passing it dot
one click equal to
function
and here we are saying
div
equal to
this
parent element
okay and
div
dot
style
dot display
equal to
so
so friends we are almost ready now
because our javascript file is ready
after that we'll be talking about how to
include it in html to take a look
well everybody so we are all set now
since we have our application ready with
me jss really sees this is really now in
our index.html5 let me just check
how to apply
this js within my code now so in my
index.html file i'll just go to my at
the bottom of my page
that is called
script
script src
equal to
the name called app.js
that's it
okay and let's check about my final
outcome
okay so you can see now the crossbar
automatically appeared
okay with my application let me try to
add another one that is called
welcome
so it is automatically getting added
click you can see it is called strike
that means it is done
if i try to click on this it goes off if
i click it here strike click here its
type add another
it's also working
delete it
click it again it is uncheck or unstrike
so guys that's it so
we are happy like finally we have
finished one of our very important
project which is called today
application okay so this time we're
gonna develop another very interesting
example
using this html
javascript and css together and that is
called working with a quiz application
so one of the very very interesting
projects will be developing it from the
scratch and i'm sure that you will enjoy
a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all i'm going
to give the name called html
quiz
now i'm going to create a three files
inside this number one i'm going to say
index.html
then i need another file that is called
app.css
and the third file i'm going to create
inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
dot js
so we have total number of three files
ready with us
now from html page we would like to
develop this html tags first
so we'll go to the html and see
so we have got this basic html syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards dev tag
so within my tab tag we would like to
create
another div tag
okay
so the first top level class
to this particular tip
see we haven't created a css but we
would like to offer some of the css
classes available here so we see
the
class equal to container
now we have got another tab tag inside
this we will set them
id equal to
question hyphen container
question hyphen
container so that is the name or id of
this step and we say class
equal to hide
now within this step tag we would like
to offer some details
but
before that we would like to create some
embedded div tags inside this so we're
going to create another tab tag here
and this step id
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the id name and we would like
to offer the class also
class equal to
btn hyphen grid see again i'm telling
you these classes we are just creating
it
but we would like to use this
in our css
okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
now inside this dev tag we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one i would like to offer a few buttons
now
button
so we see a button class
equal to btn
and after that we would like to give the
name called answer one
answer one
so that i can have this button class
copy it three more times
and now we can change
the names to
two
here three here four so we have total
number of four answers ready with us
dev tag is getting closed here another
tip tag is getting closed here
and now here
before the last step tag is getting
close we would like to create another
div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to controls
that's another div tag so under this div
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button id equal to
start button
start iphone btn
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
btn
space
btm
and we say start here
now just copy this
complete line
and put it again
so
rather than giving the start button
we say
next button and class equal to
next hyphen button
btn
and we will give additional property
called height
and here we give the value called next
let me make this s capital
and
next
two buttons we have created
after this
div tag is getting closed
after that i would like to start another
tab tag
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with a
span
and here we will say span
id equal to
hyphen
answer
or answers i can say
so
after that the div tag is getting closed
and
that's it and it last
the last step tag is getting closed
which you can see it right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this dev tag i would like to close even
before
so two tip tags are getting close and
this is another tip type which is closed
at the end
and here we want to include the script
tag
script src equal to
script.js
that's it our html page is almost ready
let's review
and yes i can see some standard buttons
has been created
now we would like to look make gives a
better look and feel to this kind of
buttons and
complete ui by offering some awesome css
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with css part now
so to work with the css we have to offer
few things
here
we're providing a route
and with this route some basic settings
we are offering it number one
hyper hyphen hue hyphen neutral
hue
hyphen
hyphen hyphen q
hyphen neutral
the value is giving a score 200
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen
q
again hyphen round
this value we are giving us
zero
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyphen hyphen hue
this we are making with the variable
hyphen hyphen u
neutral
the one which we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we're giving 0
next property is margin
module will also remain 0
after that display
and then
after that not display i would send them
instead it is better we can have
flex
after that width
we are providing with almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing is called
once again 100
okay now we have called justify contents
this justify contends i can say center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say
center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
and this will we would like to use this
var
again this in this world we are using
hyphen hyphen q
and followed by
comma
percent
these things and this is style we would
we would like to use in my index.html
page
so within my head tag
well
in index.html5 how you would like to
prefine the styles we always use
link
css
so the value is automatically style.css
but we would like to change to app
dot css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting
now we want to offer
few more things into my css it is only
for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body dot
correct
body dot correct
we are providing
queue
var
and here we would like to offer
iphone iphone raw
and also sorry not wrong just for
correct
and
we can use
body
dot wrong
body dot round
so same thing i'd like to copy
so rather than correct
we're using
wrong
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working for the container
container inside my container i would
like to offer width
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by
max weight
this max would be 80
now going forward background color
background color we are offering white
that always looks better followed by
border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box shadow we can say 0
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used
right over here let's see
okay that looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container
now
we would like to offer the buttons
here in our css
we want to now offer the button colors
so
dot
btn
hyphen
grid
well
in index.html file
so we have a call button grid
this button grid we would like to start
from here
btn grid between grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen
template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying to
comma
auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be the 20 pixels
and then zero
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now
going forward we would like to apply the
styles of my button
so how my button will looks like in
well button grids we have created it now
we would like to go ahead with the
buttons
so dot ptn
followed by the details so
iphone iphone hub
we'll be using neutral
okay
going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or i would say one pixel
and then solid
and
hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
were
hyphen iphone u
followed by
100 percent
thirty percent
okay so these are the values for
border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so
in background color we will just use hsl
rather than this
so hyphen hue
and 50
okay
followed by
border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now padding
padding
just
5 pixels
and
10 pixels
then color
this color will be white
for sure
and
the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button hover
dot ptn
dot
or
and for this performer
you want to say border color
less watercolor you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well
so
this is how my initial
looks like
okay now i also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here
we want to use
dot
start
hyphen btn
and also for
dot
next hyphen btn
common look and feel for both
one size
one
dot five
rem
next font weight
now this font weight i want to give bold
followed by padding
this padding is
10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with controls we say display
flex
followed by justify contents
just justify content services center
followed by align
items
and here we say center
and
last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display
none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be
visible to me
so the moment i said start then with
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is
well my css is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your
main
code development so here we will start
working with this const
and here we will say
start
button equal to
document dot
get element by id and here it will give
the name called
start hyphen btn
that's the name
like this
i just copy this line
make it available here like people call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
like
here
another one
here we change the name and give the
name
question
container element
container
element
question container element documentation
here we give the name called question
hyphen container
question hyphen
container
because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there
we're using
question hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called
question element
question
element document good element by id here
will be passing
question
followed by
we want to use
answer button element
answer
buttons
element
answers
or i can say answer buttons element
answer hyphen buttons
answer hyphen
buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called shovel question because we
want every time the questions to be get
shuffled
shuffled questions
shuffle questions
current question
index
shuffle questions and current question
and we would like to provide one
variable call let
quiz score
equal to
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so
here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
const
equal to
array
first question which i would like to
create it here is called question
now here you will see
javascript framework
so which of these
is a
which one of these i would say which one
of these is a
javascript framework
this is my question now
okay
so i would like to have answers for sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer i
can say
like this
here i said text
first will be python
python
okay
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false
copy
now let's change the value here i say
django
correct false
third is react
so
i can say true
last i'm keeping it's called
false as usual
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so
here after that
we want to create a few more
okay
so once again i would like to bring some
questions now
and related answers
so i just copy this
first
so second question
i can say
who's the prime minister of india
so we can have two answers available
okay
talk about render mode value is called
work true
second we're gonna give the name call
which value is called false
so taken the values like this
and we can take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like here
next is called what is 4x3
i can have many answers
so i'm just making the first is called 6
which is false seconds 12
like that totally created
three
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer
one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be nodes called clear
status class
function
here
status
class
it takes some parameter call element
and here we will say element dot
class list
dot
remove
element.classlist.remove
correct
and once again i copy the same line
[Music]
so we have two options available
call what
write
and what wrong
now
going forward we want to have
few more functions to be attached
there's only one function we've attached
that's called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
call
function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second is called correct
two parameters we are passing it down
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by we are saying if
correct then
element
dot
class list dot
add
correct
okay
else
use the same option
what will you try to add
wrong here
so this is how we would like to apply
right or
wrong so this is a set status class
which we have it now
followed by the most important function
which you're gonna use it right now here
is called
your
select answer so you have to basically
select the answer so this is a little
bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we pass e as in parameter
and from here we will reuse
const
select selected button
selected button
equal to e dot
target
number one second const
correct
equal to
selected button
dot
data set
select button dot dataset dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this
set status class function
in the set status class we'll be passing
document
dot body
as the first parameter
and correct
is the second parameter
okay now we are using
array
dot from
and here in this editor from we're using
answers
button element
dot
children
okay followed by
dot
for each here
we're using
this button
as in parameter
now here
what i will do we are using this option
called
set status class
first parameter will be what
a button
then
button
dot
data set
we can give the value call what correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array
now we'll be
utilizing the
main evaluated value called if
shuffle quotient
dot
length
if
shuffle quotients dot length is greater
than
current quotient index
plus one
then what
then we are saying
next button
dot
class list
dot remove
and here we will say height so this will
be
hidden
okay
else
else condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot inner text equal
to
restart
okay
and
next is called start button
dot
class list
remove what we need to remove height
part
that's it
okay and here we're using this option
call if
selected button
dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document dot
get element by id
here we are providing
write hyphen
answers
followed by
dot
inner html equal to
quiz score
so whatever the score will be after
selecting the correct answer
this will be available to the user
okay
now the next thing which we're going to
develop it is basically your reset state
function
reset state
function reset state
so what we are going to offer here we
are saying
clear status class
document
dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
dot
class list
add
height
okay
now
we are using this while option now
answers button element
dot first child
so here i will be using answers button
element
dot remove child
here we have a call dot remove chart and
here we'll be giving
answers button elements
dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now
we haven't called those functions but
we'll be calling those functions one by
one
but this is something which you wanted
to start with
okay
well
reset state is already set
now going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
we are saying function show question
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the question element
so we have a call question element dot
in a text equal to
question
dot
now followed by questions dot answer
question dot
answers
dot
for each and here i would like to
we are use what
answer is a parameter
now
here we like to create a button called
const
button equal to
document dot
get sorry document dot create element
i'd like to create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner text
you to set the value
equal to
answer
dot text
then
followed by button dot
class list
dot
add here we are
offering
btl
okay now we are saying
if
the condition is
answer dot
correct
if answer is correct
then what
then button
dot
data set
dot correct
equal to
answer dot
correct
okay
now
the next thing is we are using button
dot
add event listener
attaching the listener to this event
which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer butter element
dot
append child
of what
button
so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set
next question
here
function
set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset state
the function we are calling it and
saying
show question
and here we are passing this
shuffle questions
and we are passing this current
question index
that is water set
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start
function
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
shuffle questions
equal to
we have called questions
dot
sort
okay here we say
math dot
random
and
five
we're passing this value
okay
after that we are saying
current question
index initially we are given 0 right now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
dot
class list
remove
height okay
and then
we're calling
set next question
which is a function we are calling it
and initializing our quiz score
but the value called zero
well start game is
ready
next thing which you to start the cover
button
so here we are
saying start button
dot
add event listener
here
in this
on my click event
i will try to call this function
start game
first thing
now next we'll be calling
next button
dot
ad event listener on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we are calling current
question index
current question index
plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so we are mostly done with our code
script.js we have basically already
initialized there
okay
the values will be kept automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
okay so
our javascript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with us
now let's finally see how my overall
look and feel really looks like it
let's just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome i could see
the first
question appears automatically which of
these a javascript framework
if i select as usual my correct answers
for react
now you can see
is automatically making the rest of them
as a
red and not giving me the next button
now
the prime minister of india i'm saying
modi
great next
and i say
for multiply by 3a12 i said next
and which of those used in mobile up
development flutter
and flask is a flask it says twitter
and now you can see the application
looks perfectly fine
and it gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how
dear friends your project is now
completely working
and expected as the way it was designed
for when i
once again restart and you can say start
button now it's giving me four multiply
by three that means it is once again
have taken
random question so we have decided to
basically develop another very
interesting project in javascript that
is known as calculator application
so let's get started let me try to
delete first those files which we really
do not need it now
we delete this all
yeah now i'll be creating a new folder
now and give the name called
calculator
and in this calculator app once again we
need some new files which is called
index
dot html
and we also need one more that is called
app.css
and another one that is called app dot
js
so these three files required now first
of all i would start with
index.html file where we will be
creating a template of my code
now
let me go and create this template and
here
i have a god body with me
let's start with the
first
tag here that is called h1
and this h1 we are giving the name
called calculator
calculator app so that will be my h1
heading
after that we'll start working with the
div tag
now within this div
i would have to create lot many classes
i may not have lot many css classes but
we can give some classes here so we can
say class equal to
container
okay
so within this div tag we're going to
create a table now because i want to
organize it
so i'm starting with the table within
this table
tr tag
and within this tr tag i need a td
now in this td i need few things call
call
span
equal to 3
another value
and here
i want to offer the text box
input type equal to
text
okay input text id equal to give the
name called result
that will be the final outcome while uh
pressing all the different buttons id
equal to result and
class
equal to
screen remember i haven't created those
css classes but but we're giving some
names but later on we can utilize it
while creating those css classes
table data is getting closed let's get
started with another td
now inside this td we need another text
box
input type equal to
text
and
here in this input text sorry i would
like to better say button because i'll
be having
buttons
okay
input i'm equal to
button value
equal to
c
and
one click
equal to i may not have any function
right now but yes i can create
a function but let me give some domain
name here
i'm saying clear
screen
okay so that will be the function will
get called
and after that
class equal to
clear
yeah so this is my button tag
after this the td tag is getting closed
after the td tag the table row is also
getting closed
after the table row
which is getting close we're going to
start working with another table row
okay and in this table row i'm going to
create one more td
so let's go ahead and create
another td here
and inside this td i'll be having
another project we get created
so i'll just say
this is my another button now input
equal to button value equal to
one
or click equal to i'll be calling
another function called display
okay and inside this we're giving the
value call 1
okay and class equal to member
class equal to
number
and here after that tag is getting
closed
okay now we have to start another td tag
here
okay like that we have to keep on
creating the multiple buttons so let me
copy
and paste another table data
now here
again value equal to 2 on click product
display
give the value call 2
and class equal to what
number
like that i'll keep on creating multiple
buttons but first check how it actually
looks like
now i can see the buttons like in c one
two three but yes i'm gonna create few
more buttons one after another
okay so i'll go here and create
few more buttons so this is where the
table data is getting closed
okay i'll copy this
and paste it again
so i have to create
the button
like in
3 4 something like that
so after this two we're giving the value
called three
yeah
i'll give the value called three
so val equal to two well equal to three
display 3
and then afterwards
just giving the value call
forward slash
and here also we're going to keep the
value call
forward slash
and here class equal to
operator
after that you have to give the value 4
and then followed by 5 6 7
so here we give 4
six
after six we're giving call minus
[Music]
okay once again it will be what type of
operator
okay after this minus we'll be talking
about call seven
then we have to have eight
okay nine
okay after that we're giving call plus
and
display
plus class equal to operator
operator okay so
here you can see the table data is
getting closed and here the table is
also getting closed and after this table
row we can start working with
another table over here
and
after this table row we can start
working with again
td let me have this
again
inside this i'll be giving the option
called decimal which is valid equal to
dot and here we give the value called
decimal
okay
now display zero
so after giving this dot to basically
take what the value
zero which we haven't put now
we'll be talking about value called zero
so here
the decimal value we have given it td is
getting close let me have another one
zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that
we'll be once again
taking this and this time rather than
giving this 0
we'll be using this call as a button
and value equal to
equal
or click equal to
solve
okay and then this saw will not be
passing anything
it will write a normal function
and plus equal to
equal
okay
so
table data is getting closed
so we will be using another table data
now
so here it will be the button only
okay we will be using
value equal to
multiplication
display
just check and he'll be using operator
okay
so table data is getting close table is
getting close table is also getting
closed here
okay so your div tag is also getting
okay that's it
okay so that's the only thing which we
wanted to make let me try to refresh and
check
awesome so we have got uh
all those necessary calculator behavior
which
we wanted to
reveal
okay now our next statement will be once
we're giving this c then we have a
column one two three and then forward
slash
followed by
four five six will come down
okay so
let me check whether we have used six or
not
okay so we haven't used six
so let me check here
four five six
so let me go back here
four five six let me copy this
and paste it later on
before
minus
six
equal to
number
okay so we're almost set now
so we are having this uh
look and feel
in this we are giving one two three four
five six
and after this we have a call minus and
then
plus related behavior so we are all set
now and after that we will be basically
applying the css as well as the
javascript look towards my code okay
thank you
well everybody we are all good to go now
but i just want to first check whether
my
uh this outlook is looking properly or
not see what my expectation is after one
two three forward slash i really want to
bring four five six to the next and then
seven eight nine and again forward still
but i can think this is absolutely
unorganized
so after this when we say
this uh forward slash which we have used
after hyphen
okay your td is getting closed here
okay so here the tr i also want to close
here
okay and after this tr i also want to
start
another tr here
okay
so that i can put them into the another
level now so under this tr i can use
this td now so after this minus
after four five six
once again i would like to start
another table over here
okay so that it let's go to the next row
so here
after td
we're closing this dr
and starting
another tier
okay we're starting another tier after
that we talk about eight nine
okay plus
see here talking about seven eight nine
plus here the table is getting close and
it is starting right now like this
see that looks better now okay but still
few more things which i would like to
make it even more organized but that's
not a problem we will do it later on
okay because you can see 8 is missing
right now
so here
seven
we copy this
equal to eight
eight
yeah that looks better now so now they
are basically completely organized
so the moment i expect my application so
we have a call dot here then 0 then
equal to and then multiplication
okay so it looks
better now
now i just would like to perform
the overall look and feel
so i need to go ahead and use what css
because without css i really can't
utilize this in a proper way so i have
to start working with a css friend
in css front how to start first we will
go back to my code and here in my css we
will start working with
font family but before font family i
would like to start with the body part
now
body
background color i'm using called t
that looks nice
okay so
i will be using this app.css
in my html to see the look how it has
been appeared right now
so in my index.html file
on the top under my head section
click
style sheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward
in my css
we want to use
some h1 correctly so
here we would like to use the h1
texture line
center
color
white
merging top
margin top we'd like to use 50 pixels
this for h1 let's
check perfect so it is now coming in
between
next statement
will be called screen so we say
screen
so in this screen we use the background
color
background color gray
and after that border
sorry
border solid
black and two pixels
after that color
white
font size
medium
next width
we're using this
then we talk about cursor
will be same
what are the default cursor is
okay then padding
we would like to save 10 pixels
and then
margin
save auto
then margin bottom
that i'll be using 10 pixels
so in the proper alignment
okay
look
that's how exactly we want this for a
screen where the exact outcome will be
visible to me
and rest of the details we'll be showing
you one by one and now we'll be talking
about input
okay
input
type
equal to button
for input type equal to
button
okay
input application
i say
background color
change to what
right what else i can say
let's walk
okay
and
when the button is active
what i want
let me copy
and this color should be orange red
like this you can see now how it is
basically looking like it
okay active the color will be like this
okay i'll be talking about operators
operator should behave different so i'm
same dot
operator
in this operator we are saying
background color
background color orange
okay then padding
i want five pixels
okay then i want color
that should be black
after this i'm using call border
sorry
that border
i'm using this called solid
and then black
then height
height is 40 pixels
then cursive
it has to be pointed
okay that's it let's check
perfect so they should turn back to what
to your
orange color
and uh
you can see the moment they take macros
on the returns to white
perfect and now those were type number i
also want to change them
so for number
for number i want to say the same option
padding i want 5 pixels
then i need height
of type 40
pixels then i say color
i want to say called black
then border
border i want solid
black into axis for it
black
two pixels
then width
i would say point width i
and cursor
once again
point there's one number let's check
awesome so they looks nice
now we're left with a few
other type of options like a dot and
equal to
okay that i'm talking about quite
decimal but decimal i need to have a
different options with me
okay so
let me try to copy this
paste it and i say for
does it
so for decimal background color will be
light blue
padding five pixels color black border
solid
okay black two pixels with hundred
percent height forty pixels five cursor
pointer
perfect
okay looks nice but i have changed the
color to light blue
now
i talk about
clear
okay
now come back
and say
clear
okay in this color
background color is i'm changed to light
salmon
light salmon
padding 5 pixels color black
border same width
height 40 pixels
fine
so cursor
pointer
file margin
auto and margin bottom
margin bottom
let's check
perfect now it looks beautiful
okay
now
here
after giving these details we're talking
about call equal part dot equal
so for dot equal also i'm just copying
the same
so we recall
background color id color
just change to
lightly
after this
since it is equal so we say padding 5
pixels is ok color black fine border
fine with 100 height 40 pixels
color and cursor pointers just i don't
need to
it's for dot equal and i want
for container
container
in this container width i want 40
percent
padding is 15 pixels
so display block
so first of all you have call width
you see
display
block
which we're taking
margin
okay in merchandising to pixels
auto
okay now align cells
go to center
okay border radius
border radius let's just say 10 pixels
okay now using box shadow
box shadow 5 pixels
black
and padding
so these are details i have it now okay
we have it
background color we are taking it now
align cell
display block border radius padding
and a knob
writing 15 pixels we have given audi
i don't need to give it again
so it's looking beautiful now okay so
this is where exactly my application
works like that
and table when we talk about
everything with
okay
that's it
super
so it's now giving me the proper look of
how
my application should be here i can just
see about the container what we have
done
with 40 we're taking background color
let's bring it below
then align
display block
okay margin
okay
and border radius
and uh
fine so i think we're all good now
so
that's it so we will try and implement
the javascript part well everyone so our
css file is ready
our html is ready it's time to just
go ahead and talk about my
final question that is called gs part
where i want to basically perform some
calculators
now here i just say function
display
function display which takes
val as in parameter and say
document dot
get element by id
here i'm saying
result
okay dot
value
okay
plus
equal to
whatever we are adding it just basically
try to apply
calculation on the top of that
okay there is a function
after that we have another functions
available here called function solve
here in the solve
we just use the value called
x equal to
document dot
get element by id
result
okay
dot
value sorry
value
okay and say select
y equal to
perform the calculations for the will be
using one function called
eval
and type
access and parameter
now the next statement will be again
document
dot create a runway id
result
dot
value equal to
y
okay
now
later on
i'll like to use another function here
function
clear
screen
and here we say
document.
get it in by id
here we say
result
dot
value
equal to
like that
so clear screen
solve
and
display three functions are associated
with me and these three functions
are the part of this javascript file
which i'll be calling it
at the end before
the water tag get closed so here
here two you can see the values
i will say plus
six
equal to eight absolutely i say c is
clear the screen
six
divided by
equal to 3 awesome so friends your
calculator application is ready
congratulations to all so it is a very
simplest form which we have developed
this is your html which is a template
for you this is the css which is your
complete
the area of like how the look and feel
will look like in of this template
beautification and here last video for
js which is smaller logic but really
meaningful
okay welcome to the another very
exciting project for our development in
javascript that is known as call weather
pro it is in the continuation to the
series of the previous project what we
have developed in javascript and this is
once again a very competitive project
i'm going to present to you
which is called weather pro where i
would like to offer you the real time
weather application into your browser
taken from the real-time weather
applications
okay so let's get started with the new
development of our application which is
called a weatherproof
now once again
compared to the previous project what we
have seen these projects were working
more kind of static in nature where like
you talk about snake game you talk about
tick tock toe or other type of games
like an online quiz
where the data was very much static in
nature but we were presenting the data
in the form of more dynamic in nature
this time
this project we are presenting you while
connecting with the real time weather
application where i'll be making a one
rest api call or else you can say
asynchronous call and since javascript
is working as a what appear asynchronous
nature you will be enjoying the way how
the javascript can communicate with your
backend
load the data and represent the records
in a very very beautiful manner
so once again we would need this
vs code editor only just to
develop our code and uh once again
for developing our presentation part
we'll be using html for
formatting part will be using css and to
make some dynamic update we'll be using
javascript now here i'm going to create
a new file name called index
dot html
apparently i just want one more that is
called app.css
and another file we need it
and
that is called
your js file so we're saying
app
dot gs5
so total number of three files are
available to us so i'll start working
with an html now and here
we'll start
with this
html templates
now here first of all i would like to
load my css file which i do not have
right now
but certainly i can use it
okay so i can just say link
area equal to
stylesheet
and href
equal to
app.css
well that is my css location
now i just want to create
some
this link area i would better use
inside my head tag that will be the more
convenient place
now in my body
i want to have some of the div tags and
there i can decide where the weather to
be displayed so i can just start with my
div tag now
with my div tag i say
class equal to
i can just create a class which later on
i can offer
a different size of or different type of
style so we can say container
so we're saying dip class equal to
container now within a dip tag we like
to use another dev tag which is a nested
one
so this step will have another class
called
class equal to
app hyphen
title
i have hyphen title
in the same dave tag we can use
this a typical paragraph tag
and here we say weather info
whether
info
now after this paragraph tag
we want to have a text box because i
would expect a client to enter the
detail on which city or for which city
he or she would like to get the details
so we can say input
sub properties like id
equal to
search
second type
equal
to text
next placeholder
equal to
enter
the city
next
autocomplete i'm saying autocomplete off
the reason because i do not want the
previous value user can see in this case
we can say autocomplete
oh i do not want any autocomplete in
this
okay
now
here it is getting close now
after that we also want the locations
for that i may use some of the png files
and all but right now
i just want to display the details
of the user
like which city he belongs to and
accordingly i can display the records
right in your application
so for that i really need
some of the div tags once again where i
can display the details
of this particular city so i'm just
having this only text box let me go and
go back and check
how it looks
so i have a call enter the city so here
i'll be picking up the city and
somewhere down the line i have to
display
the record so
after this div
we can also have some of the locations
to be displayed
so
we can just use the notifications
and
also the location where you want the
details to be displayed
okay so we can use div class
class equal to temperature value
temperature hyphen
value
okay so div plus equal to temperature
hyphen value inside this i'll be using
paragraph tag
and here in my paragraph i'll say iphone
and
this degree centigrade or whatever you
want to display it here
and we'll use
a spandex within this and show
in degree centigrade
that's it
and if you want to define the
temperature description
after this dev tag we can use another
day of tag
and inside my div tag i can define the
temperature description
okay so we can sit down
class equal to
temperature hyphen description
and within this i'll be using what
a paragraph tag
here i'll be displaying
all the description
so right now that is the only thing
which i want let me check
okay so it's here right now
so now let me try to collect the value
from the client
and perform some javascript tag
within this
okay now it's time for us to go back and
try to bring some of the css features
into my code now
now few things i would like to say is i
have basically downloaded some fonts
which i would like to use it in my
application and i also have some of the
icons which i would like to use
during my application presentation so
there are some png files are there which
i have downloaded from the internet just
to bring more beautiful experience
towards my application development
well this is another background image
which is called bg.jpg which i would
like to
make it as a background of my
existing application so i'll start with
my css
and see how this css can really bring
some new features to my code well
first thing i need to have a call for
face so to make this font face we are
using this statement name called here at
the rate
font face
and i like to use font family
font family i'm using
mod select
okay
it is already there with me monster
and the url
what is looking forward for so we are
saying src
url
and i'm saying under the
font so we have a file called ttf
okay that is called
bold.ttf that is the file which is there
with me
next thing
so
for every
location i want to use the font family
font hyphen
family i want to use same
monster
and the next thing is like in my body
so in my body few details like
background image
i need url
and in this url we can say
bg.jpg
in my background
next thing is background color
that i needed steel blue
then i need height
i'll say 500 pixels
next your background position
this i needed is center
next is your background repeat
i say no repeat
next is your background size
this i'm saying cover
this is my body part
okay let's check
okay
looks awesome now you see this now this
is how
my weather info is looking like it they
can see like the background looks
awesome now now
next thing we required a container
so we are saying
dot
container
container we say width
width 50
next background color
which is using white
next we need it is your align itself
that will be
center
display
if we block
margin
so in margin we can say 100 pixels
after that border radius
border radius using 10 pixels
and then padding bottom
this padding bottom will be 50 pixels
then box shadow
this box should be giving 5 pixels
10 pixels
20 pixels
and black
this will be with my container so
index.html file we have called container
now
okay looks awesome now
so this is where exactly the details
will be
okay
now
after this css
container we have used
we can talk about called title
you can say
hyphen
title
inside this we will say width
will be 100
then height
will be 150
pixels
then border radius
10 pixels
then we need display
display we need flex
and then we need align items
this align items which is saying center
next we need justify content
that will be the justify content which
is centered
then flex direction
would be column
so this option we're using for our tool
name called what
app iphone
title
okay so here in my index.html file we
have called div class equal to what our
python title equal to weather info let's
check
okay so
this is another
we have used that is called app title
now we need to use it for paragraph
inside my app title what should be
alignment for my paragraph
so here
this app title
tab title is space p
but it should be the class so we are
saying dot
and there also we have to use what
dot because both have to be the class
type
okay
so here
you can see now
there is a difference i forgot to add
dot and now you can see it looks better
comparatively
paragraph
so once again in my paragraph i will be
having text align
center padding
i want 15 pixels
then i need margin
margin would be zero and
auto
followed by font size
font size
this i'm saying score 1.2
yeah
this position then color
we are giving
hash
value
call 333
okay
now here
[Music]
okay so some changes in a paragraph
well going forward for the search
because if you remember
we have an index.html file we have a
call id code to what
search so here in my
app.css i have to use
hash
search
okay so this search conditions i want to
use it
now
inside my search i need few things one
is called display
i need block
after that i need margin left
auto
margin right
width
i'm looking forward for 5 pixels
height
that i'm looking forward for 20 pixels
then
border radius
i'm looking for four five pixels
then outline
that's called none
there is a border
okay
in this bottle what we can say three
pixels
space solid
okay and once again
see
that's what
let's check
so this is actually the text box
so once again search you use display
block
margin
lift auto margin right auto width 5
pixels
width
padding sorry one thing i said
padding should be 5 pixels
width
should be 40 percent that's why it is
smaller but it will be
let's check
yeah let's look better now
okay so my text box is now ready i'll be
having some of the details for the
notifications also
so what i need for the notifications
let me go back and create a class for
notification so dot
notification okay
now in notifications i would like to
give some value called background color
and in this background color we are just
giving white
and after that we are saying display
and we are saying
none
this is for notification and followed by
the notification
we're talking about the same
notification
okay and followed by
its paragraph
we are giving the color first of all
using color
color is basically red
okay else if you want to give maroon
it will the model
and
after this
the next property we are taking is
called font size
one size we are taking is called 1.2
am
followed by margin
margin we are taking is 0
after that texture line
center
id
10 pixels
zero
so this is for notification p and then
the weather container
okay in my weather container i will say
width
sorry
yeah with 100
height height we're giving 260 pixels
or up to you 250 pixels if you want
background color
this background color we are giving is
called one second white
and followed by margin top
20 pixels
pixels this is for weather
container now for the weather icon
whether hyphen
icon
i am saying width
is
and
height
128 pixels
just to give in a better look
now the next thing we're using dot
weather
icon icon
space img
here we can display
none
and
sorry display note none and it's another
block
display block and margin
giving 0
space auto
there's for
i and location icon if i want to give
then
location hyphen
icon
this location icon i can save with same
width height
so
width i'm giving is 100
then
height i'm giving 40 pixels
and then we give this option called
padding
then take pixels
so it's for location icon
now
followed by location icon we are also
giving call location icon img
okay dot
location
hyphen
icon space img
here we're giving the value called
display block
display block width
we're giving is called 32 pixels
and then we're looking forward for
margin
margin would be 10 pixels
and
auto
then cursor
so cursor will be pointed for sure
and then we required padding
padding looking forward for five pixels
followed by border
border we are looking forward for steel
glue
steel blue
solid
two pixels
then border radius
water
radius
we're looking forward for 10 pixels
and followed by your color
steel
so these are the look and feel we have
to basically offer it for my
current application which i yet to
discuss in my
next development
then i'll be having some small small
properties here
okay
and those properties are nothing but to
give you the details of
like
temperature values so we say dot
temperature hyphen value
okay this temperature hyphen value we
can give it
is 100
and height
making this call 60 pixels
okay this is for temperature value let
me copy this again
and
i'm giving this temperature value space
paragraph
here
i'm gonna give padding
margin
zero
then color
which color you're looking forward for
so we can just say dark grey
okay for any color which you're looking
forward for it's up to you now but if
you want you can change the color answer
to another one we're giving this call
hash
okay two five one
okay that is a more perfect color for
this
development now font size
four em
then followed by texture line
and once again center
so this is for
temperature value b
we haven't used much
but you can see now it looks somewhere
in much more better way
okay that is called temperature value p
then you can use the temperature value
span
here
dot
temperature value expand
space
span
and here
remove the additional dot
now within this span
say color
once again save
and font size
[Music]
this is for
span
and in the same temperature description
paragraph you can use it
dot
temperature iphone description
description space b
so this will be having the padding
of 8 pixels
then margin
followed by color
same color the one which we have used
earlier
after this color just a texture line
center font size
this is for temperature description
okay glass which is available for your
location
so let me give the location now dot
is space three
here we can say
margin
zero
then padding
then color
same color i would like to use
after this color texture line
and font size
and copy
text align center and here we'll be
giving some different value called 0.8
okay and last which is really left with
called div
in that
relative
here position
i'll be using
absolute
top from top
i'm using 600 pixels
okay and right
using 120 pixels
that's it
okay so all set
so you can see now
here we have to basically offer the
details how my pictures will be taken
right
so this is what my css now will be
applying some of the css into my
applying the css into my html to see how
it really looks like it if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
okay so we have seen some of the css
classes we have introduced
in my html
we have used this
autocomplete equal to off then we have
used chip classical temperature
value
okay if you just check carefully we have
used this temperature and there we have
used temperature hyphen
value
but before that we would like to use
some other properties too
okay after this autocomplete equal to
off we want to use
uh another div class
okay before my previous div tag is
closed here so here
after this we would like to use another
div tag
div
here in my tip
i'll say class
equal to
location hyphen icon
location hyphen
icon
okay and here i'll be using img
src
equal to what under
icons i'm using the file name called
location
dot png
and alt equal to we leave it as it is a
blank
okay
now here the div tag is getting closed
now there's another div tag is getting
closed here
so two div tags are closed after that
we'll be using another div class for
notification here there
class equal to notification
dev class equal to notification and this
step tag is getting close right here
okay now another div for the weather
condition
another div tag and here we say
class equal to weather hyphen condition
whether hyphen what
a condition
or i can say whether iphone container
whichever so i can say
weather hyper container
under this
weather container i like to use
another tip
for weather icon
tip for
class equal to weather hyphen icon
weather hyphen icon
and within this
i want to use another img
src equal to once again
icons
slash unknown
dot
png okay div tag is getting closed
so after this dev tag is closed i'm
gonna use
um temperature value
so the temperature value is anyways used
here if you see
raising call temperature value after the
first shift tag is closed
you see like temperature value we have
used after that the paragraph tag
and the temperature hyphen
description b
after the p that the div tag is getting
close
okay and after this we are using tab
class equal to location
so we want to use
div
class equal to
location
and within this location
we want to use one more paragraph tag
[Music]
with this hyphen
after this paragraph exists close
this step tag this tip tag
and another tip tag three div tags are
closed
that's it and at the last
before my body tag is closed
i would like to use
script
src equal to
app
dot
js
that's it let's check
great my application looks pretty
beautiful now
so
this i
want to be displayed only when i don't
find the weather and the location
anymore so look and feel is absolutely
good and now i'll start working on my
javascript front
okay so let's go ahead and start writing
our javascript code
so in this javascript code first of all
i need few things
first thing what i need is call
individual elements or individual
properties of my application i need cost
icon element
i can limit equal to
document dot
query selector
and i'll be using the name
called
dot
weather hyphen
icon
okay
now
copy this
location
icon
here we are saying
dot location
hyphen
icon
now
next
i need is called temp element
we are using
the property call dot
temperature hyphen
value
space
p
next we're looking forward for
desc element which is called description
here we're giving temperature hyphen
description
hyphen
temperature has been description space
dot
p
then location element
okay we need location element and we use
dot location
space b
next we need notification element
notification element and here we're
going to keep the call
notification
so four properties we have taken so we
are selecting all the elements
next
statement what we're going to talk about
see this statement is all about
selecting the arguments the next step we
are talking about call
get the input field so we are saying var
input
to
document dot
get element by id you'll be given the
name called
search which is the name or id of my
text box let
city equal to
blank
next we're going to use caller let
latitude
equal to 0.0 we are initializing this
value and let
longitude
let longitude equal to again 0.0 so we
are getting the coordinates right now
so this is how to get the input fields
next we want to apply the elements here
we are saying input
the variable dot
add event listener
the variable what we're talking about
which even list will be talking about
key up
okay
up
and what even you want to apply so we
are saying
function
with a parameter name called what
event
and now we would like to attach the
logic now
we send if
what is the condition
event
dot
key code
equal to
okay
then
that means number 13 is basically the
enter
see the key code means for 13 13
represent the enter keyword so even dot
key code equal to what 13 so here
same event
dot
preview
default why we using this because i do
not want my page to be get
refreshed just to avoid this we're using
this and after that we are saying
city equal to
input dot
[Music]
value
now
you will be using this another function
because i do not have function created
otherwise i have to call the function
name called get search weather and be
passing this as in parameter so we are
going to get
search
whether i do not have this function i
yet to create this
and pass it here as a what
city
and we say
console
dot log
city whatever we are basically printing
it
okay
so that is the first thing later on we
need to get the data so to get the data
we are just using this variable name
called const
whether
equal to
const whether equal to
curly braces
after that we are saying
weather dot
temperature
equal to this
and which temperature conditions you
want i'm saying unit
of type what
celsius
i wanted a celsius put it in a double
quotes
okay
so next statement will be
getting the details in calvin i'm saying
const kelvin
equal to value of the kelvin is about
and after that
con c ultimately what we need is
we need to interact with our backend api
from where i will
get or receive the updated weather
applications
okay
now
to get this i'll be using one very
popular api here that is called
openweathermap.org
this is a very very popular app
which
people use it and it's used and trusted
by many companies
clear
so here
what you can do this
open method map.org
so you need to basically first of all
get yourself registered because if any
third party application is interacting
it requires that particular
unique
api key
since
as a visitor you really can't get it
unless you register yourself so i have
my api key with me so i'll go here
it'll ask me for the registration
so
i already signed up so if you're not you
need to sign it there's an api key for
me which i need to copy
and this api key i'll be using it in my
project
so i just use this property called const
key equal to
to paste my key here
okay
after this pasting the key but make sure
that you rather using my key you use
your key otherwise this application
sometimes won't work
so i'm basically trying to use this tool
name called geolocation
i'm saying if
geolocation okay again
navigator
navigator as you know is a browser
object model element
so here we are using
navigator
okay navigator dot
geo location
dot
get current position
in which i'll be passing the first
parameter name convert
set position
and second parameter will be show error
in case
if any error is received
okay
else
in the sales condition what would happen
i'm using this statement name call
notification
element
this is notification element dot
style
dot
notification remain dot
get elements by class name
but i don't need this rather i will use
what the style
dot display equal to
block
then i'll be using the same
notification element dot
inner html
equal to
you're gonna use a paragraph
saying what browser
doesn't
support
so you have to enable the current
location of use
okay that's where exactly
so after that we have to basically set
what the user position
okay if the user is having that support
available
so after this
location we'll be just using another
function here
function
set
position
it will i'll be taking
position as a parameter
and take latitude
latitude equal to
position dot
chords chords for coordinate start
latitude
okay like that
longitude
equal to
what position dot
dot
longitude
after this we'll be using this function
called what
get
weather so this get weather will be the
function in which you will be passing it
so this function will be soon seen i'll
be having it defined below but as of now
we are just saying
get feather and in which this we are
passing
latitude and
longitude
that's it
so we have this function name called
what
set position
in which will be passing all the values
okay at the same time
i will be using one more function here
that is called function
not function in fact
i would like to use location
icon the one which you define at the top
dot
add event listener
which even listener i'm saying
on click second
function
which take
event isn't parameter
and inside this i'm saying console just
to confirm whether the records have been
taken console.log
hey
just
and
we say get with it
okay once again we'll be passing what
latitude and longitude same i just copy
this
and paste it here
okay everyone so we have written till
here when i try to run my browser
so i should see there is a message name
called show error is not defined
but obvious because this message what
we're writing it here is called show
error
okay this
as a function as a parameter it is not
defined let me define this function
called show error so we are saying
function show error which take
error is in sorry just take
error is in parameter
now in this we are using
notification
dot
style
dot display equal to what
block
after that once again
notification element
dot
inner html
equal to what
we're just using this as a paragraph
and here
error
dot
message
okay and after that
paragraph
so this is how we are basically writing
it down
and now
see it is immediately asking you
to know your location okay if i say
allow
that's okay
okay so nothing
you can see now it is saying get weather
is not defined because right now the
moment i click on this
so it is saying like get weather is not
defined but obvious because i told you
this get weather function i need to
develop so i get to develop this
function called get weather but before
that i am using another function called
function
get search weather
get
search weather in which i'll be passing
what city name
now
what exactly my api will be in case if i
want to make a call i will be using let
api equal to
now the url will be what
http
colon double forward slash api dot
open
weather map dot
org now open weather map dot org
slash
data slash 2.0
sorry
2.5 that is a version slash
weather
okay question mark
i have to take the city dynamically so
i'm saying weather
question mark q
equal to
here
we're using what city
and
we're using ampersand
app id
equal to the one app id we have used it
already
okay what is that
that key
so that is the key
which we've already written so that app
id we are passing it right over here
okay q equal to ct and i have id equal
to this
now after that to make the restful api
call i'll be using one independent or
by default api which is available to us
that is known as call what
fetch
okay so if you just check this fetch it
is basically a take request info
and give you the what a promise response
so return type will be the promise type
in this fetch i'll be passing what
the api
and we'll be using dot
then that means if the request
is successful we're saying function
function
response
then function is in parameter response
we are saying let
data equal to
response dot i'm expecting the response
of type of what json
is in json now and return what
data
so it will be returning data back to me
now if it is successful then what then
i'm saying dot then once again it is
chaining
again
function again
data and parameters
now in this case we'll be getting lot of
things
i'm saying
whether
okay dot
temperature it's a predefined dot
value
equal to i'm using what
math
dot
floor inside this we are passing what
data dot
main
dot temp it is a predefined property we
are receiving it now
hyphen
kelvin whatever the kelvin value is
basically we are taking score 273 on the
top
minus
kelvin
followed by
another property or
weather dot
description
equal to we're using
data dot
weather
zeroth position because it contains lot
of data but i will be taking what
description out of that
then
weather dot
icon id
whether dot icon id equal to
data
dot
weather
icon then
dot icon then once again
weather dot
city
okay equal to
data dot
name
after this
weather dot country
dot equal to
data dot
sys dot
so these are the properties i have it
right now with me
okay and once i received all the
property i'll be using dot
then
i will be using one function
and i will say what
display there is no function written
called display weather but i'm gonna say
there's a one function name called
display
weather
this function i had to write
but this function just putting it here
okay
now this is closed
after that
since i need to get a weather from the
apa provider
so i have to also pass what the latitude
and longitude which i'm receiving it
from the client because
here i just want to have two things
the properties as well as whether both
and both i'll be using it one by one
okay so here
we have kept this get search weather and
now i'll be calling one more function
after this logic and i'm giving the name
call function
weather
okay it takes two parameter one is
called what latitude
and thing is called
longitude so we have two things called
latitude and longitude
and here i'm using this property called
what let
api
equal to
once again
if you remember
i have used this statement i'll just
copy the same
and
pass it it here
but challenge would be this time
i will not be passing city name because
there two options are available either
you type the city name or else you click
on the icon and let your application
identify the location which you belong
to
so after this feather question mark
here i will not be using queue i'm using
what
led
equal to
latitude
okay
and we're using
and
hello in
equal to
we're using logitude
okay and app id equal to what key so
this is the variable which we have it
now
okay
similar thing which we have used it on
the top
okay called fetch api
so i just copy this same fetch api again
because i really don't want to waste
time on keep on typing the code
when we know it very well it can be
similarly done i just copy and
paste it here
so the same fetch api
dot then response data equal response or
json return data then
whether the temperature matter floor
says country dot display weather so we
have used the same thing here and after
that we have to use the last function
here that is called display weather
display
weather and here in my display whether i
can use
what
i can element dot
inner html equal to
i'll be using
img
src
equal to
icons
slash
dollar
and we'll be passing what together
okay dot
icon id
okay
dot
png
okay so
that we are basically putting it here
dot png and after that
it is closing that
okay and this icon we also need to close
here
so rather than closing this i'll be
closing that and
this i'll be closing it here
now
we'll be using top element
sorry temp
element temp element
dot
inner html
equal to what
we'll be using this dollar
feather dot
temperature
dot
value
okay
and
after this value we can just use
this asterisk side
the one which i told you
okay and use
spam
okay next we're using call talk element
so we have that sorry dsc element
we have got dec element dot
inner html equal to
weather
dot
description
and last but not least location
element dot
inner html
equal to
what
i'll be using once again this
and here
weather dot
city
comma
dollar
weather dot
that's it
these two properties we have to use it
and we're all done
let's check with my code
if i get any error
now
allow
so
awesome you can see now
27 broken clouds globe undefined that's
perfectly fine intercity
you can see awesome beautifully it is
showing you the conditions it's saying
smoke 28 degree centigrade and not let
me put another city here i'm gonna say
called pulae
awesome your application is working
perfectly fine
and
let's see one more
i would say
awesome and now we are planning to
develop one very special game for you
in javascript and now it's time to talk
about another very interesting game that
is known for tic tac
tic tac toe is
world's favorite game we have already
played a lot in our childhood days and
still my favorite game so i have decided
to basically offer you this tic-tac-toe
game developed in
javascript html plus css which can
create something really really great
effects for the end users so let's go
and start developing our next game
that's called tic tac toe
so in this tech tacto i will start
working with creating a folder called
tic tac and inside this i'm going to
create a new
file name called index
dot html
now here onwards the same thing
i'll be creating this html tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer
but
to
i'll be creating some of the tags
in which the css class will be applied
so we just gonna create a classes
i'm going to just use those classes but
we'll create it later on so just go
ahead and create them so we're saying
div
okay
so now this point onwards is my first
div tag inside this i'll keep
my h1 tag
and under this h1 i will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful
to contain some necessary information
with regards to this game so tim here we
say h1
and inside this h1 we give the message
called class
equal to header
and here i'll give the name call
is a tic-tac-toe game
after this div class
yeah here we will start working with our
form tag
within my form tag i will start my div
after div tag i will use
label
so label for player one
or else i can say player one and inside
this let's give the name call
player
one label is closed
and after this label we'll start working
with our input tag
input
now in this input what are the details i
need first i need call type equal to
text number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name
equal to player1
next we want id
equal to
player 1
and then
any class if i want to apply
anyways we're gonna close this this is
my first text box
and
same thing i would like to create for my
another one
since the first div type we have used
let me go and create another tip tag
in this div tag i'll use the same label
copy the same
paste it here and this is for player 2.
so we have this
two players with me and after this div
tag
i'll offer the submit button now
input typically submit
start game
now the form tag is closed here dev tag
is also closed
so
you want the div tag to be closed or
before that it's up to you now
so here we have a called div class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we will basically form that with this
so form tag is there later on you can
just show
some containers where the details will
be visible to me
so here after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check with
it is really working fine
so here
yeah we have this option called enter
name in the name after
so
yeah
so here the details we have taken input
applicable text and input applicable
text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we will go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the tape tag again
div
and inside this div
i says i haven't created any css classes
so those we can use it little later on
but let's have
this div
and inside this step i would like to use
one more tip type
okay and here we want to use one more
div tag
so inside this div we will be using one
more div tag
so
in this div we can just give the value
called data id equal to zero
id equal to
zero it's just the value
we are passing it
div
data equal to zero the div tag is
getting closed
fine so
that's how we want it now
so here the first tip tag is closed like
that we can create another data id so 0
1 2 total number of three we want to
create it so i want to create 0 1 2 3 4
5 like this
so the way we have created here
for this div let's go and create one
more div tag
id equal to
one
two
three options we have it now
okay like that i can keep on creating
the others also
too
three
four
five so zero one two three four five dot
number five we have created
one more i would like to create it down
here for six
there'll be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay
so the div tag is getting closed here
okay and
that's it
and if you want to create a some clear
board or button that you can basically
offer it a little later on
but here
we can use one more tip
and here we see div
dip classical relative
and within this step tag i can use
any image tag if i want
so i just leave it as it is
and after this
i can create one more div type
and inside this another tip
okay
and
under this i'm going to create
a button
okay and in this button
we'll be having some value
okay we can secure the volume called
replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
spam
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay so here
it's just
a small game i want to develop it
better
now there's no user interface has been
used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure
look and feel so that you know it gives
me more better look when your
application will start
but most importantly i need to start
working with a javascript part where the
logic will get calculated here
okay so
we want to start with the javascript so
let's get included javascript with my
code
so here
i can see here
a script tag
script
equal to
now the file i haven't created so let it
be as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my
style cheat also so
i just say
link
real quick style sheet
into the name called
css though i haven't created what i'm
giving it
okay
that's it
so we have taken
this html into our
consideration now we will be creating
this css as well as the javascript to
make this example complete
well we are ready with our html but it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our javascript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js
and inside this we will start writing
the logic with our main application okay
now the first thing is how we're going
to start now
yeah
so
first thing what we need to do is we
need to attach window
dot
add event listener
and when the window will load some logic
should happen so i'm saying load
second is the name of the function
so the name of the function perhaps does
not exist but i can give the name called
m
which i'm gonna create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game board i'm saying let
gameboard
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is
eight digit
so we just make it
like that
and one more
for making it nine
okay
so that's how
we're going to create it now
okay now this is all empty right now
after that we're going to create let
turn
this new variable
equal to
zero
what this is it keep tracking if x or
zero player its turn
like which player turns it to b so just
it is trying to measure it i'm saying
let
winner equal to false
okay now let's go and create the player
so
create
layer how are you going to create a
player we say const
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
that's it
okay after that i'm defining let
here
x equal to
player
with the empty value
and again
player
y
equal to
there is an empty value now let's try to
initialize the app
okay
initialize
inside this initialize the app we're
going to create a new function
function
app
and inside this we're going to create a
variable likewise saying let
input field
equal to first of all
document dot
get element by id
here
we're gonna take
the
class name of this particular
text field so we are saying input
hyphen
field
okay
dot
focus
okay now after this we have to say const
add players
equal to once again
document
dot
get element by id let me just give the
name called player form
okay
next we are saying
add
player
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event
on which event
submit event
and what logic
add
players
okay
after that once the players are added we
are saying
let replay
replay button equal to once again
document
sorry
document dot
get element by id or rather i will say
document.queryselector
document dot query selector
replay type
btl
okay just the name we are basically
taking that and here we say
sorry
replay button
dot
add event listener
which even i want to say
click
ok that is the first event second
reset board
reset
board
that we are basically passing that
okay
now
this is the initial case which we have
it
now beyond that i will add
this is the layers what we have added
and right nut slides to add the players
so this is how we have initialized after
that let's
add
plates
how to basically add the players here we
have to just define the function
add
players
okay it will take
event as a parameter
and say event
dot
prevent
prevent default this present default
will try to prevent
the default
uh you know
behavior which is submitting to we get
avoided and now here we say if
this
dot
player one so we just define the
property called player one
if this dot player one dot what
value
okay
is
blank
okay or
this dot
player two
sorry
this dot
player 2
now i just want to find it out its value
also
value
black
then what i should do
in this case i'm saying alert
you
must
enter
name for
each
field
the user has to add the values and after
that
return
okay
now the next thing is like we would like
to select the players in this inside
this by saying cost
layer
form
container
again
const play from configure container
equal to
document dot
query selector
talk about the query selector here we
will just pass
the value call
enter
hyphen
okay now we say cost
boardman
equal to
document
dot once again
query selected
dot
class list
dot class list dot
add here we're giving the name forward
height container
class list
dot
remove
hide
hyphen container
okay so we basically taken that
and after this what i will do i'll just
say player
x
dot
name
equal to
this dot
player 1
dot
value
ok this for player x copy this
player y
and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
we'll be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which we
have implemented
well so
add player function is added right now
and after this add player we have to
basically call
one more that is called which returns
the current player so i'm saying return
current player
and here what i will do is we'll just
write function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
turn
just variable
okay percentile
2 we're just adding it with this
0 okay if it is
then
x
turn i'm telling you
okay or else
so we're adding like the current player
who says the current tail right now
well
after this adding the return current
player we're gonna add another function
that is known as call return the current
player return current player is having
this value and after that we need to say
resize the square in event browser is
resized once again if the browser is
getting resized automatically the square
size of your
tic-tac-toe should also get increased so
we just say
resize
squares
and here we're gonna say this option
equal window
dot
add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here and the second parameter what we
are parsing is called on
resize
okay on resize
now let's try to add it
after this we are writing this function
called
function
on
resize that is a functioning for me the
one which we are passing into the second
parameter
we are saying let
all cells
equal
to
document
dot
query selector all
in this we are passing
board
underscore
cell
okay and then we're using another option
called what let
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot
of
set width
or
after that we are saying all cells
dot
for each
here we are passing
cell
[Music]
and after that we are using cell
dot
style
height
equal to now he'll be using this
backtick and uses
dollar sign and say
cell
height
and that to you know pixel
so this will be taking the dynamic
values
okay that's it that's it over
now we have to just launch our build
board
now
billboard
build
board so how we gonna build our board
now for this we are saying function
build port
and inside this billboard we will see
this option called let
reset
container equal to
document dot
once again query selected
and pass the value call dot reset
okay and after that we are saying
reset container dot
class list
dot remove
and we are passing the value call
reset hyphen
hidden
this value and after that
we may call some other type of functions
also
okay so for those functions i can say
first will be called on
resize
after that we are calling
add
cell click listener
but i do not have that function with me
these functions we need to create it by
our own
okay so we will just leave those for a
time being let's go back and create
another functions now so we just want to
write another event with self click
event for play to attempt
to make move so
here we're trying to say
cell
click
event
for
player 2
attempt
to make
move
now this function need to create it so
we just say function now
we just say function
and give the name of the function
to make move now
function make
move
it takes
give it as a parameter
and here we are saying console.log
and say
now let's go back and try to check
another condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
percent because you have to read the
value from there and here we are saying
what
event dot
current target
sorry
even dot
current target dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so we're reading these values
after that we use another variable
called
cell to
add
token
now here we are typing document
dot
query selected
and here
you know using backtick
i'm using this value called
data hyphen id
okay equal to
here we are using
once again in a single quotes
dollar
current cell
okay
so this value we are taking it like that
after that we are using this situation
called if
cell
to add token dot
inner html
exterminatory mark
blank
once again if cell to add
token dot inner html
equal to blank
then what next so cell to add token
dot inner html
equal to blank then what you should do
i'm saying console
dot
log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay so
in this console.log what value we can
give it
cell to add token
we have it it is taking this value to
the current set dot inner html
console.log
and inside my console.log we can set
this
cell
is
already
taken
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be
returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
current player
okay
is x
then we'll be using this option called
cell
see we have this property option
available called send to active console
using cell to add token
okay
dot text content
equal to
current player
okay and we say
game board
the one which you created pass in this
keyboard
this value call
current cell
and in this correct cell value will be
equal to
x
okay
else
we can say
send
to add token dot
text content equal to
current player
okay and say
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name for
is winner to check whether the user is
winner or not so we are saying
is
winner
okay and
after that we are saying
turn
plus
after that we are saying
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names okay so it's
just like that we're giving it so as
usual we can leave this function for a
time being
and uh we'll call this little later on
so
leave it as a time
okay so your function is now ready
so the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not okay so we are saying
function
check
if
i
we're just taking the function
whether it is game is tied or not so
here we say
if
the condition is turned
greater than seven
alert
game
over
okay we can say give over first we can
say our type
okay
well after that we are saying winner
function
is winner
now what we will check is we'll check
const
winning sequences
winning sequences and here
sorry
here
we are
having this array and having the
different conditions associated we say 0
2 probability we are checking it
and then i just copy it
well missing 0 1 2 and here is saying
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
and zero three six again
and once again 1 4 7
and next we have a call two five eight
eight
then we are checking the vertical zero
for it
eight and one more last option we'll put
is called two four six
six so these conditions we are adding it
now
after this array we can say
varying sequences start
for each
and give the name call winning combos
winning
combos
and inside this varying compound we are
giving let
cell 1 equal to
varying combos position 0
then
that copy
and paste three times
cell two
cell three
and here we get the other call what
[Music]
we are checking the condition
let's say
if
and here the conditions you're checking
what exactly that would be for the game
board using
game board
set
one
current player
sorry
ampersand time percent
come down
game board
cell 2
i just want to copy this the same line
and paste it multiple times
now here
we are checking the condition for cell 2
and cell 3
and
cell 3
after that
we're starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position call
[Music]
by cutting this condition call
consense
const
sense
and then equal to
dot
get element by or sorry document or
query selector
all
and here let's select the position dot
okay
then after that we will be using
cells
dot
for each
cell
and inside is what we are passing we are
saying
let
cell id equal to
cell dot
first
element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so this is the value which you are
basically adding it now and we're using
one more if condition
we're saying if
cell id
now we're talking about call cell id
triple equal to
cell 1
or
cell id
cell 2
or
salivary equal to
so three
okay and in that case we can use
cell dot
class list
dot
add
and get the name board
just give the class name
winner
so here we'll be giving the winner and a
part of that we can use the other
conditions too
okay so here it is
adding the value and now let's say
let
currentplayer equal to
document dot
get element by id
so you can basically define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current player or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner
now
small change rather than using correct
layer we can use
the current
player text
the new variable we are creating it
current player text document dot rather
than saying get element by id
we can say
query selector
and in this query selector will be
giving the value
by saying dot board
the value which we are giving it here
and that
query selector
value whichever you given this let me
try to put it in a
parenthesis
like this
okay now here we just checked
if current player
x
then what
then in this case we can say
current player what is the value we are
using current text dot
inner html
equal to
now we can define the value whichever
you want to
operate
we just use a condition called div
plus equal to
okay so we are saying congratulations
okay and here you say
congratulations
along with
dollar sign
and here we pass
player
try
dot
name
and here the tip tag is getting closed
like this
okay
so that's the message we are basically
printing it
and after that
we give this value
and say this message call
winner equal to
true
and after that
if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written we'll
be talking about a little later on and
just say return true again
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition if filler
if
winner
or you can say
check
if i
and
return false
that's it
now in our continuation to this example
we're gonna develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
change
board header names
so this change board header names will
be the new function for us and here we
would like to check whether the user is
winner or not so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case you have to say let
current player text equal to
document
dot
query selector in this we'll be getting
the details like dot
or
and here we gonna give the name called
player
and hyphen turn
player hyphen turn
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current player
equal to x if the position is x sorry
let me try to put it in capital letter
here
x
then we will say
currentplayer
dot
inner html equal to
now here we have to just use the same
option called backticks because i want
to go multilines that's the benefit of
this backtick and here we say in our
inner html span
class
equal to
name
hyphen hyphen
style
close this and here
we want to use
the statement
now this
value
we want to write it with name attribute
so it is getting close and here we are
saying dollar
with this player
x
dot
name
and then
close the
span tag
and we say
you are
up
like this
and after that
we say div
class equal to
which is going to create a class which
later on we can apply the css style on
the top of that u hyphen r
hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the div type
so dip tag is closed
that's it and now
after this line
what next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current layer
text
dot inner html
inner html equal to
after this
we gonna write the span
class equal to here we say name
hyphen hyphen same option we're gonna
use it
so in this condition so
winner conditions so let me try to copy
this thing rather than copying it again
and
i'll just copy the whole text
expand class equal to
name hyphen iphone style player rather
than saying x you can use file
you are up you are
winner okay so here it's getting closed
well after this what we need to do
create another function called resupport
function
reset board
now in this function reset board which
is a console.log
a small message
resetting
resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using
the game board
and the same game board what we have
used it earlier
i'll be using the same conditions
on the top
if you remember that was the game code
for me so i'll be using the same
keyboard
to copy this
yeah
with the same condition
okay gameplay coded this after that line
we will say let
sell to add token
send to add token
equal to
document
dot query selector all
here
in this i'll be using
another class called
letter
now cell to add token
whichever we've used dot
for each
square and within this square we would
like to use square
dot
text content
equal to
black
after that square
dot
parent element
class list
dot
remove
and here you would like to say
board
okay underscore underscore
cell
winner so these classes we had to create
because these changes classes were just
using this but we haven't created we'll
be using it little later on
so that was the point
now after that we are defining the turn
value
turn
equal to zero because we are resetting
it and
winner equal to
false
after that winner equal to false we just
define another variable called define
let current player text
current player text equal to
document
dot
query selector all
yeah document query select all
so here
we're gonna use the name called board
define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
current player
text
current player text dot
inner html equal to
once again we have to use the condition
for
up
and winner point
so let me try to copy this
inner html equal to
okay and in this we have to say player x
dot name
okay just everything is same
no change at all
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function called function
add
cell
click
listener that means when i will be
adding
or clicking something to my cell
what kind of event i would like to
listen
here
we are saying const
cells equal to
document
dot
query selected all
let's check
the condition board
board
cell
and here once again we say cell stop for
each
dot for each
and here this is cell
dot
add
event listener
which event i want to listen
click and the second parameter will be
handler
once called
make move
okay and this function which we have
created called add cell clicks listener
okay this i'll be calling it here
perfect
later on once it is done let's try to
add one more function called function
remove
cell
click
listener
remove cell
click listener
now here we say
let
all
cells
equal to
document dot
query selector all
let's pass
board
cell
and now we say
all sets
dot
for each
cell
and here we say cell dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be make
that's it so friends now here
most of our javascript code is written
now
so going forward we would like to use
css
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our html file
well after the javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create our html file now sorry
the css
so
inside my tic tac i have got app.js and
index.html ready now here i'm going to
create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
app.css in either folder like in static
folder but i have just kept it
outside now from this point onwards i
would like to start with my basic
functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called morning
with my body
some basic settings i would like to do
like in background image background
color so i just start with
background color
background color i can just use it as a
white
okay
but i don't think it's really needed it
so if you want you can have it otherwise
leave this background color because it's
by default going to be white only
and now
next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position i just say like
center
next background repeat in case if you do
not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here i say no repeat
next background size
here using cover
okay so it resize the background image
to cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part
now the next thing is we have to select
the
rest of the css classes so first select
div
dot relative
inside this data alternative is first
say call position
position we are saying absolute
next is stop
from the top i'm just making 760 pixels
next
right
right is saying 120 pixels
next
after this we are saying height
container
height
dot
container or sorry hide hyphen container
here in hide hyphen container we will
display
colon
none
well after that we have to use the
header point
header
inside the cell we will say color
will be by default white but still we
just say color
and
white
next text line
we just say center
next margin
margin will be 50 pixels
font family
font family i'm selecting called
permanent marker
permanent
okay next class we are talking about
call interplayer that's called dot
enter
hyphen
players
and enter hyphen players will say color
will once again
we can use another clear but we can just
use white or any color you want
or you can just use
hash
okay
margin
margin we are giving it's called zero
auto width
we're looking forward for 80
next texture line
center position
relative
now
next we're going forward for input field
in this input field we just say border
border two pixels
solid
and black
next
outline
outline none
i do not want any outline to be there
next padding
i can take four pixels
eight pixels
four pixels eight pixels now margin
we are saying zero
10 pixels
okay and finally
for pixels
after this margin we say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field
next we are talking about something
called input field focus
input
hyphen field
okay colon
focus
now here
border
two pixels
solid
right
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want your submit button to be
from saying
dot
submit hyphen btn
border
2 pixels
solid
and black
adding
8 pixels
and again 8 pixels
font size
80 pixels
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
5 pixels
next your margin from top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
let's take
white only
okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate
with your submit button active and
submit button focus so we are saying dot
submit
hyphen
btn
colon
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outline
outline
none
next border
we're talking about 2 pixels
solid
and the color
red okay
so that's the one
and uh after that we like to use over
dot
submit hyphen button
colon
over
what you want
change the background color
to what white
you can use white smoke
well
here we like to use a
dot
board
here we'd like to use player
hyphen
these are the classes we were using in
our javascript we remember
and here we say color
color we are using once again
white or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on
text align
center margin
10 pixels
and 10 pixels
height
pixels okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken
okay so after this
turn let's go and start another classes
here i'm saying dot
name hyphen hyphen
style
and here we are saying color
red
and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about a
next important called border container
called board container dot
board container here we define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 percent we can rather take
after that background colors
that we can say coded blue
okay
next margin
we're taking is zero
and
auto
after that font size
font size we are taking zero
next border
then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
you remember this box shed is one of the
very very season
three popular property here we're
defining three pixels
three pixels
zero pixels
and
rgb
we can talk about called black
okay so my
border color will be shading color will
be
black
after that we're offering this
board cell
dot
now in this board cell we are defining
width
now in this width we are using
calculation
ca lc and in this calculation we are
defining 100
okay divided by three
this calculation
after this
the next property will be display
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well texture line
center border
we are taking
two pixels
solid
and
black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top
next font family
this formula can use permanent
permanent marker
okay
now
next option
a part of this
we have a call
your board circle
board
cell iphone
winner
i would say another iphone i could be
there
no
spelling wrong this has to be d
yeah for cellular
let's make background color
red
okay
and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
white
next position
relative
top
fifty percent
next transform
translate y
to minus 50 percent
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
let me copy
okay
now
here next option will be called winner
container
here we're giving
winner
with dot
dot
winner hyphen
container okay so for this winner
container what are the values we want to
use it
that's you want to basically do it so if
all this winner container what i would
rather suggest is you can use dot
reset
texture line
center
margin
20 pixels
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset heading we will set
display name
display
none
okay after this the replay button
it's yeah now you could talk about
replay button dot
replay hyphen
vta
and here with
we make it
to
okay
and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here
and 20 pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called two
pixels
followed by solid
okay and black color
now later on
border radius
border radius we're taking 5 pixels
later on
outline i'm saying none
after this outline we say letter spacing
now this letter spacing would be again 0
after that
text transform
this text track form value we are
talking about call
uppercase
next font size
font size
we are taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top would be 12 pixels
then word spacing
you are taking three pixels
followed by background color
this you are taking white as usual
so this is for your replay button
okay now in a similar line we can also
have
call dot
replay iphone btn
colon hover
followed by dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
then color
we are making this call white
then background color
will be black
okay
and
when it comes to the congratulations
so we'll be using this
dot
okay
so this congratulations
class will be using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this call
winner dot u
hyphen r
dot
winner
in this winner we will be taking
font
size okay that's 18 pixels
after that height
we are taking 18 pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and then
margin two
pixels and then zero
okay that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this
dot
replay
iphone btn
this i'm saying with 50
percent
so this is what my css file is all set
i know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our css also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file
and take care about the final finishing
touch
so we have this index.html file with us
and now
the css class which we were using it in
our application that is known as call
this
permanent marker this class is not by
default available so we have to include
this
using this external api so here where we
have a call css with us
before that
we want
link
so within this link we want our
variable name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying https
colon double forward slash fonts
dot google apis
okay dot com
slash css
question mark
family
equal to
permanent plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser
you will get to know
where exactly it is using
okay if i just copy and paste it
so i just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts
dot
google apis
dot com
slash
or spelling wrong
css family equal to permanent marker
that is the main url
from where i can take this kind of font
so here
css so that's what i was cross verifying
it
well it's there we have included our css
also but in which class we need to use
that is an important now
js i also want to include it
so
here
in my head tag only
i would like to include
script
src equal to
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if i just go back and check
the
final outcome of my code
which is
index.html file
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about call start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no css class are attached so i need
to attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those css classes so that at
least i can apply
those common behaviors to my application
okay like here we have a call
div
we haven't attached any class to this
after this body we have a part tip h1
class equal to header tic tac toe then
we have a call div we have a call
body
under this we have a call another dev
tag so
just imagine how many type of classes
are available what we have called tip
class equal to header
div class is closed again we have a call
one more div tag so like that multiple
css files are there where we have to
apply the new css class
to make it happen so now we have to just
go back and change our html and to apply
our main class
so this is what my final html which
looks like the same you can see we have
added
all those type of css classes which we
had that is called inter player
player form player container label
placeholder and player container
and if you see all different type of
classes we have attached this to
okay because
here only my css class will get applied
and the javascript will apply those kind
of dynamic css based on certain
conditions so these css classes are
already there added inside your html
page
our app.css is ready
app.js is also ready now let's go back
and try to reveal how it looks like
awesome so it looks like pretty nice
tic-tac-toe is a game it is expecting
when it says start game it says you must
enter a name for each field validation
is working
let me try to add
two names and say start game awesome so
now you can see it is saying a you are
up
now let me try to give the values
awesome now you can see
it's saying like hey you are a winner
great so guys congratulations on this
the first example of how the door game
is used so it is a classical example of
css
javascript and html together so this
time we're going to talk about our next
very interesting feature that is called
dealing with another example that is
called snake game so staying keep is one
of the very very powerful
example which i'm going to share with
you which will help you to understand
like how we offer a very simplest way of
developing a mini project
okay that is something which is a snake
game let's see how the snake game is
important and how we're going to deal
with this
these are our previous examples which we
have seen which i will call a project
which we have created that is called
quiz application and now we're going to
start working with our new project
now here first of all i'm going to
create a new folder
that is called snake
again
and inside this estate game we need some
new
folders
first folder i'm going to create it
inside this that is called images
and
within this snake games i'm going to
create few new files that is called
index
dot html
and here
i'm going to create a new file name
called app
dot js
at the same time i'll be having some of
the css files if i need so i can say
app dot
css so total number of three files i
have it now let me close down all the
files whichever i have opened it earlier
so
now that looks cleaner approach
this is the snake game for us from where
we need to start
and we have index.html file and here i
will i think you will create
our basic html syntax
and
here i would like to include
our script tag
script
src equal to
app.js
that's it and now going forward we will
start developing
our next
implementation of
snaking
now inside my body tag
i would like to have some
basic property called speed
okay and later on i'll be taking the
input from the client so we are saying
input
type equal to
so here we can justify the speed and we
can give id
equal to
gamespeed
and followed by value
equal to we can give the value called 5
initial value
and
min
equal to
1 that is the minimum value
and max equal to 9 that is the maximum
and minimum value we can offer beyond
that i won't allow the users to go
and step
that means the increment value that is
one
well that is the input type and now
another input we are taking
type equal to
button
and
value
equal to
start
and then id equal to
game start
okay so we're giving these values
after that
i can give some
bricks
so two bricks we are giving it and start
working with the div diagonal
and in this div tag i'll be using the
canvas
it is a html5 feature
we use canvas
and i just give id equal to
game
area
there is a canvas and
after this canvas
we will
that tip tag is closed here after the
div tag i can use another tab type
div
here i can say
class equal to
i may not have any class written but i
can say
class equal to related so later on if i
want to apply any css style
i can certainly apply
and after that i can offer the images
okay so i may not have any images right
now so i just leave this image playing
right now
okay and this script src i'll load it
only
before my body get closed it's always a
good practice to keeping this script tag
on the bottom of the body tag always
designed for good practice
now this is almost ready for me let me
check
okay so i can see
values
now it will go maximum nine that is how
we have given and minimum is one start
is the button which not doing anything
but later on we can allow some logic
inside this
now we have to start working with our
main javascript tag
this is my amp.js and here onwards we
will use
some of the properties okay which i want
to initialize it so using var
game
start
equal to none
initialized
second game speed
equal to
next game area
null
game area context
equal to null
then
game area width
game area
width
equal to
zero that is in integer value
game area height
game area
equal to zero again
then solve it
so with equal to
zero play score
equal to zero again
next snake
equal to null
next snake food
next snake direction
equal to null
snake speed or else i can say speed size
speed size
equal to
zero
next we have a timer
equal to
so these number of properties
we've initialized
okay
now after that we will be writing a
function by saying function
name is called initialize
okay and here in initialized
we would like to use some of the
properties
first we are saying
game start equal to
document dot
get element by id
here i can give the value call
hash
game start let me put it in double
quotes
again
start
now game speed now these are all
basically the values are there game
start game speed
these all values we have to take it
okay so we will be seeing these values
one by one so let me set another one
that is called game speed
game speed equal to again
document dot
get element by id now we are passing
the game speed
game
game speed
now
here
once again i take another point game
area
i say game
game area
here you have to give the value called
okay so these values we have taken
now we will be talking about called game
media context
give me the context equal to
game area
dot
get context
okay
and in this game context we will be
using what type of context using 2d
okay because i want to have
the kind of 2d so
this is how the kind of environment we
want to set
next we talk about game area width
equal to just initialize to 400
next
game area height
equal to 600
now solve it
we are initializing with 20
next game area dot width
okay so game area
dot
width equal to
game area width
and then we define k media dot height
dot
equal to
game area height
so these are the values we are
initializing this
okay
now after that we have to start writing
the logic here i'm saying game start
game start
dot now we have to line uh which event
you would like to take so i will say on
click
on
so when i basically click
what should happen so on click equal to
function
so what you want to write it here i am
saying this dot
this dot disabled equal to
true
so i want to disable these values
and after that we want to call
another function inside this
but which function let's do that so here
we are saying function
start game
start
okay
and
here in start game
we want to define the initial score see
the initial score for the player will be
certainly zero so we say
player
score
equal to zero
after that
direction in which direction you want
the snake to move so we are saying snake
direction equal to
right
in the right direction
then speed size
the value also the variable which you've
defined so speed size equal to because
it will be accepting the value
from the text boxes or from the drop
down so it certainly will be string type
so we have to use power send
so we're using this option called power
sent and here we're using
game speed
dot
[Music]
value
okay so we are using this value gain
speed dot value now here we would like
to calculate certain things
what those are first we are saying if
okay
what if condition
uh
see this function we are writing called
start game
because there are certain things which
you need to
make it
so like that we have to define it so
function initialize
we have started
okay and then after that we have written
on click within this
so this is what the on click we had and
there onwards we have to finish this
point
and after that we've started
start game and now we'll be writing the
logic for this so here we are saying if
we're seeing speed size
missing if
a speed size
greater than
in case if it is the value is hard coded
it
then we would like to write the logic
here and what this logic would be it
says if it is greater than 9 we say
speed size
equal to 9
we basically initialize to what 9
here we say else if
speed size
is
zero
say speed size
sorry
speed size
equal to 1
that means if it is less than 0 i will
be making it minimum to one if it is
greater than nine i'll be making it to
nine maximum
and that's it
okay
so after this else if condition
is getting closed we are seeing speed
size equal to
one
so here we just say snake
snake equal to
array so that is my array for me and
after that we are saying snake
dot push
because it needs to move ahead and here
we'll be pushing it towards
by saying
x
position
and
then the y
and here the y value will be what
celebrate that means how far it can go
so it will go within the width of this
application
okay so that's how exactly we would like
to make it
okay so here we have a call cell width
which we have given here
after that what we have to do is
we have to define our own function
called
clear interval
and this clear interval perform any
logic whichever i would like to make it
okay so here after that snake dot push
value has been given
here i will be creating one more
function here
that is known as call
create food okay so here
we're saying
create
food
so create food will be the function for
me now you might be thinking where this
function is but this function will be
declared soon within your application
but here first we are seeing the
function called clear interval
clear interval
with the timer
[Music]
okay whatever the timer will be passing
it
and after that
this clearing treble will be saying
timer
equal to
set interval
with this we're saying create game area
now
here in our application whatever the
value we are giving it that we need to
basically implement
so
here we are giving this call create food
is a function we are calling after that
we are calling this clear interval
cleaner will be just like in a typical
function which is there after that we
are using this option called create game
area
so
this will be available to me on which
the value will be taken that
okay and then we will be telling you
how you can call this function create
food and how to create it first well so
we are talking about a functionality
called create game interval so this
create game
timer is the one which we have to create
it by our own so this
function which we are passing it after
the saying set interval
this function is not yet there so we
have to basically go back and create
this function within my application
fine so
what we will do is just particular one
we will try to comment it for a time
being
okay so here we have a call what create
interval
in this great interval we'll be
passing any parameters which we are
passionate about as a timer here and
here we are calling this call create
food
so here after that we'll be calling this
function called create food so let's go
and say
function create food
in this function create food let's go
and write a logic here
and what logic we want to write it in a
create food we say snake food
snake food equal to
and here in our curling bases we use two
direction x and y
we say in x we say math dot
around
and inside this we say
math
dot
random
after this math.random function we have
to just take this calculation
and check the another parameter called
game area with
game
area width
minus
cell with the one which you are passing
it and here after that we'll be
performing the calculation by saying
cell bit
okay so this is for our x coordinate
similarly we would like to use for my y
coordinate also
now
math dot round round dot number game
area
game area height
but
here rather than using width we'll be
using height
minus
solve it let me give some space
divided by cell width
okay so that's where exactly it's got
closed
okay
now here
our applications is now ready by calling
the function called create4
like that we'll be going to create
another function called create game area
let me go and create all the functions
first so you're saying
function create game area
create
game
area there's another function for me
after this create game area there will
be another function i'm going to create
it
that is called control
function control
okay after that we will write one more
function called function
right score
there's another function available for
us control we have a call write score
there's another function which is going
to write it down here that is called
function
right score is done now we say create
square
create
this is another function
and finally we'll have a call change
direction
function
change
direction
so that's it so these many functions we
wanted to create it
here in our system
well
we know very well that we have taken
this call create food grade food
function is already ready now now we're
going to talk about our next function
called create gain area and in this
great game area we are defining two
location var x direction and y
interaction so we say
snake
x
equal to
snake the position we are taking is
called 0 and we are saying dot x
for the x direction
we are saying var
snake
y equal to
position we are taking once again zero
and
dot y so two directions we have taken x
direction and y direction
now here we are starting
game
area
context dot
fill style that unit very well it is a
property
fill style
equal to which color you want to fill
this up
so i'm saying hash white color
okay and then we are using this game
area context again
dot fill react
fill react
now keep the position values i'm saying
0 comma 0
so we are basically filling the values
with color we want to use it called
stroke style let me take the game area
context again
dot
stock style
stroke style
equal to now we give the another color
here
by saying hash
okay and then the next option called
same
gave me the context dot stroke react
stroke
react and here we pass the values again
comma
game area width
game
area
height
so we are passing those values like that
and now after this we have to write a
logic
of the directions
now see the when you talk about snake
game it move left right and center
up and down so now in this case we have
to increment the situations accordingly
so we say if the snake direction
if the snake direction
go to
right
then we say snake
x plus plus
now
else if
same
let's copy this
snake direction
left
then what should happen
here we say
snake
x
minus minus
okay so we're taking like that let me
copy this again
now here
here we're talking about left right we
set down
so in this case we say snake
y
plus plus
and in this case
if it is up
then we say snake
y
minus minus
so these conditions we are taking it now
now here after this else if condition we
would like to take another if condition
now here in my if condition
we are
using some more lengthy statements
what's that we say
f snake
x if snakes x
-1
or
snake x
double equal to
game
area
width which we have taken
divided by
cell width
okay or
we are taking this condition called
snake y
snake y double equal to
minus one
okay so we're giving this call minus one
or
snake y
let's take y equal to
gain area height
to save it
or
here we will take the another condition
here
yeah we will take the another condition
here call
we will have another function called
control
which we have
created it some time back and inside
this control
it will take some parameters so what
those parameters we can pass and we can
say
snake
x
comma
snake y
third parameter will be
stick
so this could be my another function
okay
so here we are passing the conditions
just like that
okay now here
this is
available to use a parenthesis
and here
we're writing the situation for write
score
which is so far the function is only
created not
described more so we're writing the
right score the score will be written
here
and here we are saying clear interval
the timer will be stopped
okay and using game start
dot
disabled
equal to
false
and after that
return
that's it
so this is the logic for we have written
to this particular example
now we can use
another if more conditions here just to
check the behavior of my code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
well here we have finished this
game start dot disabled equal to false
and we returned
now
going forward after this return
we would like to have another condition
for the snake x so we say if
snake x
if a snake x double equal to
snake food
tortex
okay snake foot cortex
ampersand perfect
snake
y
double equal to
snake
food dot
y
then in this case i will say
var new head
here
x
colon
snake x
snake these options we are taking it
now
after that we are using this option
called player score
plus
equal to
speed size
and then we are calling
create food method again
and here after that we're using the else
condition
and in this else condition
we are saying var
new head
equal to
snake
dot pop
okay and we are saying new head
dot x
equal to snake x
and new head
dot y equal to
snake
y
so these values are basically
associating with your heads and after
that we are saying snake
dot unshift
and shift
snake dot and shift and here we are
passing this option called new head
that's it and after that we'll be
starting with our for loop by saying
for
var equal to
r i
i equal to 0
then
i
is
less than
snake
dot
length
and
snake dot length and once i
plus plus
okay later on we just use the option
called
create
square and in discrete square we are
passing
snake
snake position
i
dot
x
comma
same
snake
dot y
that's it
so it's getting closed here and after
that we are calling the same option
with this snake food let me copy this
again
and here rather than
using this we can say snake food dot x
and it's like foot dot y
okay so
now this values has been added
into my code now let me start working
with your control
control needs to take three parameters
x y and the array so we are passing this
option called control and in this
control we are taking x
comma y
comma
array
three parameters we are taking it later
on we are using this option called for
plus plus and after that we'll be using
this option called if condition and here
we say
array
i
which value you're passing dot x
double equal to
x
ampersand time percent
here we say array
with a position called i
and in this we are saying dot y and this
position we are checking for
the y condition
for the y condition so it returns what
true
written
the condition
okay that is for if condition else
return was
false
now that's it now we are talking about
this option name called write score
this right score we have to use the game
area context
game
area context dot
font
equal to
here we'll be passing the situation
we're saying 50 pixels
50 pixels and then
sense
hyphen
service
after that we're using called game area
context again let me copy this
take it again call game area context
dot
fill style equal to here i'll be using
another color now
so we say hash
okay
now after that we are saying once again
the game area context
dot fill
text
here we are saying
score
colon
and here we say
plus
player score whatever it is
with game area width
game area width
slash
minus
and then
again
game area with
slash 2. so this is where exactly the
right score where the data will be
actually written
okay next we'll be having this option
called create square at this great
square it takes two parameters one we're
talking about called x
second is taking y
and now here
we're using this game area context
same
dot
fill style
equal to let me give the color
after this
we're using same gary and text
game media text dot
fill react
here we are saying x
multiplied by
cell width comma
y
multiply by
cell width
comma
cell width comma
cell width
this is what my grade square is now we
are left with only one option that is
known for change direction
it's time to figure out this last
function called change direction
which takes one parameter called e
typically we talk about for
parameters
now here we are passing this option
called workkeys
equal to e dot
and later on we want to say if
keys
equal to
okay
ampersand ampersand
snake direction
equal to
up
okay so here we say
snake direction
equal to
down so we are changing the directions
here
okay now let me try to copy this
[Music]
and here we use elsev
four times
okay
so here we talk this
30 40 and here we say 39
and followed by 38
followed by 37
39 38 37
and here we say up
let's change to what
left
down
right
here we say
up
left so three options we have changed
and last but not least here
i will just use
window dot
on key down
equal to
change directions
and
window
dot
on load
okay equal to
initialize
that's how exactly we want to use now
and this function what we have defined
in initialize
okay
so in this initialize
we are having this gamestar dot on
clicking and all so you have a call
start game now
this start game will be calling it here
okay so in start
we were called snake we have called
snake dot push and after that we are
calling
this function called what
create food
clear interval and here we say
timer equal to
here set clear interval and here
change
game area
slash
speed
size
let's say you want to use it
okay everyone so our code is almost
ready so we have this complete
javascript code ready with me
now it's time to basically use within my
html
just to check
how it may behave
so in my html page
i have written this
normal speed
number
game speed value
button start we will call game start
after that we have a call canvas where
we can id call game area
depth classic to relative
and
that's it and here we have a call script
sr is equal to app.js
so that's it what we have written now
finally we would like to see how it may
look if i try to use in my browser let
me try to refresh
okay
i really do not see any changes in my
code
okay
despite i'm having this because the css
content is actually missing
okay because then only my code really
look
better
because if there is no css it wouldn't
really make
good towards my application
okay and i also want to have certain
images but those images we will take it
later on let me go back and try to bring
css into this picture now so first of
all
have this
index.html file with me
and here i want to use css so inside my
head tag
we want to use
link
real
equal to
style sheet
okay href
equal to
app
dot
css
okay
now
here
in my css we want to offer certain
details
what those details i want to start
working with i will start with my body
part
body
so we want to offer
the font family
so
font family may be little bit later on i
can use it first i want to use margin
margin 20 pixels
auto
later text
align
center
next font size
font size 150 pixels
also 150
and here we want to say background
background image
since i do not have any image so i will
just leave it as a blank
okay so just otherwise i have to say url
and insert this url
it gives some values but i leave it as a
blank because i do not have any image
i will say background color
in this background color i can just use
white
after that height
i can just say 800 pixels
after that
background position
background position i want to use center
then background repeat
background repeat i want no repeat
then background size
okay let's see if there's an effect in
my
okay i see it's now
in the middle
better
now
inputs canvas we have to basically take
that here we just talk about call input
okay in this input i say font size
font size may be optional i can
make it
but let me just say font size 100
percent then text align
center
then padding
i want to say 5 pixels
and seven pixels
okay looks better now
well here after that i can use canvas
and this canvas i want to see the
background color
i just say white
after that border radius
border radius i can say 20 pixels
then
shadow if i want to use it
so i just say box shadow
box shadow i can say 3 pixels
5 pixels
and 6 pixels
and the color is
black
let's
check awesome
so i can see here
uh
the
logic is there so shadow you can easily
see how it has been using
and
that's it and this div
let us say div
dot
relative
position
absolute
top
here i'm saying using 760 pixels
left
120 pixels
that's it
so this is where exactly
i program now when i say start
okay so there may be some error here
let's say cannot set a property of call
on click
null
so this we can just check this into this
gamestop.onclick
let's check
anyways
we just try to fix that issue in a
while
but anyways we have our created css and
now going forward will be implementing
the rest of the logic within my code
okay everyone so we have changed some
names here because there was some value
was mismatched so we have basically
changed those values
with your properties and now when i try
to relaunch my application
by
this
index.html file
so now in my index.html file when i try
to add
so
it's just as usual same let me say start
and here you can see game start when i
go up you see like it's starting right
now
okay isn't this an amazing game right
now friends
okay that is the same game what you used
to play earlier okay where you can just
change the direction
go up and you can see the score title
being placed here
that's it so this is where exactly the
look and feel of your game has been
taken
and you can just increase the speed
suppose if you just put a value call
what zero
by default set
whatever value you want to take it with
a start now you can see
based on that the speed can be justified
and the example can be developed
okay you can see the start button is
disabled because right now the user is
still going on unless the user game is
finished this one is not going to work
right so like that you can see and
automatically this will be positioned
this is what's called food that is how
we have used in my example now called
app.js you can see we're using this
example name called food
create food so in create food of the
specific interval time this would be
automatically created and the snake will
eat and increase the size of the code
okay that's it and now the css has been
given if you want to add certain image
certainly you can add it otherwise this
is the first game which we can see how
it is running and giving you the better
example and so with that we come to the
end of this full course tutorial if you
enjoyed watching it make sure to hit the
subscribe button and the bell icon to
never miss an update thank you so much
for being here watch out for more videos
from us until then keep learning and
stay tuned to simply learn